bonsoir à tous bienvenue et merci
d'abord d'avoir choisi les chaînes
parlementaires pour votre soirée donc du
premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle nous sommes ensemble pour
une longue nuit électorale et bien sûr à
partir de 20h vous connaîtrez
l'estimation l'ordre d'arrivée des
candidats avec moi j'ai le plaisir
d'avoir Émilie auri bonsoir Émilie pour
une soirée qui s'annonce donc très très
riche très riche très chaud bonsoir
Michel bonsoir à vous merci
effectivement de nous avoir choisi ce
soir pour cette grande soirée électorale
20h on l'a dit c'est l'heure qu'on
attend tous pour vous donner les
résultats candidat par candidat et
surtout le grand duel qui s'annonce pour
le 2e tour vous pourrez suivre sur notre
antenne toutes les grandes déclarations
des candidats en direct et puis on
essaiera de de vous faire vivre le plus
possible les ambiances dans lesqg
évidemment ce soir toutes nos équipes
sont sur le pont à commencé par Michell
zamz bonsoir Michel qui passe sa soirée
au siège du Parti socialiste rut de sol
Ferrino Johann Rolla quant à lui et
qu'on salue aussi est à Tul Tul ou à
voté où est encore François Hollande
Germain Andriot est à la Mutualité
grande salle du 5e arrondissement de
Paris loué ce soir par l'UMP Mathilde
terrier nous parlera du Front national
elle est à salle Équinox dans le 15e
arrondissement de Paris pierrehenry
gergon lui nous parlera du Front de
gauche le front gauche qui se retrouve
ce soir place stalingrade toujours le
plein air et une place évidemment
symbolique quant à Marie bremau elle est
au modem rue de l'Université Michel sans
oublier bien sûr Émilie les analyses les
commentaires tout le recul nécessaire
avec une trentaine de personnalités qui
vont ce soir défiler sur notre plateau
et puis bien sûr il y a le web car on le
sait il va s'en passer il se passe déjà
beaucoup de choses sur la toile ce soir
les tweets les réseaux sociaux et c'est
Caroline Deschamp qui suivra cela pour
nous elle aura ses tweets favoris ses
perles du net elle sera notre vigie en
quelque sorte alors évidemment vous
l'avez dit il se passe beaucoup de
choses ce soir et déjà depuis quelques
heures sur la toile sur internet mais
pas question bien sûr pour nous de vous
donner le moindre résultat avant 20h
CIVIS mais respect des règles obligent
on est en effet encore en train de voter
hein dans certains bureaux de vote en
revanche voici les seuls chiffres que
nous sommes autorisés à vous communiquer
ils sont importants estimations pour
l'abstention avec nos partenaires soci
logica Business Consulting France
télévision et radio France voici donc le
premier chiffre de l'abstention pour
cette présidentielle 2012
19,7 % un chiffre qu'on va tout de suite
comparer Michel avec les dernières
présidentielles effectivement puisque
par rapport à 2002 et à 2007 on
s'aperçoit que il y a toujours une forte
participation contrairement à certains
chiffres qui avaient été avancés par
certains instituts de sondage on compare
notamment par rapport à 2002 de
évidemment mais par rapport à 2007
certes une participation euh un peu
moindre mais quand même une forte
mobilisation des électeurs ce soir on a
tout de suite demandé à nos premiers
invités de nous commenter ces chiffres
les deux présidents des chaînes
parlementaires sont bien sûr présents
avec nous je les salue tous les deux
Gilles Leclerc et Gérard Leclerc notre
éditorialiste Denis jeanar et puis
Fabienne Simon d'Ipso c'est vous bien
sûr à qui on va donner la parole en
premier donc très bonne participation
finalement contrairement à tout ce qui a
été dit ces derniers jours et ces
dernières heures effectivement très bon
niveau de participation un petit peu en
DESS des scrutins de 1974 80 et du
record de 2007 mais un très bon niveau
de de participation on avait identifié
dans nos enquêtes préélectorales un
certain nombre de leviers de la
mobilisation que ce soit sur le vote
utile que ce soit des votes d'adhésion
pour un certain nombre de de candidats
et manifestement voilà ces leviers ont
fonctionné à plein aujourd'hui et les
Français sont déplacés un premier
commentaire Gilles Lecler sur et bien on
va pas parler de ruer dans les zones
mais quand même hein oui ce qui est
intéressant pour pour compléter euh
toutes les élections intermédiaires ont
relevé une une une véritable baisse une
désaffection des Ies de la part des
citoyens en revanche il se confirme bien
que l'élection présidentielle et bien
l'élection Ren l'élection préférées des
Français les Français les citoyens
aujourd'hui ont rempli leur devoir CIVI
manifestement pour eux c'est l'élection
Rennes l'élection clé de notre vie
démocratique ils l'ont confirmé
aujourd'hui et pourtant Gérard on a pu
lire hein ces dernier jour que cette
n'avait pas abordé les vrais thèmes
qu'elle ne suscitait pas un enthousiasme
délirant VO et bien il faut le dire
c'est la première surprise première
grosse surprise de cette soirée qui peut
sans doute en amener d'autres parce que
s'il y a plus de gens qui votent que ce
qui était prévu ça peut sans doute
modifier ce qui était ce qui était un
peu annoncé et puis effectivement ça t
le coup à tout ce qu'on a pu entendre
sur campagne qui pe enthousiasm qui
n'intéresse pas les les les Français bah
c'est pas tout à fait vrai voilà plus de
80 % c'est un beau score avant de donner
la parole à à vous Denis bien sûr on a
tout de suite envie de savoir un peu
quelle est l'ambiance dans les les
différents lieux clés de cette soirée je
vous propose tout de suite de retrouver
Johann rela il est Tul bonsoir Johann
alors petite description de l'ambiance
autour de
vous bonsoir Émilie je vous entendez
parler de l'abstention François Hollande
ici à Thul évidemment à voté attendez
j'ai un problème dans l'orillet donc je
l'enlève il a voté en compagnie de son
épouse Valérie trerweiler aux environs
de 10h avant de se lancer contrairement
à certains candidats dans un dans un
dans une tournée des bu de vote assez
effrainé Tul et ses environs beaucoup de
de bureaux de vote pour disait-il tâer
le terrain prendre un peu la température
comme il le fait avant chaque
confrontation électorale peut-être aussi
pour montrer son ancrage local par
opposition au président Nicolas Sarkozi
qui lui votait à Paris donc on a vu
beaucoup de de poignets de main
d'embrassad de tutoimement de messages
d'encouragement venu d'électeurs dont
François Hollande bien souvent
connaissait le prénom puis François
Hollande a déjeuner dans un restaurant
de la ville où il a ses habitudes avant
cette fois-ci de passer aux choses
sérieuses 18h conseil général de corz
François Hollande et toutes ses troupes
se sont donné rendez-vous pour une
veillée d'armes ils y sont toujours
actuellement euh une veillée d'armes
évidemment pour analyser les résultats
qui tombent au fur et à mesure et puis
une veillée d'arme aussi pour préparer
laallocution qu'il prononcera dans
quelques minutes juste derrière moi ici
dans ce gymnase une allocution euh à la
laqu il met la dernière main
actuellement en compagnie d'aquilino
Morel sa plume celui qui lui a écrit de
nombreux discours de campagne qu'il
devrait prononcer vers 20h30 nous ditons
avant de prendre son envol pour Paris et
effectivement de de regagner la capitale
en fin de soirée c'est ce qu'on nous a
dit de la fin du programme de François
Hollande merci Johan alors vous êtes
dans la salle de presse en quelque sorte
François Holland va prendre la parole
dans un instant on n'arrive pas à lire
sur les visages on ira rut Solferino ou
peut-être que là et bien les expressions
seront plus parlantes en attendant
voyons ce qui se passe du côté de l'UMP
puisque l'UMP a mobilisé ce soir la
salle de la Mutualité à Paris et c'est
Germain andriilleux qui se trouve sur
place Germain
oui oui bonsoir et bien effectivement la
salle de la Mutualité est déjà rempli et
continue de se remplir les militants AFF
flu alors il y a bien quelques cris de
Nicolas Sarkozi président mais la
plupart des visages et bien qu'on a vu
sont plutôt tendus et concentrés en
attendant les résultats définitifs avant
le verdict des ur alors quels que soi
ses résultats et bien les militants
veulent se tourner vers le second tour
veulent croire et bien que les cartes
seront rebattues un seul scénario je ne
vous le cache pas était attendu ici
celui d'un Nicolas Sarkozi en tête de ce
premier tour pour relancer une dynamique
de campagne pour le moment on attend
évidemment les chiffres officiels
Nicolas Sarkozi lui est pour le moment à
l'Élysée il a commencé par s'entourer et
bien de son staff de campagne le plus
proche et plus proches collaborateurs
comme Nathalie cochuscooriset sa
porte-parole Franck l'ouvrier son
conseiller en communication Guillaume
Lambert son directeur de campagne ou
encore Henry Guenot et bien sûr Patrick
Buisson ils ont été rejoint par François
Fillon Jean-François Copé Xavier
Bertrand Nicolas Sarkozi devrait
attendre et bien le résultat officiel à
la télévision à 20h avant de se déplacer
ici à la Mutualité pour un discours mais
pas avant 21h et bien merci pour toutes
ces informations Germain andriux alors
on a vu déjà avec vous quelques images
du vote cet après-midi de Nicolas
Sarkozi accompagné de sa femme Carla
brunny je propose justement de revoir un
peu tous les votes des grandes
personnalités aujourd'hui c'est des
images qu'on aime bien voir les soirs
d'élection Joakim Rob les a réunis pour
nous François berou matinale des 10
candidats en Liss c'était le premier à
voter ce matin à PO c'est un jour très
important parce que c'est au premier
tour que se joue l'élection
présidentielle François Hollande a lui
accompli son devoir électoral dans son
fief de Thul en corz don il préside
encore le conseil général le candidat du
Parti socialiste était avec sa compagne
Valérie
trweiler également accompagné de son
épouse Nicolas Sarkozi a voté en fin de
matinée dans le 16e arrondissement de
Paris le président candidat s'est
ensuite offert un petit bain de
foule au même moment eva jolie votait
dans le 14e arrondissement de la
capitale c'est le bout d'un très long
parcours qui a commencé pour moi il y a
16 mois
donc c'est beaucoup c'est beaucoup
d'effort c'est beaucoup de ouais c'est
et c'est un grand travail collectif vote
à Paris également pour Jacques Cheminade
et pour Jean-Luc Mélenchon le candidat
du Front de Gauche a rempli son devoir
républicain dans une école élémentaire
du 10e arrondissement c'est pas la
première fois que je
moi la candidate du front National
Marine Le Pen a voté à ainbaaumont dans
le Pas de
Calais quant à Nicolas dupontaignnan
c'est en famille avec sa femme et sa
fille qu'il a voté à hier en région
parisienne Bill dont il est le maire
Nathalie to candidate de Lutte Ouvrière
a voté à venvelin dans la banliu
Lyonnaise tandis que Philippe Poutou
glissait son bulletin dans une urne à
Bordeaux voilà Denis jambar est
également avec nous on vous l' a
présenté tout à l'heure bonsoir un mot
vous vouliez réagir bien sûr à cette
participation plus de 80 % Oui pour
confirmer ce qui a été dit c'estàd que
on voit bien que c'est l'élection de
référence que ça dém en effet tous les
commentaires médiatiques pas sur les
chaînes parlementaires mais selon lesqu
les Français s'intéressai pas à cette
élection s s'intéressaient ils
s'intéressent à cette élection et ça et
ça montre que en effet les Français on
rapport quand même toujours très fort à
la politique très fort à la politique
alors question qu'on vous pose à tous ce
soir qu'est-ce que vous allez regarder
avec attention lorsqu'à 20h on va voir
tous les résultats Fabien Simon il y a
bien sûr la question du duel dans quel
ordre et puis la trème place dites-nous
un petit peu ce qu'il faut regarder
précisément les questions clés les trois
questions clés qu'il faudra vraiment
regarder avec attention c'est tout
d'abord le niveau du bloc de gauche on
le sait en fonction du niveau de bloc de
gauche au premier tour le candidat voilà
de gauche qui sera sélectionné Surel
justement pour qu'on a un repère disons
que traditionnellement dans l'histoire à
45 % et plus le candidat de la gauche
n'a jamais perdu l'élection
présidentielle 45% on va le garder en
tête voilà en dessous c'est encore c'est
encore un bon chiffre mais
évidemment voilà le challenge est plus
difficile deè indicateur clé c'est
l'ordre d'arrivée évidemment même si
c'est un indicateur qui est davantage
symbolique qu'arithmétique il est
notamment important pour Nicolas Sarkozi
puisque à ce jour aucun des présidents
de la 5e République qui s'est représenté
à ces successions n'est arrivé au 2è
n'est arrivé 2e au premier tour donc ce
serait particulièrement une situation
particulièrement délicate pour lui et
enfin troisème indicateur évidemment ce
sont les niveaux des candidats qui ne
seront pas sélectionnés les 3e 4e ou 5e
homme qui feront en grande partie le le
deuxè tour en fonction des des reports
de voix qui se prod que vous avez
calculé que vous avez déjà estimer et
qui peuvent bien sûr évoluer dans
l'entre d' tour ce sera tout l'enjeu
pour les différents candidats déjà très
bien de nous avoir donné ces grands
fondamentaux qu'on va garder
précieusement dans nos têtes en
attendant on continue de sonder un peu
l'ambiance dans les différents QG je
vous propose de retrouver tout de suite
Michel zames qui passe sa soirée au
siège du Parti socialiste rut sol ferino
bonsoir Michel racontez-nous un peu
l'ambiance autour de vous à 19h42
bonsoir Michel et à 19h42 ce que je peux
vous dire c'est que tout se passe à
l'extérieur ici Rud de Solférino la rue
a été coupée de long en large il y a des
centaines et des centaines de milliers
de personnes qui sont attendu des
centaines qui attendent actuellement
avec les drapot de François Hollande en
ce
qu'entend françois hollande président et
ici à l'intérieur de la rue de Solferino
il y a je peux vous annoncer un bureau
national extraordinaire qui est à lieu
lieu en ce moment même avec la majeure
partie
de la direction du Parti socialiste et
nous avons regardé les mines très
attentivement et pour la première fois
nous avons vu des visages plutôt
décontracté de la part de ces dirigeants
du Parti socialiste il y a je peux vous
le dire 400 journalistes accrédités 200
journalistes de la presse étrangère et
de nombreux invités people on a croisé
tout à l'heure je peux vous donner les
noms Eva d'arl Régis Varnier par exemple
ou encore Gérald ahan un comicque
peut-être que vous connaissez un
imitateur qui va sûrement nous rejoindre
au cours de la soirée très bien et ben
écoutez on aura l'occasion de se
distraire peut-être on va aller voir ce
qui se passe du côté du Front national
on essaie toujours de scruter les
visages évidemment parce que des
chiffres circulent on vous le cache pas
Mathilde terrier est donc dans la salle
éekinox dans le 15e arrondissement où le
Front national réunit ses partisans ce
soir et oui pour l'AMB pour l'instant
l'ambiance est assez calme Jean-Marie Le
Pen lui-même confié être serein confiant
pas un mot en revanche pour Marine Le
Pen qui est arrivée ici vers les 17h
elle est ensuite rentrer au premier
étage de cette salle en réunion car ce
soir la pression est énorme sur les
épaules de la candidate objectif et bien
pour sa première campagne faire mieux
que son père et son score historique de
2002 de 16,86 % Marine Le Pen qui confie
elle-même et ben qu'un résultat en
dessous serait un recul autre enjeu ce
soir et bien être la 3è femme de cette
élection et privée son adversaire son
rival de l'autre extrême Jean-Luc
Mélenchon de la 3e marche du podium
alors on a vu ici tous les membres du
bureau politique arrivé euh Gilbert
Collard Bruno goldnich mais aussi euh la
mère de Marine Le Pen Pierrette Le Pen
la candidate elle devra s'exprimer quel
que soit le résultat derrière moi ici à
21h merci beaucoup mathde pour ces
précisions vous êtes donc euh à Paris
vous aussi dans lesqg on essaie de vous
faire vivre l'ambiance on l'a dit de de
scruter euh les visages peut-être un mot
de commentaire autour de cette table sur
la recherche de la 3e place de njambar
mais c'est pas tellement le le la trè
place c'est le le score du 3e et en
effet selon que c'est Jean-Luc mélochon
ou Marine Le Pen ça ça nous permet de
tirer des conclusions sur le potentiel
de 2è tour de ceux qui arrivent en en en
première ou en seconde position là on n
pas encore le possibilité de donner
l'ordre d'arrivée mais c'est vrai qu' je
dire par plus de franis s les sondages
étaient quand même en dehors des marches
d'erreurs pour ce qui était les deux
premiers grand en ou en plus de ce qui a
été dit excellemment dit celui qui
arrivera premier c'est quand même un
avantage parce qu'il y a une dynamique
qui se crée à partir du premier tour
donc ça c'est important et puis
également l'écart entre le premier et le
2è et puis effectivement très important
aussi le score des autres parce que quel
que soit le candidat vous allez pas
faire la même campagne du 2uxème tour
suivant que vous avez un Front national
Très Haut ou plus Bas François beayou
qui finalement réussit un bon score ou
au contraire
et la clé du deè tour va être dans
quelques instants connaî les Scor des
uns et des autres avant de partir au
front de gauche placealrade un tout
petit mot de commentaire parce que vous
êtes tous des observateurs aviser autour
de cette table comment vous l'avez vécu
vous Gilles Leclerc cette campagne de
premier tour on a beaucoup dit on n pas
suffisamment parlé des vrais thèmes on n
pas parlé d'Europe on n pas parlé
d'économie on n pas parlé
d'environnement en même temps on voit
aujourd'hui cette participation vous
comment vous la définiriez la résumeriez
cette campagne de premier tour je pense
qu'il faut écouter les Français et je
dirais que le niveau d'abstention qui
est relativement faible ce soir euh
démontre en fait tout ce que disait très
bien Denis tout à l'heure c'est que en
effet cette campagne contrairement à ce
que certains racontaient a intéressé les
les les Français on a parlé de beaucoup
de sujets on a parlé d'économie on a
parlé de thèmees ardu quelque fois on a
parlé de thème peut-être un peu jugés un
peu secondairire mais visiblement cette
campagne électorale a intéressé les
Français et sans doute que la la fin de
dans ces derniers jours les enjeux ont
été vraiment bien compris de la part des
Français ce que je voudrais juste
ajouter sur les les scores des numéro 3
4 ou 5 qui vont être quand même les
leviers et les clés importantes du
second tour quels étaient les objectifs
par exemple d'une marine Le Pen c'est
dégaler ou dépasser par exemple le score
de son père en 2002 je le rappelle 16,8
% c'est bien à retenir euh le score
évidemment de Jean-Luc Mélenchon on
rappelle quand même que Marie-George
Buffet c'était 1,9 en 2007 et puis quel
était l'enjeu pour François berou c'est
de sans doute réaliser un score à deux
chiffres il sait ce soir probablement
qu'il n'atteindra pas le très bon score
qu'il avait réalisé en 2007 mais score à
de chiffres ou pas c'est un des points
d'interrogation que nous connaîtrons
évidemment quelques minutes encore à à
patienter Fabien vous vouliz ajouter un
motou sur la mobilisation ce qui me
paraît important de souligner c'est
c'est vrai que le le ressort n'a sans
doute pas été en 2012 le ressort
traditionnel de l'enthousiasme mais bien
davantage le ressort d'une forme de
gravité c'estàdire que les Français euh
ont intériorisé désormais les enjeux et
les contraintes de la médialisation des
marchés et cetera et cetera ils ont pris
conscience sans doute que le pouvoir
politique ne peut peut pas ne peut pas
tout donc ils se sont sans doute moins
mobilisés effectivement sur un
enthousiasme comme on a pu le vivre dans
d'autres campagnes que sur un mode
finalement assez grave dans lequel ils
attendent moins des promesses que des
solutions d' cette absence de ferveur
qui a été constaté effectivement lors
des
derniè il y avait du monde mais pas
cette ferveur et du monde pour regarder
les émissions de télévision dépêche que
vous vouliez que la Commission des
sondages en effet décidé de saisir le
parquet de la publication anticipé de
résultats puisque certains chiffres
effectivement tournent déjà y compris
dans certains médias mais également bien
sûr vous l'avez compris sur Internet
sauf chez nous sauf chez évidment très
et très et très sur sur la Chaîne
Parlementaire parlementaire se devait de
respecter la loi évidemment priorité aux
images et à ce qui se passe à
l'extérieur on retrouve maintenant tout
de suite pierenri gergon PL stalingrade
pour sentir un petit peu l'ambiance du
côté du Front de Gauche bonsoir
pierrehenri
B r on l' peut-être oublié mais c'était
ici même place la lineegrade que
Jean-Luc Mélanchon avait tenu son tout
premier meeting de candidat du Front de
Gauche à cette présidentielle c'était en
juin 2011 Jean-Luc Mélanchon qui a donc
choisi cette même place
stalingrade pour vivre cette soirée de
premier tour de la présidentielle dans
les mêmes conditions qu'il avait mené
l'ensemble de sa campagne au cours des
mois et de ces dernières semaines alors
bien sûr il n'y a pas l'affluence qu'on
a pu rencontrer à la Bastie à Toulouse
ou encore à Marseille la configuration
des lieux ne s'y prête pas néanmoins ils
sont vous le voyez derrière moi
extrêmement nombreux ces militants ces
sympathisants venus ce soir écouter
Jean-Luc Mélenchon alors l'ambiance et
bien vous la voyez les gens attendent et
ils attendent dans le calme ils ont
bravé la météo qui était un peu
menaçante tout à l'heure mais qui
visiblement s'est remis au beau fixe il
y a quelques minutes on continue à
distribuer les derniers drapeaux
Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui est actuellement
présent sur ce site de la place
stalingrade vous le voyez derrière moi
il y a une estrade il n'y a pas de
groupes musicaux cette fois-ci j'allais
dire pour chauffer la salle uniquement
une tribu nous devrons s'exprimer au
cours de cette soirée Martine Billard ou
encore Clémentine Autin Pierre Laurent
pour le parti communiste quant à
Jean-Luc Mélenchon il devrait s'exprimer
très rapidement après 20h aux alentours
peut-être de
20h05 pour donner euh ses premières
réactions après la publication la
divulgation officielle de ces fameux
résultats du premier tour de la
présidentielle vous avez raison de le
dire et 9 minutes hein encore attendre
on vous donnera tous les résultats 19h51
le suspense est total puisqu'on parlait
du du Front de gauche un mot de
commentaire avec vous sur la campagne
qu'a mené Jean-Luc Mélenchon chouchou
des médias on l'a beaucoup dit phénomène
Mélenchon c'est ce qu'on a dit ces
dernières semaines le talent le talent
de Jean-Luc Mélanchon c'est d'avoir
réussi à disons rassembler la la gauche
radicale mais quand on regarde
l'histoire politique française toutes
les élections depuis 20 ans en réalité
il n'a pas d'après les sondages on va
voir si c'est vérifié tout à l'heure il
n'a pas élargi le spectre de la gauche
radicale il a réussi son talent a permis
de regrouper ces forcesl mais vous savez
elle se cite toujours alors elle a eu un
niveau très bas en 2007 qui était de 8,9
mais oui mais quand vous rassembliez
tout l'extrême gauche et cetera vous
vous rendez compte que Ben que vous avez
une gauche la gauche du Parti socialiste
qui se situe entre 10 et 18 % les très
grandes années voilà mais donc ce qu'on
a ce qu'on observe aujourd'hui c'est un
homme de talent qui a réussi à
rassembler ces forcesl qui souvent
étaient très
éparpillé par rapport à cette question
là il faut pas oublier que dans les
derniers jours le candidat de gauche
François Hollande a beaucoup beaucoup
insisté sur le vote utile parce qu'
manifestement il voulait creuser l'écart
y compris avec Jean-Luc Mélenchon on va
voir tout à l'heure si ça s'est vérifié
ou pas quelle est l'ambiance modem ce
soir pour pour le savoir on retrouve sur
place Marie bremau rue de l'Université à
Paris donc Marie que se
passe-t-il et bien on commence à manquer
de place ici on vient de voir passer il
y a quelques instants Philippe douelazi
ou encore le sénateur Jean artui qui ont
rejoint François Baayou réuni avec son
comité stratégique depuis 17h30 environ
comité stratégique auquel participent
les principaux cadres du MoDem parmi
lesquels Marielle dearnaz sa directrice
de campagne ce comité stratégique se
réunira également demain matin pour
élaborer la stratégie à suivre en
fonction des résultats François baayrou
lui est arrivé ici au 133 rue de
l'Université à l'heure du déjeuner après
avoir voté plusut tôt ce matin à poau il
devrait prendre la parole ce soir aux
alentours de 21h 21h30 il y a ici de
très nombreux journalistes et quelques
militants modemes qui pour l'heure
apparaissent très calmes voire
détendus revenir sur Baayou parce qu'on
le voilà merci BEP merci Marie Fabien
voulait intervenir peut-être peut-être
ben sur le le score de François Baayou
qui a beaucoup évolué au cours de cette
campagne comme celui de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon mais dans un sens inverse on a
beaucoup dit qu'il il avait raté sa sa
campagne on va en parler dans un instant
à mot d'abord sur c'est vrai que en tout
cas ce qu'on a mesuré dans les enquêtes
préélectorales le le score voilà putatif
de présumé de François baayrou illustre
ce paradoxe quand même de la vie
politique française entre une
personnalité qui bénéficie de niveau de
popularité très élevé capital sympathie
un vrai capital sympathie don
personnalité tout à fait don le projet
est également jugé souhaitable et
réaliste vraiment de par une majorité de
Français et ça ne se traduit pas en tout
cas ça dans les préélectoraux ça ne se
traduisait pas dans dans les yeux schop
un problème de positionnement politique
je crois que c'est surtout la loi des
reins de de de la 5e République la
bipolarisation qui broie les candidats
du centre sauf si l'un des deux grands
candidat de droite ou de gauche des vis
et là semble-t-il ça n'a pas été le cas
en tout cas durant la campagne d'près
les les les sondages ça n'a pas été le
cas d'accord alors donc centrisation de
la société française mais qui ne se
reporte pas sur le centre c'est un
paradoxe français alors on l'a dit se
passe beaucoup de choses hein
aujourd'hui sur les réseaux sociaux sur
Internet on l'a dit toute la soirée
Caroline Deschamps ser un peu notre
vigie de la toile bonsoir Caroline alors
qu'est-ce qui se passe déjà
racontez-nous un peu quels sont vos
tweets préférés bonsoir Émilie alors
j'ai envie de vous dire il était une
fois sur Twitter les réseaux sociaux
rembl en effet un véritable western
spaghetti il y a les desperados les hor
lois qui ont décidé donc de braver
l'interdiction de diffuser les sondages
et les estimations avant 20h il s'agit
des sites belge et suisse qui ne sont
pas soumis à la législation française et
puis certains internautes qui ont décidé
d'assumer leurs actes Libération.fr qui
avait annoncé en grande pompe divulguer
les premiers résultats à 18h30 n'a
finalement pas franchi le pas Nicolas
Demorand s'explique en argant ne pas
disposer de résultats fiables il faut
faut dire que les desperérados du net
risquent jusqu'à 75000 € d'amende une
jolie somme si bien que la plupart des
journalistes présents sur Twitter ont
préféré rester du côté des légalistes
des untweetable et puis il y a les
petits malins qui ont trouvé la parade
des astuces pour ne pas se faire
attraper par le gendarme comprenz la
commission des sondages alors pléor de
métaphor ont été trouvé pour désigner
les candidats le gouda l'omelette
norvégienne la Rolex le du béarne et
pour ainsi donner les tendances le tout
avec le mot- clé sur Twitter radio
Londes et puis vers 19h 15 laafp a
commencé à donner les estimations des
instituts de sondage mais uniquement
pour les clients ce qui fait dire à
pierreaskii de Rue 89 lafp qui donne ses
infos à ses clients et les Français qui
s'informment en Suisse et en Belgique
une loi vient d'imploser un bon bazar
donc Émilie merci beaucoup et vous
continuez à suivre bien sûr Caroline
tout ce qui se passe sur le net avec vos
tweet favoris tout au long de la soirée
qui va nous mener très loin au cours de
cette soirée on vous l'a dit je note que
la Commission des sondages dénonce des
faits délictueux de la part de
particuliers vous si vous êtes sur
Twitter en ce moment et également de
certains médias je vous rappelle que la
Commission des sondages a décidé de
saisir le parquet alors nous on est
civique bien sûr même si nous aussi sur
cet ordinateur on voit bien qu'il se
passe des choses il est 19h56 et 49
seconde il peut y avoir des surprises ce
soir Gill Lecler dans ce premier tour ou
absolument il faut toujours se se méfier
que tout ce qu'on a connu comme chiffre
jusqu'à vendredi soir ce cétait des
sondages c'est-à-dire des photographies
à un moment donné et on le sait depuis
déjà un certain nombre d'années il y
avait beaucoup de de citoyens qui
disaient qu'ils étaient encore indécis
jusqu'au dernier moment beaucoup de gens
y compris encore hier et ce matin ne
savait pas sans doute pour qui ils
allaient voter donc ce scrutin peut
révéler des surprises un sondage encore
encore une fois n'est pas une prédiction
c'est une photo à un moment donnéard le
photo à un moment donné mais qui quand
même indiquait depuis une quinzaine de
jours des évolutions il y avait
incontestablement une montée de François
Hollande et une petite baisse de Nicolas
Sarkozi une montée de Marine Le Pen qui
avait véritablement creusé l'écart avec
avec Jean-Luc Mélenchon voilà ça c'était
ce qui était annoncé on va voir si cette
tendance s'est confirmée si ça a été
stabilisé ou si elle s'est infirmée très
très brièvement expliquez-nous comment
vous allez travailler ce soir les
résultats que vous allez pouvoir nous
donner notamment les projections sur deè
tour ce sera vers quelle heure ça se
passe comment vous travaillez comment
alors très brièvement à 20h ce qu'on va
vous donner c'est une estimation et pas
un sondage c'est-à-dire que les chiffres
ont été fabriqué à partir du
dépouillement des bulletins de vote réel
dans 250 bureaux test en revanche c'est
vrai que dès
21h45 je serai en mesure de vous donner
le résultat d'une intention de vote pour
le deuxème tour c'est-à-dire pour le
coup d'un sondage qui sera réalisé entre
20h10 et et 21h30 et pourquoi à partir
de 20h10 c'est très important de le
préciser parce que c'est important que
les électeurs pour nous répondre a pris
connaissance des résultats du du premier
tour notamment s'il y a des des
surprises c'est important qu'il puissent
s'approprier ce résultat là pour
déterminer au mieux leur vote de second
tour résultat petite minutes de patience
encore et on connaîtra le visage les
visages du duel de ce deème tour Michel
et ces chiffres qu'on va dévoiler dans
quelques secondes vont encore bouger au
cours de la soirée ou ce sera
véritablement à la marge il ils vont ils
peuvent bouger mais vraiment très très à
la marge d'ors et déjà voilà précis et
fiable voilà maintenant on est près de
la minute silence religieux sur ce
plateau il va y avoir matière à
commenter d'ici quelques secondes avec
bien sûr les résultats candidat par
candidat c'est maintenant dans quelques
secondes le décomte est annoncé Michel
voilà je crois que nous allons
maintenant tout de suite vous annoncer
les résultats donc l'estimation à partir
nous l'avons compris des calculs des
remontées qui sont effectué par
l'Institut sa à partir je le rappelle
des bulletins dépouillés dans un certain
nombre de bureaux à travers la France
c'est tout de suite c'est parti pour les
résultat premières estimations premiers
chiffres pour ce premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle 2012 François
Hollande en tête avec 28,4 % suivi bien
sûr de Nicolas Sarkozi 25 5 % les autres
estimations Michel voilà pour la suite
donc le 3è homme la trè femme Marine Le
Pen donc avec ce score impressionnant de
20 % celui qu'elle Espérit mais que
n'avait prédit aucun institut
manifestement ces derniers jours et
Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui visait beaucoup
plus obtient donc 11,7 % François Baayou
n'arrive pas à un chiffre à deux
chiffres un score à 8,5% eva jolie n'est
qu'à 2 % voilà pour ces premières
estimation la suite c'est ce qu'on a
appelé les petits candidats dans cette
campagne Michel Nicolas duponignan 1,8 %
Philippe Poutou 1,2 Nathalie au 0,7 et
Jacques cheminat 0,2 % et nous allons
tout de suite rut ferino Michel zames
nous attend avec son premier invité
Michell
oui vous pouvez l'entendre derrière moi
Michel émilié beaucoup d'effervescence
des cris de joie à l'annonce évidemment
du résultat de François hand notre
premier invité Jean-Marc bonjour
groupeiste
éidanis prier témoignage sur ce chire
284% pour votre
candatanç à ce point moi je suis heureux
pour lui magif mais tout reste enore à
fairez derrière nous vous endez on va
gagner on va gagner mais rien
fait passant en tête François Hollande à
l'occasion d'une élection présidentielle
pour le président sortant à toutes les
élections présidentielle le président
sortant est arrivé en tête et là il est
deuxè c'est une sanction
particulièrement sévère de sa politique
c'est l'échec de sa politique mais c'est
aussi l'échec de sa manière de faire la
politique est-ce que vous attendiez
vraiment à une si large avance de
François Hollande pour ce premier tour
je sentais monter depuis des mois dans
le pays le besoin de changement un
changement profond pour politiqu nouvell
des méthodes nouvelles et vous savez les
Français on disait qu'ils allaient
s'abstenir qu'il se désintéressai cette
élection c'est pas ce qui s'est passé
ils ont montré le sérieux qu'il porta à
cette élection mais ils l'ont fait avec
gravité parce qu'il mesur la gravité de
la crise parce que la crise n'est pas
qu'économique elle est pas que sociale
elle est politique elle est aussi morale
on sa que vous devez partir deux petites
questions très courtes Marine Le Pen à
20 % est-ce que ça vous étonne c'est le
symptôme d'un malaise très profond d'une
colère sûement mais aussi d'une très
grande responsabilité du président
sortant qui a joué avec les thèmes du
Front National et et finalement qui a
renforcé le Front national mais je crois
qu'au-delà de ça le peuple français veut
reprendre son destin en main et et toute
la tâche qui nous incombe maintenant
c'est de convaincre que le choix que
propose François Holland au français qui
était le choix de l'espoir mais aussi le
choix de la raison c'est le seul
possible pour redresser le pays dans la
justice mais aussi créer les conditions
du redressement de l'Europe donc plus
François Hollande aura un score élevé au
2è tour de cette élection présidentielle
plus nous les Français nous lui
donnerons avec les Français avec la
société française les moyens de changer
vraiment les choses en France en Europe
mais si on vient de regarder les
chiffres Jean-Marc HUD le total de la
gauche n'est pas si important que ça
n'est pas plus fort que ce qu'on pouvait
imaginer par rapport au total de la
droite ce qui est important c'est la
dynamique d'une élection placer en tête
franç Hollande c'est un message très
fort et nous nous allons amplifier cette
dynamique au second tour parce que notre
responsabilité c'est de mettre en
mouvement la société sortir de l'ornière
dans laquelle on t tfon
de retrouver la République les citoyens
et puis de retrouver notre influence
sortir du déclin et faire en sorte que
demain en donnant à François Hollande
les moyens d'une majorité nette nous lui
permettrons de gouverner la France mais
aussi de débattre et discuter et
négocier avec nos partenaires européens
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup Jean-Marc
h vous l'avez peut-être entendu
d'ailleurs nous rue de Solférino il y a
des centaines de personnes qui viennent
de hurler à l'annonce des résultats nous
aurons peut-être des images d'ici
quelques minutes merci beaucoup Michel
Zam on reviendra bien sûr vous voir très
régulièrement tout au long de cette
soirée vous étiez avec Jean-Marc Hau
cité bien sûr dans la liste des
possibles premier ministraable en cas de
victoire de François Hollande autre
première ministraable pressenti Martine
auri qui vient de faire cette
déclaration les Français ont exprimé
aujourd'hui un terrible des aveux à
Sarkozi alors disait qu'elle aurait été
avantagé peut-être pour matigon en cas
d'un bon score de jeanluc Mélenchon ce
qui n'est pas le cas he ce so avait été
dit ces dernières heures alors je disais
Nicolas Sarkozi justement on va aller
sonder un petit peu l'ambiance qu'on
imagine très différente à l'UMP salle de
la Mutualité où est toujours Germain
andriux Germain racontez-nous un peu
comment s'est passé l'annonce à 20h de
ces premières
estimation et bien écoutez les militants
ont applaudi ces résultats ont gardé ont
gardé le sourire et les applaudissements
mais bien sûr ce n'est pas le scénario
qu'ils attendaient certes Nicolas
Sarkozi est qualifié pour le second tour
mais il est en retrait derrière François
Hollande alors un autre résultat qui a
été très applaudi et bien c'est la place
du supposé 3e homme Jean-Luc Mélenchon
avec un score inférieur aux prévisions
en clair les militants pour ces
militants UMP pas question bien sûr de
laisser la place aux défétis ils veulent
croire et bien que les compteurs vont
être remis à zéro pour ce second tour et
que rien n'est joué pour le moment
Nicolas Sarkozi lui ne devrait plus trop
tarder à venir ici face aux militants il
est attendu pour un discours mais pas
avant 21h très bien merci effectivement
Guillaume Pelletier qui travaille à
l'élisé pour Nicolas Sarkozi considère
qu'une deuxèe campagne commence dès ce
soir pour Nicolas Sarkozi nous allons
voir ce qui se passe du côté du Front
national tout de suite avec Mathilde
terrier qui est-ce que vous m'enteendez
bien qui se trouve à côté du directeur
stratégique de la campagne menée par
Marine Le Pen Mathilde vous êtes là OK
et on va donc lui poser question Michel
merci votre réaction d'abord à ce score
ce bon score que vous espériez
effectivement dans les derniers jours de
la campagne mais dont ne vous créditez
pas les
instituts est-ce que vous nous
entendez les chiffres problème de son
manifestement un mot peut-être Denis
jambar sur ce score effectivement
imposant de Marine Le Pen qu'est-ce que
ça change dans la perspective du second
tour ça pose une question stratégique à
Nicolas Sarkozi pour le second tour on
sait bien qu'il y a eu des débats
pendant la première partie de la
campagne sur est-ce qu'il faut aller
vers la droite qui était la stratégie
préconisée par Patrick Buisson est-ce
qu'il faut aller vers le centre et c'est
vrai que on a eu un Nicolas Sarkozi qui
a fait un peu l'essuie-glace donc là
aujourd'hui clairement ces réserves sont
dans l'électorat de Marine Le Pen donc
ça doit dicter normalement une campagne
très à droite d'autant plus que le score
de François baayerou est faible c'est n
pas qu'est-ce qu'on sait sur le report
de voix Fabien Simon alors avant
l'annonce de des estimations de 20h ce
qu'on sait sur le report de voie ce
qu'on avait mesuré c'est que moins d'un
électeur de Marine Le Pen sur 2 on était
plutôt dans la zone des 40 45 % avait
l'intention de se reporter sur Nicolas
Sarkozi au second tour ça n'est pas
assez pour le président candidat ce
n'est pas suffisant donc c'est vrai que
toute la difficulté pour lui ce sera de
mobiliser ses réserves de voie fronti un
mot sur la campagne de de Marine Le Pen
faut surt cette log que ça c'est un
chiffre historique pour le Front
national on en était resté le sommet ça
avait été jean-marine le Pen en 2002
c'était 168 là l'é à 20 pour c'est c'est
énorme et ça surprend tout le monde
c'est vraiment avec bien évidemment
quand même les deux premiers et Françis
Holland qui creuse l'écart avec trois
points d'avance mais le score de Marine
Le Pen c'est une énorme qu'il a beaucoup
plus d'électeurs aux
ce score avait été obtenu avec 28
% aujourd'hui effectivement on est un
peu moins de 20 % d'abstention donc en
voit c'est une
progression véritablement dans le payage
je vrais quand même ajouter parce que
c'est vrai qu'on est focalisé là-dessus
et c'est un événement très important
mais c'est la première fois en dehors
des deux élections 75 74 où il y a eu
qu'un candidat de gauche c'est la
première fois qu'un candidat socialiste
arrive aussi haut au premier tour aussi
haut c'est la première fois qu'est-ce
que ça valide sur la stratégie de
campagne de Marine Le Pen en revenant un
petit peu quand même sur sur le tous les
chiffres qu'on a pu donner des 20 j'ai
fait des petit
calculs d'abord petit score mais elle
parand
mais chers et chers
compatriotes les urnes ont
parlé je tiens à remercier avec chaleur
le million de Françaises et de Français
qui m'ont apporté leur suffrage et se
faisant ont défendu par leur vote
l'écologie l'Europe et la République
exemplaire
le
score le score du Front national est une
tâche
indélbile sur les valeurs de notre
démocratie une menace pour la République
un avertissement que chaque responsable
politique doit
entendre je veux dire à cell et ceux qui
se sont laissés abuser par le Front
national qu'il se trompe de
colère je veux
dénoncer je veux dénoncer les apprentis
sorciers de l'identité nationale qui à
force de discours de division et de
haine ont permis à l'extrême droite de
faire son plus haut score dans é
présidentielle je veux rédire ce soir
que l'écologie est bien le grand défi du
temps qui vient aucune politique ne
pourra réussir sans entamer d'urgence
une transition écologique basée sur la
conversion de l'économie la lutte contre
le réchauffement climatique le choix des
énergies renouvelables et la protection
des
écosystèmes chacun doit désormais
prendre ses
responsabilités j'appelle dès à présent
toutes celles et ceux qui ont voté pour
moi et au-delà toutes celles et ceux qui
sont attachés aux valeurs de la
République à tout faire pour que notre
pays sorte enfin du sarcossisme en se
rassemblant autour de la candidature de
François Hollande qui doit désormais
porter
toutes les couleurs de la gauche et des
écologistes je vous appelle à faire des
15 jours qui viennent 15 jour de
mobilisation permanente la belle date du
1ier mai doit être un symbole de justice
et de fraternité contre l'extrême droite
et ces idées marquant notre volonté
de reconquête
républicaine par ces soutiens sans
ambiguité je veux signifier qu'il nous
faut restaurer les valeurs de la
République lutter contre l'esprit de
clan qui a prévalu ces 5 dernières
années et redonner un soufle à notre
démocratie à nos institutions pour
établir un lien de fierté et de
confiance entre notre pays et ses
représentants
politiques il y va de la morale
républicaine la défense des privilèges
indus l'absence de respect des règles
qui fondent notre morale publique
doivent d'urgence connaître un terme il
va surtout de l'intérêt général notre
pays doit retrouver le sens du bien
commun mais il ne s'agit donc pas
simplement de battre un homme il faut
qu'une société nouvelle voit le jour
porteuse d'un modèle de développement
plus respectueux des êtres humains et de
la planète dans les semaines et les
années qui viennent les écologistes
continueront agir à vos côtés en ce
sens nous voulons donc construire une
nouvelle majorité rassemblant la gauche
et les écologistes bien au-delà du seul
parti du précédent cette majorité devra
être une majorité de
combat une majorité de combat pour la
justice d'abord la répétition des
solutions classiques n'est plus possible
il faudra de l'imagination et de la
détermination pour ne pas retomber dans
les ornias du passé et décevoir l'espoir
de nos compatriotes la justice devra
être à la boussole de la nouvelle
majorité une majorité de combat pour
leur Europe ensuite sans une nouvelle
ambition européenne rien ne sera
possible il faut un nouveau traiter
européens qui mettent enfin la
solidarité et l'écologie au cœur de la
construction européenne l'Europe doit
redevenir un espoir pour les Françaises
et les
Français une majorité de combat pour
l'écologie enfin la France doit sortir
des nucléaaires lutter contre les
dérèglements climatiques
convertir son économie au développement
durable et faire de la protection de
l'environnement un principe de
gouvernement la France voilà c'était la
première déclaration d'Eva jolie la
candidate d'Europe Écologie les vers et
avec un chiffre pour l'instant qui la
donne à 2 % des voix je salue l'arrivé
sur ce plateau de nos premiers invités
politiques Bruno lerou porte-parole de
François Hollande bonjour Merci d'être
parmi nous et Valérie rossau Debord
député UMP merci à vous également je
vous donne la parole dans quelques
secondes pour que vous réagissiez à ces
premiers résultats mais avant cela on va
tout de suite rejoindre une nouvelle
fois Michel zames rue de Solferino siège
du Parti socialiste à Paris je crois
Michel que vous êtes avec Benoît
amamont oui absolument avec le
porte-parole du Parti socialiste benoî
Hamont un score presque rêvé pour un
premier tour pour François Hollande en
tout cas il est en tête ce qui est c'est
la première fois dans la 5e République
qu'un président sortant qui se
représente n'est pas en tête donc ça
nous donne une force indiscutable
indiscutable aussi en raison de la
participation des Français très
importante maintenant la responsabilité
de François Holland est de rassembler et
de rassembler tous les Français dans un
face à faceace face à Nicolas Sarkozi où
on défendra le progrès social contre
l'austérité le le la renégociation du
traité européen contre le laiss faire et
la moralisation de la vie publique
contre une pratique du pouvoir qui a
laissé beaucoup de traces négatives pas
les français on attend Jean-Luc
Mélenchon qui est en train de s'exprimer
on va aller tout de suite le retrouver
merci pour ce témoignage beno bien
déterminé à tourner la page des années
Sarkozi le total des voies des droites
dans toutes leurs composantes recul par
rapport à
mais l'extrême droite est à haut
niveau nous avons donc eu
raison de concentrer notre
campagne sur l'analyse et la critique
radicale des propositions de l'extrême
droite nous avons eu raison de le faire
et si nous ne l'avions pas fait
peut-être le résultat ce soir serait-il
encore plus alarmant il
est alors c'est le moment pour moi de
dire combien nous nous sommes sentis
seuls à certain moment dans cette
bataille
l' imitit l'autre ignorait et nous avons
porté sur notre dos l'essentiel du
combat honte à ceux qui ont préféré nous
tirer dessus plutôt que de nous
aider souvenez-vous pour toujours des
noms de ceux qui ont refusé ce combat ou
pire qui ont préféré relayer les
arguments calomnieux et antiommuniste de
l'extrême droite contre
nous à cette
heure c'est le score du Front de gauche
qui tient la clé du résultat final dans
ses mains c'est donc vous tous et non
pas moi bien sûr qui avait cette
décision car à la
vérité nous aurons été la force
politique nouvelle la seule qui est
percé
et qui soit né dans cette
élection c'est
nous dès
lors qui avons les clés du
résultat je vous appelle en conscience à
assumer pleinement cette
responsabilité sans vous occuper des
commentaires des impressions des petits
jeux de
pronostic auquel j'invite à ce que
personne ne
s'abandonne et je le redis très
clairement à cette heure en conscience
il n'y a rien à
négocier notre engagement en a besoin
d'aucune
autorisation ni d'aucune cageolerie pour
se déployer dans toute sa force je vous
appelle à vous mobiliser aux rendez-vous
qui vous sont
donnés le 1er mai derrière nos syndicat
avec la classe ouvrière dans la
lutte notre camp notre famille politique
le monde du travail et de ses
revendications je vous appelle à vous
retrouver le 6 mai sans rien demander en
échange le CIM pour battre
Sarkozi
je vous demande de ne pas traîner les
pieds je vous demande de mobiliser comme
s'il s'agissait de me faire gagner
moi-même l'élection
présidentielle ne demandez rien en
échange seulement l'acte de votre
conscience
pourquoi la bataille que nous
menons n'est pas une bataille
personnelle ni même une bataille dans un
seul pays il s'agit de retourner la
table de renverser la tendance qui en
Europe maintient tous les peuples sous
le jou de l'axe Sarkozy Merkel il faut
le briser en
France voilà ce que nous allons faire et
parce que nous allons le faire alors il
sera clair net et sans bavure que c'est
nous qui faisons les décision
d'oravant à gauche et dans le
pays
élevons-nous à la hauteur du pouvoir qui
nous a été donné par notre
rassemblement continuons tranquillement
de marcher notre
chemin car je vous le
dis
inéluctablement l'histoire vient à notre
rencontre et nous allons à la sienne
inéluctablement les solutions que nous
avons défendu et principalement celle du
partage des richesses et du changement
de régime seront mis à l'ordre du jour
par les chocs qui
s'annonce quel que soit le président de
la République qui sera
élu la finance d'orge et déjà est
déterminé a agresser le peuple français
et alors quel que soit le responsable il
n'aura d'autrees choix que de se
soumettre ou de résister et pour ce qui
est de résister il n'y a qu'une force la
nôtre voilà c'était Jean-Luc Mélenchon
qui s'exprimait à place stalingrade à
Paris en même temps on a vu des images
en direct de Nicolas Sarkozy dans sa
voiture qui arrive pour sa déclaration
qui est attendu aux alentours de 21h
Jean-Luc Mélenchon qu'on a donc entendu
appeler très clairement à battre Nicolas
Sarkozi le 6 mai prochain ce qui m'amène
à vous poser cette question Valé rossau
de bord je rappelle que vous représentez
l'UMP sur ce plateau est-ce que vous
avez le sentiment vous aussi ce soir que
ce premier tour c'était d'abord une
sanction et une sanction dure de ce
quinquena Nicolas Sarkozi non moi ce que
j'ai comme impression si vous voulez
c'est que ce premier tour c'est la fin
d'un cycle où on était neu contre un la
un cycle où neuf candidat on fait de
l'antisarkozisme primaire par certains
moments comme Monsieur Mélanchon mais
comme d'autres on va se retrouver dans
un deuxème cycle une nouvelle campagne
qui commence dès ce soir cez vraiment
qu'une autre campagne est possible pour
ce de je crois c'est la Constitution qui
le dit si vous voulez la constition la
Constitution elle prévoit 15 jours que
tout peut changer de Manès long 15 jours
c'est très très long dans une campagne
électorale 15 jours c'est très long il y
a 15 jours qui commence à partir de ce
soir avec une nouvelle campagne à un
contre un ça veut dire au même temps de
parole pour le 1 contre un et donc plus
à 9 contre un et avec avec la
possibilité enfin d'avoir ce débat face
aux Français et c'est à partir de ce
soir que ça commence c'est pour ça que
nous sommes à la fois sereins et
déterminé et nous nous jouons la
victoire le 6 mai en essayant d'aller
séduire les électeurs du Front national
particulièrement Jean-Marie Le Pen
déclare ce soir que pour lui Nicolas
Sarkozi a perdu il ne faut rien attendre
de ce côté-là manifestement aujourd'hui
si vous voulez notre campagne nous la
continuons comme nous l'avons commencé
nous adressons au peuple français nous
adressons ni à quelconque force ni de
droite ni de gauche ni du centre nous
adressons à ceux qui partageront nos
convictions nos valeurs et c'est ainsi
que Nicolas Sarkozi va faire cette
campagne de deè tour Bruno lerou on
entend les responsables socialistes
depuis tout à l'heure on a l'impression
que les jeux sont faits pour eux
contrairement à ce qu'on vient
d'entendre vous avez mal entendu je vois
pas qui peut vous avoir donné cette
impression et s'il y a quelqu'un qui l'a
fait donnez-moi son nom il y a un second
tour tout simplement alors le second
tour il est en même temps le second
c'est-à-dire qu'il est porteur des
résultats du premier tour il est porteur
de ce qu'on voulu dire des Français il
est porteur d'une cohérence et là la
cohérence elle s'affiche ce soir Nicolas
Sarkozi rendez-vous compte était le
président qui était le plus rejeté de
l'histoire de la 5e République il est
maintenant le premier président sortant
à ne pas être en tête au
soirierour sanction d'ors et déjà au
soir du premier tour je dis je dit qu'en
même temps il y a une cohérence et que
les Français sont cohérents et qu'ils
vont chercher au deuxième tour à faire
en sorte que ce rejet qui est un rejet
marqué qui n'a jamais été vu dans
l'histoire de notre République et bien
se marque au soir du second tour et que
rien est joué qu'il reste 15 jours
encore de campagne donc nous ferons
campagne pour incarner encore le
changement pendant ces 15 jours mais il
n'y a pas de compteur qui soit comme ça
remis à zéro il y a les résultats d'un
premier tour voilà c'était le
commentaire de Bruno lerou porte-parole
de franç Hollande vous restez bien sûr
avec nous sur ce plateau on va
maintenant retourner de l'autre côté
l'autre camp celui de l'UMP on va
écouter tout de suite je crois Luc
Chatel qui est avec vous Germain
and oui bonsoir je suis au côté de Luc
Chatel qui est à côté de moi Luc Chatel
bonsoir alors tout d'abord les urnes ont
confirmé ce qui était dit depuis
plusieurs semaines dans les sondages
Nicolas Sarkozi est qualifié maisve mais
arrive en seconde position alors quelle
est votre réaction les urnes les
Français ont montré ce soir qu'ils
aimaient surprendre d'abord en se
déplaçant massivement ensuite en mettant
à un niveau certains candidats qui
nétait pas prévu et puis surtout en
ouvrant totalement le scrutin du deuxè
tour le deè tour est très ouvert et les
Français vont avoir droit à ce débat
projet contre projet candidat contre
candidat qu'ils attendent TS ça veut
dire que ce soir c'est la fin de
l'esquive c'est la fin de la dérobade il
faut que sur chaque sujet les deux
candidats se prononcent Nicolas Sarkozi
l'a fait mais François Hollande il va
bien falloir qu'il sorte du tout SAF
Sarkozi on peut pas continuer comme ça
l'autre surprise de ces résultats vous
l'avez dit vous l'avez évoqué c'est
également a le score de Marine Le Pen
est-ce que c'est un désaveux pour la
stratégie Nicolas Sarkozi du premier
tour non on a des Français qui ont
exprimé pour certains d'entre eux
aujourd'hui un mécontentement une
inquiétude parfois une colère
la question du deuxème tour c'est de
répondre à ces inquiétudes c'est pour
chacun des finalistes d'être capable de
parler à l'ensemble des Français et de
s'exprimer sur çausé c'est un choix de
société est-ce que le 6 mai on veut
sortir du nucléaire ou pas est-ce que le
6 mai on veut le droit de vote pour les
étrangers aux élections locales est-ce
que le 6 mai on veut un retour à
l'équilibre budgétaire ou non c'est ça
le débat ça veut dire que chaque
candidat doit se positionner c'est la
fin de la dérobade c'est la fin de
l'esquive à laquelle on a assisté la FR
depuis plusieurs mois un dernier mot
tout de même sur ces sondages à
répétition sur le second tour vous
pensez ce soir et vous dites au militant
et bien que tout est remis à zéro on
part sur une nouvelle perspective pour
ce second tour bien s savez quand vous
êtes qualifié pour la finale des Jeux
olympiques du 100 m ce qui compte c'est
d'être qualifié et d'être en forme le
jour de la course faut être qualifié
c'est le cas de Nicolas SAR mais c'est
une nouvelle épreuve qui commence et là
c'est projet contre projet candidat
contre candidat qui est le mieux apte à
exercer la plus haute fonction celle de
chef de l'État Nicolas Sarkozi il a
montré ses qualités il a montré ses
compétences Luc Chatel merci mais
écoutez voilà la première réaction à vif
à la Mutualité de Luc châel comme je
vous l'avais dit bien effectivement ici
à l'UMP on espère et bien repartir sur
des nouvelles bases pour ce second tour
peu importe les sondages merci beaucoup
Germain on va retrouver Mathilde terrier
maintenant toujours dans la salle
éekinox où se réunit le Front national
avec votre invité madame
arnutu oui madame arnutu vice-président
chargé des affaires sociales alors ce
soir l'objectif de Marine Le Pen c'était
de faire mieux que son père en 2002 un
score largement écrasé aujourd'hui c'est
une victoire pour vous c'est une
victoire pour la France je crois c'est
une victoire évidemment pour le tout le
travail de cette campagne fait par
Marine Le Pen c'est une victoire aussi
pour nos militants et moi qui suis en
charge des affaires sociales je crois
que c'est aussi une grande victoire pour
pour ceux qu'elle a oublié qu'elle a
appelé tout au long de la campagne les
invisibles et les Oubliés vous pensez
que ce soir c'est de sa stratégie de
dédiabolisation oui mais je crois que ça
va bien au-delà de la dédiabolisation
c'està-dire que avec un score de 20 % et
avec la campagne qui a été faite nous
nous inscrivons maintenant comme la
seule vraie force d'opposition face à la
gauche et c'est ça qui est le plus
important parce que c'est une force
d'opposition claire stable qui n'est
plus du tout le vote contestataire comme
on l'a souvent dit mais au contraire un
socle très important qui ne bougera plus
et qui ne fera que s'amplifier alors
victoire ce soir parême qui se tourne
puisque et bien la campagne s'arrête ici
qu'est-ce que vous allez faire pour le
second tour ah la campagne s'arrête pas
ici vous savez très bien qu'il y a les
législative qui vont être le véritable
deuxème tour d'ailleurs je crois de
cette élection présidentielle et là ça
ne ça ne peut que nous encourager
puisque d'après les informations que
nous avons à 7h marine est première dans
beaucoup de communes rurales elle est
très bien placé première ou deuxè dans
le vote ouvrier ce qui est assez
intéressant d'ailleurs de voir comment M
a été balayé et puis et puis voilà donc
elle s'impose dans beaucoup de
catégories de français et je crois que
les législatives vont amplifier ce très
beau résultat de ce soir une alliance
pour second
tour elle l'a dit à plusieurs reprises
elle va pas dire le contraire
aujourd'hui vous savez je crois que la
force de ces 20 % aussi elle est
beaucoup d à sa force de conviction et à
sa sincérité donc évidemment qu'elle va
pas dire le contraire ce soir de de ce
qu'elle dit depuis 8 mois il n'y a
aucune alliance possible mais pourquoi
parce que le PS Sarkozi et les autres à
aucun moment durant cette campagne nont
parlé de nation nont parlé de protection
des Français particulièrement de
protection sociale et donc par
définition il ne peut pas y avoir
d'alliance avec ces gens-là qui ont
bradé la France et qui vont sans doute
continuer à le faire Merci Merci à VOUS
matildde terrier vous étiez au Front
national Valérie rau de Borin FN à 20 %
ça veut dire pour quoi pour l'UMP à
partir de ce soir à partir de demain
matin dans la manière dont vous allez
traiter avec cet électorat là et sur la
recomposition de la droite dans les
jours à venir si vous voulez il n'y a
pas d'électorat ou de terr réservé les
voix n'appartiennent à personne il y a
des idées des convictions et nous nous
adressons aux Français dans leur vérité
dans leur unité sur une thématique sur
une campagne que nous avons faite et par
rapport aux problématiques qui sont
celles des uns ou des autres par rapport
au désendettement qui est absolument
essentiel par rapport à la la nécessité
de conserver notre système de protection
sociale par rapport aux valeurs que nous
défendons nous disons à l'ensemble des
électeurs qui se sont porté sur les H
qui ne sont pas qualif que vous aviez su
capter en 2007 que là vous n'avez pas
capté en 2012 vous en tirez quel
enseignement ce soir je crois très
sincèrement qu'il ne faut pas raisonner
comme ça je crois très sincèrement oui
je crois très sincèrement que raisonner
sur des terres qui appartiendraient aux
un ou aux autres serait absolument faux
les Français ne sont pas comment divisés
dans leur façon de penser les
actuellement c'est un électorat qui vous
a échappé ce soir c'est un électorat qui
demain va avoir à choisir entre François
Hollande et Nicolas Sarkozi c'est un
électorat qui va avoir à se demander
pour les problèmes qui sont les M AC le
report que l'on connaît vous allez nous
le rappeler Fabiane le report des voix
alors avant l'annonce des des
estimations c'était moins d'un électeur
sur deux de Marine Le Pen qui avait
l'intention de se déclarer enfin de se
reporter sur Nicolas Sarkozi au second
tour mais on verra tout à l'heure
effectivement dans quelle
mesure la connaissance des estimations a
pu
modifier doit faire augmenter ce
pourcentage de report en sa faveur de la
part des électeurs du Front national
donc il va bien falloir en tenir compte
dans la campagne électorale donc cela
veut dire une droitisation confirmée au
cour des 15 jours VI je crois très
sincèrement que la campagne que nous
allons mener que Nicolas Sarkozi va
mener sur les 15 jours qui restent cette
nouvelle campagne elle n'est pas sur des
terres qui appartiendrai entre
guillemets à des uns ou à des autres
elle est clairement sur des idées sur
des propositions
et elle n nouvelle parce que nous un
contre un tout simplement nous serons
plus neuf contre un elle est nouvelle
parce que tout simplement nous aurons un
temps de parole qui nous permettra de
nous exprimer elle est nouvelle tout
simplement aussi parce que enfin
l'ensemble des propositions Nicolas
Sarkozi vont réellement pouvoirt
présenté elle sera nouvelle parce qu'il
y aura égalité des temps de paroes Bruno
l est-ce queise àé des comptes lui va
mener une campagne nouvelle à partir de
demain mais non il va y avoir de la
cohérence je remarque que Nicolas
Sarkozi dit 9 contre un contre un il a
été tout seul pour gérer la France et
pour faire l'état dans laquelle il l'a
mis pendant 5 ans c'est bien lui tout
seul qui a réussi he il y avait personne
contre lui il avait même des Français
qui lui avent fait confiance alors quand
j'entends parler de protection sociale
mais ces personnes qui se plaignent
aujourd'hui elles ont été touchées par
les franchises médicales parler des
remboursements quand j'entends parler de
lutte contre les déficits plus de 600
milliards elles sont aujourd'hui
inquiète ces personnes quand j'entends
peut-être parler de sécurité demain vous
allez parler comment à partir de ce soir
et de demain à la fois à l'électorat de
Marine Le Pen et à celui de jean-l dit
très clairement avec les 60 propositions
de François Hollande elles étaient le
programme au premier tour elles seront
le programme au deuxè tour davantage en
valeur il n'y a pas de campagne en
zigzag dans une élection présidentielle
il y a une cohérence à avoir il y a un
discours adresser aux Français et par
exemple nous dirons ce que nous voulons
faire sur la sécurité sur les zones
prioritaires de sécurité nous dirons ce
que nous voulons faire en matière de
santé nous dirons ce que nous voulons
faire en matière de lutte contre la
finance écoute François Fillon le Pr
tout de suite Bruno doivent être
respecté parce qu'ils sont tous
l'expression de notre nation ce soir
rien n'est joué le second tour c'est
celui du choix décisif les Français le
feront en leur âme et conscience mais je
veux leur dire ma
conviction la crise des dettes n'est pas
finie ce qui signifie que nous n'avons
pas le droit à l'erreur ceux qui
promettent tout et trop vous trompe la
France doit continuer de se moderniser
elle doit continuer de gérer
sérieusement ses finances l'enjeu c'est
de garder notre indépendance et de
protéger notre modèle social notre foi
dans l'Europe ensuite doit servir la
France Nicolas Sarkozi a démontré que
l'intérêt national et l'intérêt européen
était un même
combat au cours de ces CIN dernières
années j'ai été admiratif du courage des
Français face à la crise durant 5 ans
votre travail et votre unité ont permis
de tenir le choc notre unité nationale a
été notre force désormais nous avons un
socle un socle pour aller de l'avant et
pour obtenir des succès revenir en
arrière ce serait un gâi enfin en ces
temps difficiles il faut un chef d'État
peu d'hommes ont été aussi injustement
attaqués que Nicolas Sarkozi mais
personne ne peut douter de sa
détermination et de son courage en
français française le 6 mai vous allez
décid faites-le pour l'idéal républicain
que nous avons en partage faites-le pour
la France pour son avenir pour celui de
vos enfants faites-le au tour du
président de la République voilà voilà
c'était François Fillon avec une
certaine dramatisation des enjeux de ce
second tour rien n'est joué choisissez
Nicolas Sarkozi faites-le pour la France
c'est le message du Premier ministre ce
soir on va voir maintenant quelle est
l'évolution de l'ambiance chez les amis
de Bruno lerou puisquon retourne tout de
suite rut Solferino avec vous Michel
zamas et vous êtes en compagnie de
Claude Bartolone oui vous parlez
d'ambance Émilie l'ambiance est toujours
là l'ambiance se passe aussi beaucoup à
l'extérieur de la rue de Solferino
toujours des centaines de personnes sont
là à attendre éventuellement peut-être
François Hollande alors Claude Bartel
François Hollande est-ce qu'il va venir
ce soir ici il est surtout à Thul et il
va intervenir de Tul le département dont
il est président dans dans quelques
minutes al plus sérieusement ce score de
François Hollande est-ce que vous y
attendiez ce soir je dire franchement
non parce que face à un président de la
République sortant arrivé en tête et av
un écart vraiment c'était dans mes
moments d'euphorie que j'imaginais que
les Français allaient manifester à la
fois leur soutien à une personnalité
François Hollande et les orientations
qu'il a eu l'occasion de leur présenter
pour changer de politique en même temps
on a entendu François Fillon à l'instant
qui lu a dit que rien n'était terminé et
qu'il fallait se mobiliser
éventuellement pour Nicolas Sarkozi au
2è tour on arrive dans 15 jours très
décisif cl Barcelone oui vous pensez
bien que le premier ministre n'allait
pas dire autre chose mais c'est vrai que
rien n'est fait il faut maintenant que
toutes celles et tous ceux qui ne
veulent plus de cette politique
d'austérité dont a été responsable
Nicolas Sarkozi se rassemble pour
arriver maintenant à une politique plus
juste plus équitable qui réponde même à
la colère d'un certain nombre
d'électeurs qui se sentant abandonnés
ont cru trouver une issue dans un vote
d'extrême droite surpris par le score de
Jean-Luc mélonchon qu'on attendait
beaucoup plus haut et qui finalement a
baissé dans la dernière journée
d'élection c'était difficile de trouver
le bon score de Jean-Luc Mélanchon dans
la mesure où il y avait à la fois son
talent personnel et les orientations
politiques qu'il a présenté aux Français
j'avais beaucoup de mal moi à me faire
une idée sur le score qui allait être le
sien merci Claude Bartelone un autre
invité nous rejoint également c'est
Jean-Christophe cambadellis qui vient
nous rejoindre en direct juste pour
quelques petits mots Jean-Christophe
cambadellis tout d'abord le résultat de
François Hollande est-ce qu'il vous
surprend c'est la question que je posais
à Claude Bartelone qui lui avait l'air
plutôt surpris par ce bon score bah
écoutez être de devant Nicolas Sarkozi
ce n'est pas la victoire encore mais ça
lui ressemble personne s'y attendait
c'est la première fois sur la 5e
République que vous avez un président
sortant battu dès le premier tour
concernant le score de Marine Le Pen
parce qu'on en a pas encore parlé mais
qui arrive à quasiment 20 % des voix
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de ce score et
de l'influence qu'il peut avoir pour le
deuxème tour c'est important c'est
important il faut le noter mais c'est
une autre sanction de Nicolas Sarkozi il
avait dit qu'il faisait campagne à
droite à l'extrême droite pour réduire
le Front national il ne l'a pas réduit
il n'a fait que le faire progresser
c'est vraiment une sanction contre
Nicolas Sarkozi contre les politiques en
général bah plutôt contre Nicolas
Sarkozi parce que François Hollande
n'est pas encore sortant on verra ça
peut-être dans 5 ans merci beaucoup
Jean-Christophe cambalce et je vous
signale toujours qu'il y a de plus en
plus de monde rut Solferino la clameur
se fait entendre ici dans la cour
bergovois où nous trouvons Rud Solferino
merci beaucoup Michel et on se retrouve
bien sûr très vite rutsol Ferrino le
siège du Parti socialiste un petit mot
avec vous Bruno lerou et puis avec vous
Fabien sur où vous en êtes dans vos
comptes sur ce que constitue aujourd'hui
le bloc de gauche dont on sait que c'est
essentiel de connaître ce chiffre pour
essayer d'anticiper le deuxè tour
écoutez un point qui est important il
est 43 aux alentours de 43 % il va
s'affiner très certainement pendant la
soirée c'est-à-dire plus fort qu'il ne
l'était il y a maintenant 4 5 ans 4 qure
à voir 4 à 5 points de plus donc voilà
c'est une dimension importante et dans
le même temps je le redis ici au deè
tour les 60 propositions elles visent à
rassembler largement très largement 43
Fabien nous disait que est 46 plutôt
hein pour être sûr de passer au second
exactement donc 43 % voilà c'est un
terrain plutôt favorable plutôt
favorable donc c'est le scénario
peut-être gris non pas gris plutôt rose
quand même prendre la typologie de
François Hollande qui s'attendait à so
scénario noir gris ou rose aujourd'hui
vous êtes sur quelle couleur c'est un
scénario qui laisse entrevoir pour
beaucoup de Français le changement
possible le changement possible et en
même temps je le redis par rapport à ce
que je viens l'entendre moi je suis très
content ce soir je suis très content
d'un très bon premier tour et en même
temps tout est à jouer tout reste à
jouer pour le second tour tout doit être
fait pour la mobilisation modestie de
bonalois de celui qui remporte le
premier tour c'est pas c'est pas la
mobilisation c'est la mobilisation se
doit être de ne pas voler au français
leur victoire ils ont envie moi la leçon
que je tire de ce premier tour c'est que
très majoritairement ils ont envie de
faire partir Nicolas Sarkozi ne leur
enlevons pas aujourd'hui cette fête
qu'ils doivent pouvoir avoir le 6 mai
c'est eux qui décideront encore une fois
si vous voulez l' SAR jusqu'à preu du
contraire n'est pas un pour la France
nous nous allons proposer à la France
sur ce deuxième tour effectivement des
propositions non mais l'antisarkozisme
nous ne proposons pas le sarkozisme
monsieur lerou et manifestement et
manifestement l'arrogance de Monsieur
Cambadelis que je ne retrouve pas
effectivement dans votre bouche monsieur
lerou l'arrogance de Monsieur Cambadelis
montre à quel point l'état PS est en
route à quel point il y a cette volonté
de revanche vous voyez dans le sourire
de Monsieur cambadellis elle sa
gourmandise cette volonté manifestement
d'écrasere et bien moi je dis à tous les
Français qui n'ont pas envie de cela à
tous les Français qui veulent autre
chose pour la France qui veulent
notamment un projet et des propositions
concrètes et cohérentes rejoignez Nicola
Sarkozi pour ce deuxème tour monsieur
lerou vous êtes quand même interpellé
par le très bon score de Marine Le Pen
on n pas encore regardé dans le détail
mais on sait qu'elle fait un score
supérieur par exemple à Jean-Luc
Mélenchon dans les classes populaires
parmi les ouvriers et là la gauche n pas
forcément au rendez-vous quand on
regarde parmi les classes les plus
populair aurions-nous dû faire plus
aurionsnous dû Ener encore plus au
contact aurionsnous dû nous avons décidé
de faire du porte à porte pour aller
distribuer les 15 millions d'exemplaires
les 60 propositions mais bien entendu il
reste 15 jours donc il faut faire
campagne et ces électeurs sont des
électeurs qui ont crié leur
mécontentement moi je veux aller
répondre avec les propositions de
François Hollande pas celle de Marine Le
Pen et continuer à leur dire que c'était
un mauvais choix que de la choisir mais
qu'en même temps ils veulent en finir
avec le sarkoziis il y a une autre voie
possible d'accord en tous les cas le
score de Marine Le Pen qui a réussi son
entreprise de dédiabolisation on peut le
dire comme ça on a répété au cours de
cette soirée qu'elle avait qu'elle
s'était installé dans le paysage fait
énormément réagir peut-être plus encore
que les autres scores sur le web ce soir
c'est ce que vous nous confirmez
Caroline Deschamp oui tout à fait Michel
Twitter est plutôt abassourdi par le
score de Marine Le Pen et le record du
FN ce qui fait dire à julière bon je
peux le dire maintenant je suis bien
honteuse pour mon pays Marine Le Pen 20
% aucune victoire ce soir cause toujours
lui est plus fataliste désolé les gars
mais même si ça vous gonfle les 20 % de
Marine Le Pen reste démocratique juste
un fait certains estiment que la faute
en revient à Patrick Buisson le
conseiller de Nicolas Sarkozi à son
virage droitier pour d'autres comme Emer
d'liger Mélenchon n'a pas su être le
catalyseur de la colère des Français
cela va être compliqué écrit-il Sylvain
lapois noteli que Sarkozi est obligé de
raller les voix du FN pour battre
Hollande au second tour il écrit
l'inquiétant c'est maintenant et puis
beaucoup point les Institutes de sondage
qui ont globalement plutôt sous-estimé
les résultats de Marine Le Pen Guber
renbau m'écrit les sondeurs vont devoir
s'expliquer de même Éric mayillard ça va
encore être une soirée à thème institut
de sondage on va vous faire votre fête
beaucoup attendent ce soir les résultats
définitifs sur les réseaux sociaux mer
Caroline alors forcément là on va donner
la parole à notre représentant d'un
institut de sondage sur ce plateau
Fabienne c'est vrai qu'on pense au 21
avril c'était il y a 10 ans on avait
beaucoup dit voilà personne n'a vu venir
le phénomène du FN là encore qu'est-ce
que vous vous dites ce soir alors ce
qu'on a vu venir quand même ces derniers
jours c'est une progression des
intentions de vote en faveur de Marine
Le Pen c'est vrai que la dernière nous
intention de vote chez hsos qu'on a
publié elle était à 16 % d'inttention de
vote en progression donc ça c'était
c'était jeudi soir et clairement il y
avait une dynamique une dynamique qui se
portait sur alors puisqu'on est avec
vous on VI de vous donner la parole on
va justement commencer à regarder des
des études que que vous avez fait fait
on va regarder ça tout de suite sur cet
écran on va apparaître un premier
résultat alors vous avez posé la
question voilà est-ce que quand lorsque
vous êtes allé voter c'était un vote de
soutien ou d'opposition à Nicolas
Sarkozi soutien 26 % opposition 53 % ni
l'un ni l'autre 21 % Valérie rossseau
Debord comment vous réagissez à ces
études qualitatives sur le vote ouvrier
puisque là on est clairement sur le vote
ouvrier effectivement si vous voulez il
y a clairement une désespérance on voit
53 % du vote
d'opposition là on était sur le vote
ouvrier enfin pr voilà en fait on a on a
on a interrogé les Français sur leur
motivation de vote et on leur a
notamment posé la question de savoir
s'ils souhaitaent à travers leur vote
d'aujourd'hui manifester leur soutien ou
leur opposition à Nicolas Sarkozi 53 %
d'entre eux ont déclaré leur opposition
et 26 % leur leur soutien donc on a
manifestement quand même un message de
sanction qui a été envoyé aujourd'hui
dans les de rejet
référend qui Ava été en avant NOTAM par
la GAE oui mais si vous voulez après
nous ce que nous disons c'est qu'à
partir de ce soir autre chose commence
oui mais si vous voulez c'est
importantés oui mais oui mais si vous
voulez analyser les résultats du premier
tour c'est intéressant mais
som som toutoute ce qui est intéressant
aussi c'est de se projeter sur un second
tour puisque ce qui est important c'est
qui va gagner le 6 c'est pas au ce soir
qu'on gagne c'est bien le si vous êtes
d'accord avec moi donc c'est là en fait
que les choses vont se voir ce qui est
important aujourd'hui pour nous c'est de
dire vous avez fait effectivement un
choix sur ce premier tour sur le
deuxième tour il reste Nicolas Sarkozi
et François Hollande à vous de voir par
rapport à vos convictions et vos valeurs
qui s'en rapproche le plus c'est nous
allons regardz le deuxième tableau qui
va vous intéresser également sur les
enjeux qui ont pesé dans le choix des
Français on découvre donc que le pouvoir
d'achat arrive en tête suivi de la crise
économique et financière le chômage les
inégalités sociales l'immigration
arrivant en dernier donc on avait bien
dit au cours de cette campagne qu'il y
avait peut-être des erreurs quant à
certains candidats sur les priorités des
Français alors ça pour le coup j' dire
toutes les enquêtes préélectorales le
montrer cette campagne se jouait
essentiellement sur des préoccupations
économiques et sociales juste peut-être
un un détail une précision à vous
apportter c'est c'est vrai que
l'immigration est citée par 24 % des
électeurs en moyenne dans le corps
électoral comme un enjeu qui a pesé dans
leur choix mais par 61 % des électeurs
qui ont glissé dans l'urne le vote le
bulletin de Marine Le Pen cétait les
prior ét les préoccupations vous avez
également interrogé les personnes pour
leur demander à quel moment
véritablement et ben ça il s'était mis
d'accord sur ce sur quoi ils allaient
voter alors on va regarder tout de suite
les résultats le moment du choix de vote
c'était il y a plusieurs mois pour 61 %
des personnes interrogées c'était il y a
quelques semaines pour 20 % c'était ces
derniers jours pour 12 % et nous l'avons
fait au dernier moment ça c'est 7 % donc
finalement des tendances assez lourdes
qui était là depuis plusieurs mois déjà
Fabian Simon Bruno lou ça pardon je
crois deux choses la première chose
c'est que c'est une élection
effectivement qui s'est joué de depuis
longtemps on est davantage sur un modèle
un petit peu 1981 où vraiment les
fondamentaux de l'opinion étit posés
depuis longtemps et la campagne
évidemment a joué un rôle à infléchi
mais n'a pas bouleversé les rapport de
force à la différence d'autres campagnes
plus récentes autre phénomène évidemment
que ce que ces chiffres illustrent c'est
à quel point l'indécision aujourd'hui
des électeurs reste une donnée difficile
effectivement à prendre en compte et ce
jusque dans les derniers jours puisque
on a un électeur sur 5me du pourcentage
d'unc manifestement qu'on nous avait
annoncé ces derniers jours là
manifestement ça n'est que 7 % oui 7 %
au dernier moment mais ces derniers
jours 12
% que vouz dire Bruno lerou sur l'idée
que ces tendances elles étaient lourdes
et qu'elles existaient depuis plusieurs
semaines vous l'expliquez comment vous
allez me dire par le briillau de la
campagne de Françis je crois que ça
relativise d'ailleurs aussi un peu les
campagnes électorales que ces chiffres
ça montre bien que le résultat d'une
élection présidentielle les Français le
marquent par rapport à l'action pendant
5 ans d'un président de la République et
pas simplement à une campagne électorale
et donc pas simplement pas une adhésion
à François Hollande c'est d'abord un
rejet de Nicolas
saration il y a bien entendu les deux
quand on veut demain être président de
la République on met tôt et nous je
rappelle que dès le mois de janvier nous
avons mis les 60 propositions sur la
table que Nicolas Sarkozi l'a fait il y
a 15 jours et donc nous avons discuté
des propositions mais le vote qui est le
vote aujourd'hui des Français est aussi
profondément un vote accès vers le
changement un changement de président
ils ne veulent plus aujourd'hui de
Nicolas Sarkozi et je considère que
pendant 15 jours il faut encore leur
donner toutes les raisons sur les points
qui les
intéressour nous attend MAM avec un
nouvel invité et c'est Jeanpierre chev
qu'on trouve à vos côté mich
oui Michel absolument monsieur chev qui
accepte de répondre à nos questions en
direct monsieur chev tout d'abord
François Hollande ce est-ce que vous
attendiez à ce résultat et qu'est-ce
qu'il veut dire ce résultat pour vous
oui je m'y attendais et je trouve que
c'est bien car c'est la première fois
quand même depuis le début de la 5e
République qu'un président sortant est
distancé au premier tour François
Hollande est nettement en tête et je
pense que à partir de là il peut mener
une stratégie de rassemblement non
seulement de la gauche mais de tous les
républicains pour battre Nicolas Sarkozi
le 6 mai c'est un vote d'adhésion de
François Hollande ou c'est un vote de
rejet de Nicolas sarzi ce soir et bien
écoutez c'est les deux il y a des gens
qui vont voter pour François Hollande
parce qu'il symbolise plus de justice
sociale la reconstruction d'un état
républicain impartial de meilleurs
services
publics l'amorce d'une
reconstruction
de de ce qu'on appelle la République et
puis il y en a d'autres qui seront
davantage m par l'exaspération et la
colère et qui iront davantage non à
Nicolas Sarkozi mais dans le négatif il
y aura aussi du positif Jean-Pierre
chevement tout le monde se rappelle de
2002 et de la présence du Fond national
au 2è tour ce soir Marine Le Pen est à
plus de quasiment 20 % des voix ce qui
est un score quasiment historique
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de ce score
effectivement est-ce qu'il vous gâche la
fête effectivement c'est un score
supérieur à celui qu'avait fait
Jean-Marie Le Pen même au 2è tour de
2001 mais je n'ai jamais cru de 2002
mais je n'ai jamais cru que Jean-Marie
Le Pen pouvait l'emporter d'ailleurs il
n'a pas vraiment augmenté son score
entre les deux
tours SC pas la f ce soir Marine Le Pen
est éliminé
donc maintenant les électeurs ils vont
devoir choisir je crois que beaucoup
d'entre eux sont frustrés exaspérés à
l'égard de Monsieur Sarkozi et le
partage des voix ne se fera peut-être
pas comme certains le croi merci
beaucoup Monsieur Merci d'AV avoir
répondu en direct ici rue de Solferino
c'est à VOUS Michel Émilie merci
beaucoup et sans transition on fil
maintenant tout de suite retrouver
Germain Andrieux à l'UMP Germain vous
êtes avec Bruno Le
Maire oui exactement je suis au côté de
Bruno Le Maire qui vient tout juste qui
était à l'Élysée avec Nicolas Sarkozi a
participé donc à la Réunion stratégique
avec les proches de la campagne Bruno Le
Maire a rédigé le projet de cette
campagne à synthétiser toutes les
propositions alors aujourd'hui Brou le
maire bonsoir quelle est votre réaction
les on don le verdict de Nicolas SAR
qualifié pour ce second tour mais en deè
position c'était pas forcément le
scénario rêvé pour l'UMP non mais je
crois que non seulement tout est
possible mais nous avons vraiment avec
les scoresu ce soir la possibilité de
voir Nicolas SAR l'emporter au second
tour ce que je tire comme leçon c'est
d'abord une très forte participation
donc la conscience que les Français ont
de la gravité de l'enjeu la gravité de
cette élection présidentielle ils
veulent pas se faire voler le vote par
qui que ce soit d'autre ils iront aux
urnesè son que je tire c'est qu'il y a
évidemment un vote de crise qui n'est
pas une surprise le score élevé du Front
national n'est pas pour moi une surprise
parce qu'on le voit dans nos
circonscriptions on le voit dans nos
région beaucoup de Français touchés par
la crise économique et qui manifeste
très fortement leur mécontentement et
puis la troisième leçon la plus
importante c'est que maintenant on
rentre dans une campagne totalement
différente ça va être projet contre
projet François Hollande contre Nicolas
Sarkozi et je pense que les Français
verront comprendront que le projet que
porte Nicolas Sarkozi est le seul qui
permet de garantir un avenir fort à la
France tout de même vous venez d'en
parler ce score inattendu de Marine Le
Pen à près de 20 % à plus de 20 % est-ce
que quelque part c'est pas un désaveux
de la stratégie du premier tour on a
beaucoup reproché au président d'écouter
trop monsieur buisson est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui et bien les électeurs ont
préféré l'original à la copie je crois
que ça montre au contraire que il y a
une attente très forte de la part de
beaucoup de Français sur le rappel des
règles républicaine sur le respect d'un
certain nombre de principes sur le
respect d'un certain nombre de valeurs
et moi ce que je souhaite pour le second
tour c'est qu'on nentre évidemment pas
dans les tractations comme le fait
aujourd'hui le Parti socialiste avec le
Front de gauche mais qu'on tienne bon
sur nos valeurs nos convictions et notre
projet notre projet c'est moins de
dépenses publi c'est la défense de la
souveraineté nationale c'est le
renforcement des capacités de production
dans notre pays c'est le rappel d'un
certain nombre de principes de valeurs
sur les règles républicaines je pense
qu'en tenant bon sur nos valeurs Nicolas
Sarkozi l'emportera pour conclure il il
est l'heure de rassembler pour ce second
tour ou d'aller chercher les électeurs
de Marine Le Pen il faut pas aller
chercher qui que ce soit il faut pas
commencer à rentrer dans les tractations
il faut tenir bon sur nos valeurs nos
convictions notre projet les Français
verront parce que ils sont lucides que
le projet porté par Nicolas Sarkozi est
de très loin celui qui permet de
garantir le meilleur avenir à la France
Merci Merci voilà cétait en direct de la
mutualité et dans quelques instants et
bien Nicolas Sarkozi ne devrait pas
tarder à venir s'exprimer devant les
militants 20h53 effectivement on attend
l'intervention du candidat UMP dans
quelques minutes de devrait suivre en
tout cas dans le même lapse de temps
Marine Le Pen est également annoncé nous
ont rejoint sur ces plateaux sur ce
plateau et on les en remercie Stéphane
roses politologue du Cap bonsoir merci
d'être avec nous Didier Guillaume
vice-président du Sénat sénateur
socialiste de la Drome Roger carucci
qu'on remercie également d'être passé
par le plateau des chaînes
parlementaires sénateur UMP des haut
scèes et puis Élisabeth chavelet bonsoir
ellisabeth de Paris Match alors
justement on écoute d'abord la
journaliste hein on vous écoutez très
attentif ce qui dit sur ce plateau ce
qui se dit dans les QG vous aviez l'air
assez interpellé frappé par ce qui s'est
changé ce soir par le climat oui j'étais
très frappé de ce que disaent vos deux
invités je trouve qui illustre un peu
l'avance d'un et le retard de l'au
Valérie rut de bord d'abord je crois que
elle elle refuse de voir les faiblesses
de de Nicolas Sarkozi et de sa campagne
j'en citerai bon uniquement deux la
première qu'on a largement cité c'estir
focaliser sa campagne sur les thèmes
pour siphonner les voies du Front
national que sont l'immigration et la
sécurit
vos s mon que les préoccupations des
Français ne sont pas là c'est le pouvoir
d'achat et d'ailleurs c'est Mar le P qui
l'emporte ça c'est évident et donc ça
c'est une chose qui me frappe énormément
et deuxièmement elle refuse de voir que
moi je crois que cette campagne illustre
que le fait que les Français ont moins
rejeté la politique du président parce
que l'histoire lui rendra grâce il a
fait des réformes que son être profond
avec des marqueurs profond que qui on
été le bling bling enfin tout ce qu'on
connaît le C et par ailleurs à côté il y
avait donc Bruno lerou qui était là qui
lui a capitalisé sur les forces qui ont
fait les forces de Nicolas Sarkozi
pendant cette campagne un candidat de
rassemblement contre un candidat qui
clivait ça c'est très important et
deuxièmement un candidat de François
Hollande et deuxièmement unand un
candidat qui dit j'ai fait 60
propositions en janvier je m'y tiens j'y
reste j'ai de la cohérence par rapport à
un autre qui zigzague vous faites sour
Roger car qui va don la parole dans
quelques secondes parce que il a répété
au moins 10 fois on aller
voirite de deux parties qui sont
satisfaits ce soir on va aller à Thul
dans un instant il y a eu une explosion
de joie tout à l'heure et mais d'abord
nous retournons au Front national donc
dans cette salle du 15e arrondissement
de Paris c'est la salle éekinox et
Mathilde terrier vous vous trouvez avec
Steve briwais
oui Steve Briis secrétaire général du FN
alors 20 % un score historique c'est
Paris réussi ce soir c'est Paris réussi
c'est aussi une grande claque à tous les
sondeur et autres politologues qui nous
avaient enterré et qui avait mis
Monsieur Mélenchon à un niveau très
élevé et donc aujourd'hui bien c'est une
grande victoire c'est la victoire du
peuple du vrai peuple pas du peuple des
élites du peuple celui qui qui n'a
jamais la possibilité de s'exprimer donc
ce soir c'est une grande victoire pour
nos idées alors maintenant il va falloir
penser au second tour est-ce que une
alliance est possible écoutez Nicolas
sarzi et François Hollande c'est la même
chose donc donc nous n'avons aucun
espoir de quoi que ce soit ni avec l'un
ni avec l'autre en revanche Marine Le
Pen donnera sa position de vote au Pr le
1er mai lors de
son de sa manifestation traditionnelle
et nous donons surtout rendez-vous aux
électeurs au mois de juin pour confirmer
mais amplifier la la vague marine alors
justement la campagne présidentielle se
tourne celle des législatives s'ouvre et
surtout àinbaaumont vous êtes justement
bien placé pour en parler vous êtes
conseiller municipal à hinbaaumont là où
Marine Le Pen va être candidate et je
crois que ce soir elle a recueilli 40 %
des souffrages effectivement elle a
obtenu plus de 40 % sur la la
communeumont et sur la circonscription
mais je pense surtout à toutes les
autres circonscriptions aux
circonscriptions qui n'ont pas de
députés à cause d'un mode de scrutin
unique puisque aujourd'hui en France un
parti qui représente 20 % des Français
n'a aucun député cela est scandaleux et
bien je je pense que les électeurs du
Front national vont se mobiliser à
nouveau au mois de juin pour mettre un
nouveau coup de pied au système et pour
envoyer des députés au du Front
Nationale à l'Assemblée nationale merci
St merci à vous voilà il y a un autre
merci Mathilde un autre représentant du
Front national Florian Filippo qui vient
de déclarer Marine Le Pen devient ce
soir la chef de l'opposition le score de
Marine Le Pen légèrement revu à la
baisse dans nos dernières estimations
elle ne serait plus à 20 % mais à
19,6 pour
rogci très brièvement votre commentaire
sur sur ce score du Front national
attendez je vous coupe parce que Nicolas
sarzi vous m'y autoriserez Marine Le Pen
Marine Le Pen pardonnez-moi va est en
train d'arriver suivi par des ordes de
caméras bien sûr elle va rejoindre la
tribune elle avait annoncé qu'elle
s'exprimerait à 21h il est
20h58 bain de foule pour Marine le P
donc donné à
19,6% avec nos dernières estimations
pouvez vous avez le temps le temps
qu'elle remonte jusqu'à ça elle est sur
l'estrad elle est sur l'estrade elle va
s'exprimer dans quelques secondes en
direct sur la chaîne
parlementaireen de vainqueurs ce soirog
c'est le score le plus important du
Front national à une élection
présidentielle puisque le score de
Jean-Marie Le Pen donc était de 16,8 %
c'était en 2002 et que du 2è tour sur
les deux vainqueurs même si je reconnais
le très fort score de Marine Le Pen mais
ce sera de et notamment au mien de
convaincre l'ensemble des électeurs de
François Baayou de Marine Le Pen comme
des autres de se reporter sur des
valeurs sur un certain nombre de projets
sur des choses
essentiellesout attente à la table des
élites ce premier tour n'est pas une fin
en soi mais le
commencement d'un vaste rassemblement
des patriotes de droite comme de gauche
des amoureux de la France et des
défenseurs de son
identité des amoureux de l'exception
française quoi qu'il puisse
arriver dans les 15 jours à
venir la bataille de France ne fait que
commencer chers amis
français rien ne sera plus jamais comme
avant car face à tout le système
coalisé à coup de mensonge et de faux
sondages nous tous ensemble avons fait
exploser le monopole des deux parties de
la banque de la
finance des
multinationales du renoncement et de
l'abandon
nous avons porté plus haut que jamais
les idées
nationales mais il ne s'agit là que d'un
début
maintenant face à un président sortant à
la tête d'un parti considérablement
affaibli nous sommes désormais la seule
et véritable opposition à la gauche
ultralibérale
TER dans la France dans la France
déclocher des terroirs dans nos
campagnes dans nos grandes régions
industrielles les ouvriers les
agriculteurs les pêcheurs les petits
fonctionnaires les commerçants et les AR
on tous ceux qui travaillent et qui
souffrent qui ont la France au cœur tout
cela ont fait monter la vague bleu
marine qui fait ce soir je vous le dis
tremblez le
système mais mais j'ai besoin de vous
pour continuer le travail à accomplir et
le renverser définitivement pour rendre
au peuple français sa liberté sa
souveraineté sa dignité sa
fierté tous
ensemble dans ce grand élan de
fraternité que nous incarnons nous
imposerons le grand changement que vous
attendez car tous unis tous
rassembler tout est possible maintenant
c'est le chemin du renouveau national du
retour de la croissance de la
restauration du pouvoir d'achat et de
l'emploi de la sécurité rétablie
du bonheur d'être français enfin
retrouvé c'est ce chemin que nous sommes
en train
d'emprunter mes amis il nous mène au
retour de la
France des millions de Français ce soir
sont entrés en résistance ça n'est qu'un
début continuons le combat bravo et
merci
Didier Guillaume une réaction à ce que
vous venez d'entendre avec nous en
direct Marine Le Pen qui a un discours
plus combatif que jamais elle a fait
mieux que renouveler l'exploit de son
père en 2002 elle fait un meilleur score
elle a fait mieux que son père en 2002
elle fait un score très important et je
crois qu'il faut en prendre le prendre
en compte de quelle manière ce que je
constate c'est que en 5 ans Nicolas
Sarkozi a un bilan qui fait du Front
national à 10 % à un Front national à 20
% et donc la politique menée depuis 5
ans a échoué tous les tous les Oubliés
toutes celles et tous ceux qui souffrent
qui ne se reconnaissent pas dans la
politique ont voulu donner un signal et
par rapport à ce premier tour que nous
devons prendre avec beaucoup de sérieux
beaucoup d'intérêt ce que nous disons
nous c'est que il faut aller plus loin
il faut de la cohérence dans un projet
pas des allers-retours des atermoements
et François Hollande peut face à un
président isolé peut incarner le
rassemblement et vraiment il faut une
grande mobilisation parce que le score
du frontc National ce n'est pas rien
nous l'avons jamais obtenu en France
encore ce n'est pas rien Stéphane Rosas
puis Roger carucci effectivement ce
score ça n'est pas rien c'est même l'une
des principales infos de cette soirée et
ce alors même Stéphane Ros qu'on sait
que Patrick guisson conseiller très
influent de Nicolas Sarkozi avait poussé
à une droitisation de la campagne c'est
l'échec de cette stratégie ce soir oui
c'est c'est l'échec en fait il y avait
deux lignes la ligne Henry guot et la
ligne Patrick Buisson ils avaient en
commun l'idée qu' avait d'un côté le
peuple les élites mais il y a un
désaccord sur les raisons pour
lesquelles en 2007 Nicolas Sarkozi a
récupéré l'électorat du Front national
Henry Guenot pensait à mon avis à juste
titre que c'était en donnant à chacun
une place positive au sein de la nation
travail mérite pouvoir d'achat là où
Patrick Buisson disait non non le Front
National est allé trop loin sur les
questions sociales il passe à gauche il
faut aller sur sécurité immigration donc
là très clairement on l'avait vu lors du
discours de Grenoble ou dans les
intentions de vote Marine Le Pen même
potentiellement aurait pu être au deème
tour sélection avait lieu donc on avait
vu à cette époque clairement que la
ligne Patrick Buisson était une erreur
stratégique ça veut dire que le succès
de Marine Le Pen ne vient pas seulement
de cette erreur de stratégie mais
beaucoup on l'avait vu lors du discours
de Grenoble ça veut dire surtout que la
victoire de Marine Le Pen est double non
seulement elle fait en soin un bon score
mais elle va peser dans l'entre de Tours
parce que cette stratégie erronée fait
que Nicolas Sarkozi par exemple lors du
débat face à à François Hollande alors
que d'habitude on regarde au centre va
être très tiraillé pour regarder à
droite l'erreur qu'avait fait Chac
cherac en 88 d'ailleurs qui avait fait
la victoire de François mitteron là où
François Hollande n'a qu'à regarder au
centre parce que mécaniquement il aura
les les reports et donc Marine Le Pen va
peser sur l'entre de tour et si les pour
l'instant les transferts de voie
montrent que ce serait environ 45 55 si
on voit large sur les transferts de voix
de l'électorat FN à 50 ça veut dire que
si Nicolas Sarkozy perd la
présidentielle Marine Le Pen est en
situation de recomposer la droite parce
que déjà au sein de l'UMP certains comme
la Droite populaire n'est-ce pas sont
pour faire des CS donc François Baayou
s'exprime en direct sur notre antenne et
Roger CCI vous allez bien sûr avoir la
parole juste après François Baayou le
candidat du MoDem on va l'écouter en
direct toutite sur la situation du pays
cette inquiétude est ce soir brûlante
l'extrême droite à 20 % en France en
2012 c'est la gravité de la crise étalée
devant tous les yeux crise du chômage
crise économique crise sociale crise
morale et ces crises
s'additionnent alors bien sûr notre
score est au-dessous de nos attentes
mais ce que nous avions vu et
diagnostiqué de l'état du pays de l'état
réel du pays est là plus impressionnant
que jamais
le mal français est là et il s'aggrave
et le seul chemin disponible pour en
sortir ce sera un jour ou l'autre celui
que nous avons proposé aux Français une
politique nouvelle courageuse qui aille
pour une fois au fond des choses soutenu
par une union nationale pour remettre le
pays sur ses railles je vais m'adresser
aux deux candidats sélectionnés pour le
deuxè tour je vais leur dire ce qui est
pour nous l'essentiel en terme de valeur
en terme d'action à conduire j'écouterai
dans les jours qui viennent leurs
réponses et je prendrai mes
responsabilités mais il suffit de
regarder ce paysage éclaté le trouble du
pays les difficultés économiques et
financières pour comprendre que ce qu'il
faut pour l'avenir ce qu'il faut
construire d'urgence c'est une force
d'équilibre au centre qui résiste aux
extrêmes et aux démagogies c'est cette
force que nous devons construire avec
tous les démocrates et les républicains
et nous devons aussi construire les
institutions nouvelles qui empêcheront
l'explosion qui menace du pays nous
serons présents à ce rendez-vous nous
construirons cet avenir je vous
remercie Françis Baayou avec la phrase
effectivement il a dit qu'il prendrait
ses responsabilités vous vous sentez
interpellés tous les deux Didier
Guillaume peut-être il a jugé pendant
toute la campagne que le projet de
François Hollande n'était pas tenable
est-ce que vous allez pouvoir rassurer
François Baayou fort de ses 8 et de % de
VO nous pensons qu'il est tenable et
qu'il est cohérent la force de François
Hollande c'est d'avoir présenté un
projet de cohérence et à partir de là il
y aura sûrement entre les deux tours bah
des ajuste
non
justobjetifour n pas nelle é c'est la
suite de la première c'est deuxè
tour attende attendez et on regarde ce
qui s'est passé au premier tour mais
nous ne sommes pas là pour aller
chercher telle ou telle voie François
Hollande a dit très clairement qu'il
veut rassembler les Français il
rassembla la gauche et toutes C pour
luiouver la vérité c'est que euh nous
par exemple Nicolas Sarkozi s'adressera
au peuple français il va pas s'adresser
à l'électorat de Marine Le Pen à
l'électorat de François Baou quand il
dit réduction des déficits réduction des
dettes réduction de la dépense publique
ça correspond à ce que dit François
baayrou quand il dit non au droit de
vote pour les étrangers ça correspond à
ce que dit Marine Le Pen pour autant il
y a pas un appel aux un app proposé ce
qui avait été murmuré qu'il soit Premier
ministre il appelle clairement à voter
pour Nicolas SAR pour vous c'est desl
franis Baou lui-même disait qu'il n
était pas
ours il dit je veux voir sur les valeurs
sur les valeurs nous on a toujours dit
avec François Ba qui a gouverné avec
nous un temps qu'on partage beaucoup de
valeurs communes et par conséquent on
aura évidemment des discussions tout à
fait det peut pas vraiment croire par
rapport à ce qui s'est passé depuis 5
ans en plus qu'avec vous avec la
création de la qui sera au cœur du débat
du deuxème tour en attendant on part
tout de suite pour le Front de Gauche ou
Martine Billard et tu nos MICR je crois
le Front de Gauche tout de suite
ce combat aujourd'hi oui absolument
Martine Billard est à côté de moi la
coprésidente du Parti de Gauche madame
Billard on vient d'entendre un slogan
ici on ne lâche rien est-ce que c'est
votre état d'esprit du moment ce soir
oui absolument depuis le début nous
disons qu'il faut absolument battre
Sarkozi battre l'UMP parce que tant que
eux restent au pouvoir on ne peut rien
faire et on a des politiques qui sont
les politiques d'austérité menées dans
toute l'Europe donc l'objectif est
toujours le même il faut battre Sarkozi
battre Sarkozi massivement et le front
gauche a les responsabilités dans cette
bataille et nous continuons comme nous
l'avons fait jusqu'ici donc vous allez
bien sûr voter François Hollande
pourtant le nom de françoisutante n'a
pas été prononcé tout à l'heure dans le
discours de Jean-Luc Mélenchon ici même
parce que depuis le début nous disons
l'élection présidentielle fait qu'au
deuxè tour il y a deux candidats donc il
y a deux bulletins de vote à partir du
moment où nous disons nous voulons
battre Sarkozi parce que c'est la seule
manière de mener d'autres politiques et
pour le Front de Gauche d'aller vers ses
objectifs donc évidemment nous
utiliserons le bulletin de vote qui
reste pour battre Sarko qu' a e
martinard est-ce que vous vous êtes
senti seul dans cette campagne comme l'a
souligné tout à l'heure Jean-Luc
Mélenchon ici même est-ê oui absolument
parce que quand nous avons expliqué
qu'il fallait faire reculer le Front
national d'autres ont trouvé qu'il
c'était plus utile de taper sur Jean-Luc
Mélanchon que de faire reculer le Front
national nous regrettons nous disons
qu'ils auraient mieux fait de se battre
avec nous parce que aujourd'hui on voit
le résultat mais nous ne désespérons pas
il y a encore la bataille pour le deème
tour la bataille pour les législatives
donc avec le Front de gauche du trop
contre le Front national qu'est-ce qui
vous déçoit le plus dans ce score est-ce
que c'est le score élevé du Front
national ou le score qu'aurait pu
imaginer meilleur de Jean-Luc Mélenchon
mais quand nous regardons les scores
nous voyons que le total de gauche est
plutôt plus élevé et ce grâce au au
Front de gauche il y a très longtemps
qu'il y avait pas une force de la
puissance du Front de Gauche en dehors
du Parti socialiste donc c'est un bon
point c'est une force organisée c'est
une force mobilisée qui va continuer
c'est pas seulement un score de ce soir
c'est une force qui va continuer à se
battre qui sera dans le 1er mai avec les
syndicats qui sera le 6 mai pour battre
Sarkozi qui continuera au législative et
après nous n'oublions pas les
travailleurs qui aujourd'hui sont en
lutte pour empêcher les licenciements
nous sommes à leur côté nous n'allons
pas les laisser tomber nous continuons
avec eux c'est le Front de gauche qui va
faire la gauche de demain Martine Bard
c'est absolument notre objectif et nous
sommes optimistes quand nous voyons tout
le dynamisme qu'il y a et encore ce soir
sur cette place merci beaucoup Martine
Billard d'avoir été avec nous en direct
de la Place stalinerade ici à Paris
merci Pierre-Henri gergon et on rappelle
le score de Jean-Luc Mélenchon d'après
nos dernières estimations
11,7 % des voix on vous précise
également sous le contrôle de Fabiane
Simon dipsos que d'ici une petite
demi-heure on devrait commencer à voir
vos projections pour le deè tour ultime
information François Hollande se
préparerait à intervenir à Thul bien sûr
une intervention qu'on vous fera suivre
en direct sur notre antenne en attendant
je me tourne vers Roger carucci qui ne
nous a pas tout à fait répondu tout à
l'heure j'ai pas eu la question moi je
répond question commche ou non l'échec
ou non à vos yeux de la stratégie de
droitisation qui a été soulignée par les
observateurs l'influence de Patrick
Buisson dans cette campagne fait que
vous n'avez pas parlé des bons thèmes
dans cette campagne de premier tour
attendez moi je sais pas je rentre pas
dans le détail je je vois que nos amis
sont passionnés par l'idée est-ce que
c'est Guo est-ce que c'est buisson moi
je n'ai qu'un candidat c'est Nicolas moi
je n'ai qu'un candidat c'est Nicolas
Sarkozi qui est censé faire la synthèse
du tout qui ce soit sur les problèmes
sociaux que ce soit sur les problèmes
d'identité soit sur les problèmes de
nation par conséquent moi mon candidat
il s'appelle Nicolas Sarkozi il
s'appelle ni non il s'appelle ni Guo ni
buisson pour qui j'ai de l'estime pour
l'un pour l'autre mais c'est pas eux les
candidats le seul candidat c'est celui
qui rassemble c'est donc Nicolas Sarkozi
vous me dites est-ce que ça stratégie a
été la bonne pardon de rappeler je dis
ça je dis rien que au mois de janvier on
disait mais il sera même pas au deuxème
tour le voilà au deè tour maintenant on
me dit est-ce que c'était la bonne
stratégie attendons les jours qui
viennent attendons la capacité de l'un
et de l'autre de répondre aux
aspirations aux attentes aux inquiétudes
parce que dans le vote du FN comm pour
parler très clair est-ce que vous
parlerez moins de sécurité d'immigration
davantage de pouvoir d'achat dans les 15
jours qui viennent Roger kou des trois
thèmes moi je vois pas pourquoi estce
que si vous parlez de sécurité et
d'immigration il faut pas parler de
pouvoir d'achat pourquoi voulez-vous
sectoriser la vie des gens comm ça
suffisamment parler de pouvoir d'achat
dans cette campagne de pr moi je crois
que Nicolas Sarkozi a beaucoup parlé de
pouvoir d'achat beaucoup parlé d'Europe
a beaucoup parlé d'emploi alors
peut-être que dans le brois médiatique
avec beaucoup de candidats ça n'était
pas suffisant mais là au deème tour ce
sera bloc à bloc projet à projet et
chacun arrivera avec ses idées ses et
là-dessus on ira clairement le président
candidat n'a pas réussi selon vous cette
année à siphonner les voix du Front
national d'abord parce que contrairement
à ce qui a été dit partout on n pas
cherché à siphonneroi non non non non
non non non non non non écoutez si on
avait cherché à sioner d'abord faitnous
nous confiance en la matière on aurait
fait mieux et on aurait fait plus et
Marine Le Pen serait pas à 20 mais la
vérité elle est pas là c'est que quand
le président dit attention je veux
renégocier certains éléments européens
mais je suis européen et un Européen
convaincu on sait que ça plaît pas à
certains bon on l'a dit quand même le
candidat l'a dit parce que c'est un
candidat responsable conscient et
courageux et bien on va voir comment
entre les deux tours les gens jugeront
de la conscience du courage et de la
responsabilité cl quandême ce soir que
c'est la San d'un d'un style de
présid dans les sondages de de il y a
quelques jours on nous disait qu'avec un
Mélanchon à 15 ça faisait un bloc de
gauche tel au premier tour que de toute
manière c'était joué plié bon maintenant
on nous dit que finalement Mélenchon est
beaucoup plus bas et que par conséquent
c'est pas du tout le même jeu qui sera
au deème tour et ben écoutez moi je dis
pas que le deuxème tour c'est une
nouvelle élection complète évidemment
qu'il y a eu un premier tour évidemment
qu'il faut en tenir compte mais en même
temps le débat maintenant engagé très
directement alors juste avant d'aller au
modem quelques tout petits mots Stéphane
en rosè sur ce qu'a dit François Baou
tout à l'heure vous aviez une
interprétation sur ce que ça veut dire
de sa stratégie des prochains jours
d'abord d'abord il dit les choses
beaucoup plus précisément que ces
derniers temps c'est-à-dire il il semble
dire qu'il va choisir or ce qui a tout à
fait intéressant c'est que l'élector
centriste se sent sur les questions
économiques notamment de réduction de la
dette et de réduction de la dépense
publique plus proche de Nicolas Sarkozi
par contre ce qui hérisse dès le départ
cet électorat centriste c'est c'est une
des raisons sans doute pour lesquelles
une partie a dû aller sur François
Hollande c'est ce que vous avez indiqué
tout à l'heure le style de présidence de
Nicolas Sarkozi sa façon d'être sa façon
de faire et à forceori le cours qui
d'extrême droitisation de Nicolas
Sarkozi et donc du coup si François
beayrou insiste à ce point sur la
question des valeurs c'est comme dit
l'autre celui qui pose la question donne
la réponse c'est qu'il se prépare me
semble semble-il a appelé finalement à
voter François hand sinon il aurait dit
l'ensemble on va justement aller au
modem pour voir si tout ce que vous
dites est confirmé on rejoint tout de
suite marie avec Verling le porte-parole
du MoDem qui nous en dira peut-être un
petit peu plus et puis il peut même
exprimer son choix lui avant son
candidat
Marie oui tout à fait je suis avec y
Verling porte-parole du candidat alors
François Baayou en dessous des 10%
François Baayou à la 5e place c'est un
revers pour le modem vous savez faut
estimer quand même que 3 millions de
Français qui se sont prononcés pour les
propositions de François Baou pour ce
qu'il a dit dans cette campagne c'est
quand même pas négligeable c'est quelque
chose de très important c'est un courant
de pensée c'est un courant politique qui
vivra et cont continuera de dire ce
qu'il a à dire dans cette campagne
surtout dans cette période de second
tour et de crise politique et économique
dans laquelle notre pays se trouve alors
justement les militants ici attendent
que François Baayou se positionne entre
les deux tours c'est ce qu'il va faire
il va prendre ses responsabilités je
crois que ce
soir le vote en faveur de Marine Le Pen
et le la situation économique dans
lequel le pays se trouve invite
forcément les deux candidats qui sont
sélectionnés pour être au deuxième tour
dont l'un entrex sera président de la
République à répondre très précisément
sur un certain nombre de choses donc
François Baayou va redire quelles sont
ses priorités dans les jours qui
viennent et il va écouter ces deux
candidats sur les réponses qu'ils
apporteront et c'est bien évidemment en
fonction de cela que nous nous
prononcerons ou ou pas tout est ouvert
nous ne nous sommes libres de de nos
positions et de ce que nous avons à dire
dans cette campagne certains disaient
que la candidature de François baayerou
était nécessaire pour exister le
l'avenir de modem vous le voyez comment
aujourd'hui encore une fois faire 9 % 3
millions de voix c'est un courant
politique dans ce pays qui compte un
courant politique au centre un courant
politique qui a refusé toute démagogie
qui continuera de refuser toute
démagogie qui dira la vérité au français
les Français ont besoin d'une formation
politique de cette nature là qui soit
aussi indépendant des deux camps qui
disent que ça suffit l'opposition
permanente entre les deux camps et ça ça
devra exister ça
existera durablement je pense les
Français ont également peut-être besoin
que le MoDem se positionne clairement et
là c'est l'occasion entre les deux tours
de ne pas réitérer le scénario de 2007
oui mais encore une fois voyez comprenez
bien que nous avons dit un certain
nombre de choses pendant ce premier tour
nous avons émis des critiques sur les
propositions et les avance les choses
qu'ont avancé les candidats qui sont
jjourd'hui au second tour ce n'est pas
pour penser que s'ils ne change rien
dans ce qu'ils vont dire nous allons
tout d'un coup changer d'avis donc bien
évidemment que nous saurons être
responsable nous sommes tous dans le
même bateau le pays tout entier est
attentif à ce que le prochain Président
de la République fera on interromp Yann
Verling qui nous a donc confirmé que son
candidat François Baayou prendrait ses
responsabilités dans cette entre
deutours car on va écouter tout de suite
François Hollande c'est un moment clé de
cette soirée évidemment on est très
attentif à ce que va dire maintenant le
candidat socialiste arrivé en tête ce
soir François
Hollande
mes chers
concitoyens les Françaises et les
Français se sont massivement mobilisés
dans cette élection présidentielle
avec une participation rare
80 % plusieurs faits
majeurs sortent de ce scrutin et ils
sont
incontournables le premier c'est que je
suis ce soir en tête du premier
tour je veux remercier
chaleureusement les électrices et les
électeurs qui par leur suffrage m'ont
placé dans cette position qui m'honore
et m'oblige la plus forte pour
l'emporter c'est un acte de confiance
dans le projet que j'ai présenté devant
les Français pour redresser notre pays
dans la
justice pour maîtriser la finance pour
retrouver la croissance et l'emploi pour
réduire la dette pour protéger notre
industrie pour promouvoir les valeurs de
la
République pour préparer l'avenir et
notamment la transition
énergétique voilà ce que j'ai dit au
français pendant des mois avec constance
avec cohérence et ils m'ont répondu ce
soir en me permettant d'être aujourd'hui
le mieux placé pour devenir le prochain
président de la
République
le le
second le second fait majeur du scrutin
et il est sans
appel c'est que le premier tour
représente une sanction du quinquena qui
s'achève et un désaveux du candidat
sortant dont le discours tout au long de
ces derniers mois a fait le jeu de
l'extrême droite car c'est le dernier
élément qu'il faut regarder en face ce
soir c'est que jamais le Front national
n'avait atteint un tel niveau dans une
élection
présidentielle
même même en 2002 où il avait été
qualifié pour le second tour
il n'avait pas mobilisé autant de
suffrag c'est un nouveau signal qui
appelle à mes yeux un sursaut dans la
République et une compréhension non pas
des colères simplement mais de ceux qui
travaillent notre pays dès lors qu'il
n'est pas porté avec fierté sur ce qui
doit l'élever et où il est parfois
abaissé amoindr
et c'est ce qui s'est passé depuis 5
ans ce soir je deviens par le vote des
Français le candidat de toutes les
forces qui veulent cl une page et en
ouvrir une autre où tous les atouts de
la France seront
mobilisés je pense à la jeunesse qui
attend que lui soit enfin donné toute sa
place et je le
ferai
au terme de ce premier tour je suis le
candidat du rassemblement pour le
changement ce rassemblement doit être le
plus large possible il concerne d'abord
les forces de gauche et les écologistes
dont je suis aujourd'hui le
représentant je salue les candidats du
premier tour Jean-Luc Mélenchon
eva
jolie qui ont appelé
clairement et sans négociation à me
soutenir pour le second
tour je suis
aussi le candidat de rembl de
attaché à une république enfin
exemplaire soucieux de l'impartialité de
l'État candidat de tous les Français qui
veulent que l'intérêt général prenne le
dessus sur les
privilèges je mesure la responsabilité
qui est la mienne
d'abord réussir une alternance qui
redonne confiance au français dans
l'action politique et dans la morale
publique
ensuite répondre aux
inquiétudes légitimes aux colères
nombreuses que le scrutin a révélé le
chômage la précarité l'amputation du
pouvoir d'achat les inégalités qui se
sont creusé les rémunérations indécentes
et l'insécurité qui frappe les
catégories les plus exposé et
notamment les plus pauvres enfin ma
dernière responsabilité je sais que je
suis regardé au-delà des frontières de
notre pays c'est de réorienter l'Europe
sur le chemin de la croissance et de
l'emploi grâce à vous ce
soir le changement est désormais en
marche et rien je dis bien rien ne
l'arrêtera il dépend
désormais du peuple français et le choix
est simple soit continuer une politique
qui a échoué avec un candidat sortant
qui a divisé soit redresser la France
dans la justice avec un nouveau
président de la République qui
rassemblera le 6
mai je
veux une
victoire viire à la hauteur de la France
de son histoire et de son avenir et
pendant tous ces jours qui me sépareront
du second tour je continuerai à
rencontrer les Français à les mobiliser
et leur dire la fierté qui est la mienne
de conduire cette campagne et qui sera
s'ils en décident la fierté de conduire
le pays comme président de la République
merci voilà c'étaitis qui en direct de
Thul cette fois c'est très clair la
campagne du 2e tour a commencé le 6 mai
je veux une belle victoire le changement
est désormais en marche rien ne
l'arrêtera je serai ce président de la
République qui rassemblera François
Holland qui s'est félicité de cet acte
de confiance exprimé ce soir dans son
projet qui a également réagi au score
très important du Front national il
appelle un sursaut dans la République et
il a insisté il veut vérit ement être le
candidat de toutes les forces politiques
qui je cite veulent clore une page et en
ouvrir une autre cette intervention de
François Hollande on va la commenter
Michel avec nos invités sur ce plateau
même si Nicolas Sarkozi devrait
s'exprimer d'une minute à l'autre oui
puisque effectivement c'est lui que l'on
attend maintenant après donc la
déclaration à l'instant àul du candidat
socialiste qui s'estime donc le mieux
placé pour devenir le Président de la
République dans 15 jours maintenant nos
invités donc Jean-Vincent placer bonsoir
président du groupe écologique au Sénat
alors que on a entendu François Hollande
et bien saluer à la fois eva jolie et
puis Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui lui apporte
leur soutien sans conditions a-t-il
précisé François repsamen est à vos côté
président du groupe socialiste au Sénat
sénateur maire de Dijon Benoît Apparu
est également avec nous bonsoir ministre
délégué au logement et puis y Pozo di
Borgo qui a un soutien de François
Baayou qui s Franois Baou voilà et
qu'est-ce que vous allez faire vous dans
15 jour vous pouvez nous le dire là il
vous a dit François Baou il va prendre
ses responsabilités responsabilité on a
de TR jours pour réfléchir pour savoir
ce que vont faire mais vous vous à titre
personnel moi écoutz on est quand même
dans une équipe et dans qu personnelle
mon choix a déjà fait mais c Ros parce
qu'il entendait parler de valeur il
voyait un infléchissement une inflexion
plutôt vers françois Hollande je pens pe
pas cette analyse j'ai écouté je pens
pas je crois qu'il y a plusieurs
problèmes qui se posent la dette alors
est-ce qu'on peut aller vers Hollande
quand vous avez le le candidat Hollande
qui dit 60000 postes depuiséducation
nationale alors qu'il faut réduer les
déficit excusez-moi je m'interroge
premier point deè point prier point 2ème
point sur l'Europe le flou de l'Europe
du côté de Sarkozi l'intergouvernemental
ça nous convient pas trop mais également
du côté de nos amis socialistes
également non non mais il y a des
questions plus précises ré l'intégration
européenne est nécessaire non mais c'est
les questions sur lesquelles les
candidats n'ont pas répondu
l'intégration européenne n'a pas a été
abordé et personne n'a répondu troisème
point la désin la désinstruisation de la
de la France les PME et les PMI qui
créent les emplois et les produits
français on n' pas eu de réponse
à-dessus des deux candidats et je crois
qu'il est nécessaire dans cette campagne
qui commence entre deux candidats et 4e
point si vous permettezac est-ce qu'
est-il normal qu'un candidat qui a 5 ans
fait 18 % des voix et vit à l'Assemblée
nationale avec de deux députés est-ce
qui sera normal si Mad Marine Le Pen qui
fait 20 % des voix n'aura aucun député à
l'Assemblée nationale ça veutà dire
qu'il faudra bien changer ce système et
qu'il faudra bien ces grands partis qui
existent au életion présidentiell puiss
exprimer toutes ces exigences vous allez
aller les soumettre aux deux candidats
dans dans les heures qui viennent vous
allez compter ens de vousê on pas dans
une logique de négociation je crois dit
il a simplement simplement les candidats
s'exprimeront voilà François repsamen
comment vous réagissez à ce discours de
de François Holland c'était le discours
qu'il fallait tenir ce soir beaucoup de
sobriété de gravité et en même temps il
le dit il sent maintenant que la
victoire est apporté demain
permettez-moi d'exprimer d'abord une
double satisfaction cette campagne
contrairement à ce qui avait été dit a
intéressé les Français la participation
était très élevée or nous avons entendu
pendant des jours et des jours une
campagne qui sodisant n'intéressait pas
qui ne mobilisait pas la vérité est
inverse c'est la première chose le
deuxième constat que je voudrais faire
c'est un moment de de plaisir c'est la
joie de voir personnel de voir le
candidat que je soutiens depuis fort
longtemps arrivé en tête à une élection
au premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle c'est quelque chose
d'exceptionnel parce que c'est la
première fois président de la République
sortant et
devancé au soir du premier tour d'une
élection sous la 5e République et donc
on voit bien qu'il y a un mouvement qui
s'est créé autour de de François
Hollande un mouvement de rassemblement
pour une république apaisée exemplaire
et je pense que la victoire est àortée
demainors ch c'est qu'il a dit votre
candidat ben paru va réagir dans une
minute mais on va d'abord à la réunion
de l'UMP à la Mutualité avec Germain R
qui se trouve à côté de gérrard Longuet
qui va avancer ses contre-arguments
après ce que l'on vient d'entendre dans
la bouche de François
repsamen oui bonsoir je suis au côté de
de Gérard Longuet alors est-ce que vous
pouvez Gérard Longuet réagir tout de
suite et bien ce que nous a dit François
Hollande il y a encore quelques instants
à savoir qu'il appelait au large un
rassemblement le plus large possible
pour une République exemplaire quelle
est votre réaction à ces propos c'est
que la gauche est minoritaire dans ce
pays l'ensemble des candidats gauche
pèse en gros un peu plus de 40 % 42 43 %
des voix il n'a donc pas de majorité
pour gouverner ce pays je pense
profondément que le deuxème tour qui va
être un match loyal entre deux candidats
deux options pour notre pays se projeter
sur l'avenir sur les 5 ans que nous
avons à accomplir ensemble va permettre
à Nicolas Sarkozi d'apporter une réponse
à la majorité de nos compatriotes qui
veulent une France Forte une France qui
les protège qui les sécurise et il
compte sur lui sur son caractère et sur
ses tion mais avec ce premier tour il y
a une surprise c'est ce score de Marine
Le Pen selon vous est-ce que c'est tout
de même un désaveux de la stratégie de
Nicolas Sarkozi est-ce que les électeurs
ce soir on dit on préfère l'original à
la copie et cette stratégie n'a pas payé
je crois simplement que des électeurs
ont voté ailleurs notamment pour Madame
Le Pen parce qu'il pendant 5 ans ils ont
connu nous avons connu ensemble des
épreuves des difficultés parfois des des
frustrations ou peut-être même des
déceptions il était normal qu'au premier
tour ces 5 années fassent en quelque
sorte un vote pour solde de tout compte
mais que veulent ces électeurs ils
veulent une France forte qui les protège
de la mondialisation une Europe
construite qui les sécurise qui leur
donne la certitude que leurs entreprises
seront prises en considération qui ne
seront pas je dirais exposé au vent de
la concurrence et donc ces gens-là
naturellement iront chercher la sécurité
là où ils se trouvent dans le caractère
dans l'énergie et dans les solutions de
Nicolas Sarkozi une dernière question
c'est un recours naturel vous pensez
Nicolas Sarkozi pour ses électeurs de
Mar Le Pen il va falloir les séduire
plus au second tour ou appeler au
rassemblement non je crois appeler au
rassemblement de ceux qui volulent une
France Forte c'est-à-dire une France
capable de protéger tous les Français
sur l'autorité de l'État sur la sécurité
sur la protection frontières sur la
protection économique c'est Nicolas
Sarkozi pour les 5 années à venir merci
ben écoutez justement Nicolas Sarkozi
qui devrait dans quelques instants
s'exprimer ici à la Mutualité venir face
aux militants bien pour les convaincre
de ne rien lâcher sur la Mobil que rien
n'est joué pour le second tour
effectivement Germain on voit des images
de la voiture de Nicolas Sarkozy qui
sera donc partie d'élysée qui serait aux
abords de l'Assemblée nationale et qui
serait donc en train d'arriver d'ici
quelques minutes salle de la Mutualité à
Paris dans le 5e arrondissement en
attendant l'intervention du candidat
Nicolas Sarkozi le commentaire le
témoignage de vous Benoît app paru on
sent bien que ce soir c'est un peu la
soupe à la grimace dans les équipes de
l'UMP comment vous iser trouver un
nouveau Souf pour cette campagne de
deuxème tour qui commence maintenant
alors un je fais pas la grimace c'est
vra radiu j' pas jusque là quand
même ce soir c'est un nouveau combat qui
commence on a maintenant on l' vu sur
votre antenne comme sur toutes les
antennes deux visages un choix qui est
proposé au français entre deux personnes
François Hollande Nicolas Sarkozi dans
les 15 jours qu'il viennent ils doivent
se prononcer pour savoir qui est le plus
crédible pour gérer les 5 ans qui
viennent quels arguments doit mettre en
avant Nicolas Sarkozi selon vous je
pense que l'idée de rassembler le peuple
de France de s'adresser à tous les
Français est un premier élément mais qui
montré qu' av capacité de rassembler et
l'autre de s on a bien compris qu'il y
avait les gentils d'un côté les méchants
de l'autre ça c'est ok ce schéma là on
l'a tous très bien compris d'accord on
est bien d'accord avec ça moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est de dire au français je
suivante qui est le plus crédible pour
gérer les 5 ans qui viennent on vient de
l'entendre à l'instant est-ce que c'est
celui qui propose des postes de
fonctionnaires en plus ou celui qui
propose de continuer à faire des
économies sur le fonctionnement de
l'État parce que l'État doit se
désendetter on a ce choix là à faire à
proposer au français deux visages deux
images qui sera le plus crédible pour
gérer le pays pour parler très très
clair on a beaucoup dit ces derniers
jours que les propositions du candidat
Sarkozi n'avaient pas été suffisamment
audibles et identifié contrairement au
prramme de François Hollande qui a
égrainé ses mesures très tôt dès janvier
comment vous allez faire aujourd'hui
pour en mettre voilà quelquesunes en
priorité en avant pour marquer les
esprits et faire la différence avec le
candidat là où on a une nouvelle
campagne qui commence c'est que nous
avons eu pour l'instant un référendum
pour ou compre Sarkozi ça était ça le
premier tour on avait neu candidats
contre et quand on entend quand on
entend François tout à l'heure c'est
toujours la même logique on tape sur le
président de la République c'est leur
stratégie maintenant là encore on va
avoir deux candidats du temps de parole
comme on dit dans les médias entre
réparti entre deux personnes on va
pouvoir réexprimer fortement toutes nos
propositions notamment pour réduire la
date la dette pardon et ch faut pas
seapper pour se tromper et pour réduire
placer un mot je vous ai vu presque
vibrer tout tout à l'heure au discours
de Françis Hollande ça ne vous est
peut-être pas arrivé durant la campagne
avec Eva jolie non non moi je suis un
écologiste très très déçu bien sûr mais
très fier aussi de la campagne
d'exposition de nos idées qui a été
faite par Eva jolie voilà on peut se
poser toujours la question de savoir si
les écologistes on est on est prêt face
à cette élection la répse on n'est pas
prêt ça c'est vrai il faut qu'on soit
plus crédible pour beaucoup de choses
plus experts sur des questions qui
touchent l'immédiateté le quotidien et
euh
les les moments importants pour les
Françaises et les Français et c'est vrai
que oui vous l'entendez d'ailleurs on a
une difficulté à cette élection autant
d'ailleurs il y a une for il y a une
forte crédibilité au moment des
européennes au moment des régionales au
moment des municipales et au niveau
national on a encore la démonstration de
cette crédibilité à faire et c'est pour
ça que moi je ne fais pas partie de
celles et ceux qui émettent des
critiques pour le casting n'est-ce pas
ou le marketing notre campagne eva jolie
est une femme très sincère qui a
beaucoup de conviction qui j' père
d'ailleurs continuera à travailler avec
nous à nos côtés dans les mois à venir
et en revanche par rapport à la
vibration pour François Hollande ce qui
est clair c'est que François Hollande a
fait une très très belle campagne qui le
porte haut au premier tour qui va lui
donner je l'espère une dynamique pour le
2uxè il sait qu'il peut compter sur les
écologistes il sait qu'il peut compter
aussi sur les communistes et je crois
que au-delà encore de ce rassemblement
il y a les Françaises et les Français
parce que je suis désolé pour Monsieur
apparu qui a un culot d'acier pour
expliquer que président S cand vous
annonz une annonce PS vert communiste
c'est
ça je ve connaître le paysage on est
bien d'accord une alliance entre lea
s'il vous plaît sur ce plateau on verra
ce que sera le visage de la gauche dans
les prochaines heures justement parce
que on commence par aller tout truc seul
Ferin m avec Gérard et on vousetrouve
tout de suite sur ce plateau messieurs à
vous mich oui avec le sénateur maire de
Lyon qui a écouté avec nous notamment
François Hollande depuis Thul et on a
senti ici une grande effervescence et
des mots très précis de François
Hollande on va revenir évidemment sur le
fait qu'il soit en tête au premier tour
mais il a beaucoup parlé du Front
national aussi Gérard Colom oui d'abord
il a dit ce qui est la réalité à savoir
que le bilan de Nicolas Sarkozi a été
durement sanctionné que lui-même sur son
projet le projet qu'il a défini et Don
certains pensaient qu'il n'était pas si
ceci assz cela et bien fait un score
exceptionnel et donc le met aujourd'hui
en position de l'emporter au second tour
alors c'est vrai qu'après la deuxième
information c'est le score du Front
national mais nous étions quelques-uns
élus locaux en particulier qui pension
que ce score sera important d'abord
parce que évidemment il y avait un échec
de Nicolas Sarkozi sur le problème de la
sécurité et ensuite parce qu'il y a un
profond désespoir qu'il va nous falloir
prendre en compte dans les semaine et
surtout dans les mois qui suivent alors
on a vu aussi que le pourcentage de
gauche le total des gauches représentait
à peu près 45 45 et demi est-ce que ça
sera suffisant tout de même pour le
deème Tour ah bah c'est un score très
élevé jamais dans les élections qui se
sont passés au cours des dernières
années on a atteint un score aussi
important en plus moi je suis sûr que
nous allons être rejoint par beaucoup de
femmes et d'hommes qui ne sont pas de
gauche par un certain nombre de
centristes je connais un peu lion ce
vote là et je sais qu'ils vont être
d'accord avec nous parce que ils
partagent un certain nombre de valeurs
humanistes qui nous sont communes Gérard
colon vous parliez des centristes on
vous on a entendu tout à l'heure
également François Baayou vous l'avez
entendu avec nous ici rue de Solferino
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de son choix
il ira vers la gauche vers la droite il
ne
s'abstiendra je ne sais pas vous savez
il y a toujours un mystère autour de
François Baayou mais il n'est comme
aucun d'entre nous propriétaire de les
électeurs et donc je pense que beaucoup
de femmes et d'hommes qui sont du centre
qui appartiennent au MoDem qui ont voté
pour François Baou au premier tour
voterons demain pour François Holland
merci beaucoup Gérard colon toujours en
direct de la rue de Solférino merci à
vous deux merci Michel à tout à l'heure
donc à Solferino alors beno paru mait en
garde contre le danger du retour d'une
alliance entre le Parti socialiste le
Parti communiste et les vert c'est bien
ça beno à paru François repsamen Nicolas
Sarkozi lui-même disait dans le Figaro
vendredi que vot votre candidat serait
l'otage de Jean-Luc Mélenchon est-ce
qu'il l' moins avec ce score moins
impressionnant que prévu 11,7 pour le
candidat du Front de gauche je le
rappelle est-ce que vous pensez que
François Hollande est l'ottage de
quelqu'un personne ne le pense François
Hollande depuis maintenant 1 an il fait
sa campagne l'élection présidentielle à
la rencontre des Françaises et des
Français et il va poursuivre pendant ce
second tour cette démarche de
rassemblement qu'il porte depuis
toujours pourquoi le rassemblement parce
que c'est exactement l'inverse de la
pratique de Nicolas Sarkozi qui n'a pas
arrêté pendant 5 ans d'opposer les uns
aux autres de chercher le Bou émissaire
le responsable d'opposer la police à la
justice donc ça va 2 secondes vous
pouvez me laisser finir ma phrase s'il
vous plaît et donc nous avons
aujourd'hui d'un côté une UMP et un
candidat qui est désavoué c'est un
désaveux ce soir pour Nicolas Sarkozi
écoutez arrivver deux ou trois points
derrière le candidat François Hollande
lui qui se sentait si fort qu' voulait
renverser la table à chaque fois alors
on nous promet un autre mat mat non
c'est pas un autre match c'est la même
élection présidentielle qui continue et
cette élection présidentielle ce
rassemblement qu'a supporté François
Hollande ça va être le redressement de
la République demain ce redressement de
la République qui va porter il va être
fait avec le rassemblement d'hommes et
de femmes qui viennent d'horizon divers
d'abord la gauche bien sûr mais plus
largement parce que j'entendais
notentendais notre collè du
mod j'entendais notreègue centriste qui
s on a déjà Gérard long suit la voiture
de Nicolas Sarkozi donc vous faites pas
de souci on l' entendu puis on l'assez
entendu pendant 5 ans donc il y a pas de
problème de ce côté-là je voudrais dire
à notre collèg centriste je dire à notre
collègue centriste question
intransigence et comportement sectaire
vous n'avez aucune leçon à nous donner
je voudrais vous dire que nous avons la
la
proportionnelle nous avons la
proportionnelle nous la mettrons en
place
voilà ch para c'est
uneitionair on a beaucoup dit ces
derniers jours que le 2 tour Nicolas SAR
allait jouer l'Union nationale contre
l'union des gauches c'est ce que vous
avez l'air d'amorcer comme débat vous
aussi ce soir ici clairement quand j'end
tout à l'heure monsieur placé il nous
disait quoi qu'on va avoir en gros une
alliance entre trois partis le parti
Europe Écologie Les vert le Parti
communiste c'est lui qui l'a cité pas
moi et le Parti socialiste donc on a
effectivement une tendance qui se
dessine avec l'Union des gauches c'est
un choix je le conteste pas
je simplement que Chun assume s chix
clair devant les Français une alliance
entre ces TR partis c'est leur choix
nous on s'adresser à l'ensemble des
Français qu'ils a voté Mélenchon qu'ils
a voté jolie qu'ils a voté Le Pen qu'ils
a voté berou on s'adressera à l'ensemble
des
Français en leur disant une seule chose
est le
plus qui va s'exprimer dans quelques
secondes 21h45 onécoute direct sur les
antennes de Public Sénat et de LCP c'est
tout de suite Nicolas
SAR mes chers
compatriotes
mes chers
compatriotes mes chers
compatriotes avec une participation
supérieure à
80% français ont pris la mesure du choix
historique qu'ils ont à faire pour
l'élection
présidentiel les
Français ont fait un acte de civisme et
en agissant ainsi ils ont démenti toutes
les prédictions et déjoué tous les
pronostics les
Français ont
exprimé un vote de crise témoignant de
leurs inquiétudes de leurs souffran et
de leurs angoisses face à ce nouveau
monde qui est en train de se dessiner
ces angoisses ces souffrances je les
connais ces angoisses ces souffrances je
les comprends
porte sur le respect de nos
frontières la lutte déterminée contre
les
délocalisation la maîtrise de
l'immigration la valorisation du travail
la
sécurité pour eux et pour leur famille
je sais que dans ce monde qui bouge si
vite le souci de nos
compatriotes de préserver leur mode de
vie et la question centrale de cette
élection les deux
candidats les deux candidats désignés
pour le second tour par les Français ont
maintenant un devoir de vérité et un
devoir de courage nul n'aura le droit de
se dérober le moment crucial est venu
celui de la confrontation des projets et
du choix des personnalités il s'agit de
désigner celui qui aura la
responsabilité de notre pays et qui
devra protéger les Français pour les 5
années à
venir j'ai
exercé pendant 5 ans cette fonction je
vous prie de me croire j'en mesure le
poids et j'en connais les devoirs ces
deux semaines qui viennent doivent
permettre à chacun d'entre vous de faire
un choix dans la clarté tout doit être
débattu sans hypocrisie sans esquive
sans fauxfuir c'est pourquoi je propose
que b
soanis sur les question économi et
social sur les questions de société et
sur les questions internationales les
Français ont le droit à la vérité et à
la clarté nul ne
pourober Chun
alors
pourire de cause je vais aller à votre
rencontre je préciserai encore mes
engagements je vous prie de me croire
j'y consacrerai toute l'énergie dont je
suis capable j'appelle tous
ceux j'appelle tous ceux qui refusent la
fuite en avant dans les dépenses
publiques sans aucun contrôle et qui ne
veulent pas que la France connaisse le
sort de tant de nos voisins européens
aujourd'hui emporté par la crise
j'accueillerai tous ceux qui souhaitent
se rassembler autour de mon projet je le
ferai sans aucun esprit partisan car
c'est au peuple français à tout le
peuple français que je veux parler je
souhaite remercier tous ceux qui m'ont
soutenu dès le premier tour grâce à leur
mobilisation nous pouvons aborder le
second tour avec confiance
et j'appelle
maintenant tous les Français qui mettent
l'amour de la patrie au-dessus de toute
considération partisane ou de tout
intérêt particulier à s'unir et à me
rejoindre vive la république et vive la
France voilà c'était Nicolas Sarkozi qui
s'exprimait de Paris salle de la
Mutualité dans le 5e arrondissement
Nicolas Sarkozi applaudit on a pu
reconnaître son épouse Carla Bruny au
premier rang Nicolas Sarkozi qui dit
conserver la confiance grâce à la
mobilisation et à la participation et
qui appelle vous l'avez entendu à
l'organisation de trois débats dans
l'entre de tour sur l'économie sociale
sur la question de société he sur les
questions internationales pour que
vraiment les Français puissent faire la
différence entre les deux projets
l'heure du choix est venu Michel on en
parle avec nos invités et avec Christian
Jacob qui nous a rejoint le le président
des députés UMP trois débats pourquoi
est-ce que votre candidat insiste
tempant alors que François Laurent
Hollande a déjà répondu ça sera un le
temps qu'il faudra toute une soirée mais
un contre trois mais tout d'abord je
crois qu'on il y a eu trois débats pour
les primaires socialistes donc je pense
que sur un deè tour des présidentielles
on peut avoir trois débats et il y a
intérêt aller au bout ce que les
Français attendent aujourd'hui c'est le
choix de la crédibilité le rendez-vous
de la crédibilité on a eu un match là
dans cette première partie de campagne
de neuf contrein un certain moment il
est bon maintenant que l'on soit dans le
choix et le choix pourquoi refuser de
débattre pourquoi refuser de confronter
ces idées pourquoi pas trois débat
François c'est c'est les propositions en
général c'est la proposition des des
président qui vont être batttu c'est
celle qu'avait fait Valérie giscardestin
à François mitteran en 1981 il avait
proposé il avait proposé qu'il y ait
deux débats pas for
peut-être deux débats il avait proposé
deux débats la la la 5e République a des
traditions il y a un grand débat il y
aura un grand débat pourquoi tris
peut-être 4 5 c'est toujours Nicolas
Sarkozi est toujours dans l'excès vous
voyez et donc il y aura un grand débat
et entre-temps chacun chaque candidat
ira à la rencontre des Français voilà ce
qui alors on a un chiffre à vous
communiquer Émilie puisquil nous
parvient à l'instant et bien c'est euh
les perspectives de score au second tour
il s iche sur l'écran avec c'est
toujours nos partenaires Ipsos en
partenari avec France Télévision et
Radio France attention de au second tour
54 % pour François Hollande 46 % pour
Nicolas Sarkozi messieurs si vous voulez
bien commenter ces
intionp peut-être moi au Parti
socialiste mais surtout à l'UMP on
entend beaucoup dire que rien n'est joué
Christian Jacob oui tout d'abord jamais
le jeu a été aussi ouvert qu'il qu'il
est là et et ensuite la triple erreur
des des Institutes de Sondag
sortir un sondage pour le deè tour
aujourd'hui je vous rappelle qu'à 48h
les sondages
sontbat les sondages se sont trompés
de de 10 % sur la participation jamais
les instituts ne se sont autant trompés
et tous les commentateurs politiques se
sont trompés de la même façon 10 points
d'écart sur la
participationécise
explicationexte été calculé après
l'annonce du des résultats du premier
tour c'est une précision importante oui
moi ce que je veux rappeler c'est la
triple erreur des instituts et de tous
les commentateurs 10 points d'écart sur
la mobilisation par rapport à la à la
réalité on nous annonçait Marine Le Pen
Mélenchon cou à coude il y a un pour
deux de de différence on nous annonçait
Nicolas Sarkozi complètement écrasé et
on voit aujourd'hui selon les instituts
on est entre 1 et demi et 3 donc on est
vraiment au coude à coude avec une une
une campagne de 2uxè tour qui est
totalement différente parce qu'encore
une fois c'est le rendez-vous de la
crédibilité et c'est pour ça qu'il y a
besoin de ces trois débats moi je veux
bien qu'on prenne toutes les excuses
qu'on veut mais pourquoi refuser de
débattre sauf si on a pas d'idé à
exposerand est-ce qu'il le redoute ce
débat dans trop de du tout vous le
verrez d'ailleurs continuez à
sous-estimer François Hollande vous
aurez encore des surprises pendant le
débat c'est ce que je voulais vous dire
vous l'avez sous-estimé d'ailleurs
depuis fort longtemps c'est toujours le
côté un peu Matam président de la ré
c'est plutôt le PS reprend les citations
de Martin
il l' il l' désigné largement et donc on
a là moi je je m'intéresse pas tellement
aux intentions de vot de second tour
comme ça projeté euh il y a une campagne
à faire il y a 15 jours ce que je veux
dire c'est que la victoire est apportée
demain mais rien n'est
acquis ri rien n'est acquis et il faudra
faire cette campagne parce que je sais
que les Français ont exprimé ce soir une
volonté de changement ils ont exprimé
cette volonté de changement et je leur
dis le changement il est possible le 6
mai et c'est donc le 6 mai que cela se
décidera et nous avons à rassembler
toutes celles et tous ceux qui veulent
une République exemplaire demain qui
veulent rompre avec les pratiques de
l'injustice sociale fiscale vousêtes à
côté de Jean Vincent placé est-ce que ça
veut dire que dans les jours qui
viennent vous allez dire précisément
comment vous voulez travailler avec les
écologistes est-ce qu'il peuvent rentrer
au gouvernement quel thème vous allez
mettre en
avant qu'est-ce que vous attendez du
candidat Hollande maintenant le candid
le candidat Hollande il est dans la
logique de la 5e République et depuis un
an il présenter un projet compris il a
émis des commentaires forts sur l'accord
parlementaire que nous avons passé avec
le Parti socialiste il est dans cette
logique la 5e République et il veut être
président et je pense que c'est
important qu'il soit très bien élu le 6
mai prochain y compris pour donner une
dynamique notamment par rapport aux
Européens et par rapport au monde entier
parce que il y a des grands enjeux qui
sont là immédiatement il faut aller à
cand David pour le G8 il faut aller à
Chicago pour l'OTAN il y a eu
Rio
%50%ici 205 est-ce que ça vous va est-ce
que çait le problème pas savoir si ça me
va ou moi vous savez si j'étais à 100 %
d'accord avec le programme de Françis
Hollande j'aurais voté avec pour lui
aujourd'hui c pas ce que j'ai fait r en
revanche il y a le deuxème tour il faut
faire ce deème tour et moi j'appelle
toutes les écologistes et tous les
écologistes de France à voter pour
François Hollande parce que quand je
vois les dégâts qui ont été fait par
Nicolas Sarkozi sur cette question après
l'échec absolu du Grenel comme
d'habitude des discours au départ très
bien et des actes zéro échec absolu sur
l'écologie sur
l'industrie côté pour l'écologie je peux
vous dire il y a pas photo entre
François Holland et Nicolas Sarkozy et
donc évidemment je préférerais que ça
soit un écologiste Président c'est
logique puisque je suis écologiste mais
là puisqu'il y a un deuxième tour vous
me posez la question c'est évident pour
moi comme on dit trivialement il n a pas
photo mais si on a répondu depuis très
longtemps parce qu'on nous avons dit
dans l'accord que nous étions inscrits
dans la démarche franis
éici 2025 et nous déb dans la majorité
parire je l'espère dès le 17 juin après
que nous ayons gagné mais vous m'en
voudrez pas de pas aborder ce sujet dans
la mesure où nous sommes extrêmement
concentrés
derrire vore quand Mme leol
2%ie ex
pvezoirz d'ailleurs très française
excusez-moi vous le dire de faire la
politique parce que ce serait à 10 % ou
à 2 % on fait tel ou tel type de
négociation parce que ce serait
uniquement le rapport de force qui
vaudrait et bien il y a un moment aussi
non non il y a aussi des questions de
conviction et quelque part François
Hollande et je pense que il touche les
dividends de ce type de campagne il a
dit au départ voilà mon projet pour la
France voilà ce que je dis y compris au
Parti socialiste y compris au vert il
dit au deème tour je dis la même chose
il a reçu ce soir sans discussion sans
aucune discussion le soutien d'Iv joli
et aussi de Jean-Luc Mélenchon et je
pense que ça va faire réfléchir beaucoup
de gens y compris qui ont voté François
berou ce soir cette façon de faire la
politique un peu plus intéressant non
pas que la superbe de Monsieur Sarkozi
qui dit je parle à toutes les Français
et tous les Français heureusement parce
qu'il n' plus un seul allié politique
première exigence quand même C qui va
être satisfaite c'est d'obtenir un
groupe parlementaire à l'Assemblée
nationale c'est une autre c'est une
autre élection qui va avoir lieu mais de
élection élection présidentielle et je
l'ai dit tout à l'heure nous ne sommes
pas les mieux amés pour cette élection
et là nous voulons faire françisand
aider à faireir François hand et il y
aura les élections législatives on
parlera de tout ça comme ça on se
reverra et puis comme ça le
débat centrme répondreement est-ce que
sur le premier tour l'ensemble des
dossiers ont vraiment ét ordés en
profondeur et mais non et c'est pour ça
que les trois débats tris demandes que
demand Nicolas SAR doiv être abordé
qu'est-ce qu'on a dit sur l'nationale
rien maintenant je vais reprendre àure
je regardais j'ai beaucoup de respect
pour toi tu sais mais tout à l'heure
rciement tout à l'heure je regardais tu
fais 2 % tu es un bon négociateur sur la
table de travail sur la table du tapis
de de négociation tu as obtenu un groupe
et plus qu'un groupe tu as obtenu 60
députés sont les Français attends mais
prends l'exemple de François Baayou qui
a fait presque 20 % la fois dernière qui
a vécu avec deux députés prends
l'exemple de Marine Le Pen parce que les
électeurs attendez attendez je termine
par jeir les électeurs de Marine Le Pen
je veux dire ils aimeraient bien être
représentés pendant 5 ans l'Assemblée
nationale est-ce que vous croyez que la
seule proposition qui d' peut-être mieux
que la votre mais je vous envoie ça de
proportionnel les socialiste est
suffisante je crois qu'il y a une
réflexion beaucoup plus en profondeur
pour que l'ensemble des courants qui
s'expriment à la vie présidentielle
élection présidentielle soit
représenté victime de lui-même d'avoir
refuser la bipolarisation qui qui une
fois de plus s'impose mais c'est le
système de la bipolarisation qu'il
faudra ninrog c'est pour n av
pass pour la prèrea une
sign
sy la mémoire un peu courte je me
permettrais de vous le dire parce que
quand les socialistes ont mis la
proportionnelle en 1986 à l'Assemblée
nationale vous l'avez brocardé en disant
ça fait rentrer le Front
national c'est rentrer le Front national
à l'Assemblée nationale
mainten maintenant vous voir me demander
ça vous savez très bien qu'il n'y aura
pas l'autonomie du centre s'il y a pas
un jour de la proportionnelle dans le
mode de c'est ce que nous proposons
depuis suffisamment longtemps pour être
crédible sur ce sujet parce qu' on l'a
faition réagir sur ce point on est
vraiment dans la petite tambouille
électorale non mais c'est ce qui vous va
très bien
monsieur
lateouillelector ce qui nous intéresse
ce qui nous intéresse aujourd'hui c'est
de rassembler l'ensemble des Français de
s'adresser au peuple de France et non
pas de s'adresser ici au vert ici à
Monsieur Mélenchon et à d'autres
François Hollande l'a dit lui-même il
veut réconcilier la gauche avec la FR
sadresse à l'ensemble des Français on
s'adresse au
français fr il faut stir de petit Bage
électoraux parce que c'est ça qui
caractérise François Holland et
R 0 l'heure du flash de Delphine Girard
justement pour revivre les temps fort de
ce début de soirée électorale de premier
tour merci encore c'est l'heure du flash
le rappel des fa Delphine
Girard bonsoir à tous merci à vous si
vous nous rejoignez en direct sur les
chaînes parlementaires voici les
résultats de ce premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle avec 28,8 pour
des voix c'est donc selon nos
estimations les estimations de notre
partenaire l'institut de sondage hipsos
et bien c'est donc François Hollande qui
arrive en tête de cette présidentielle
Nicolas Sarkozi réunit quant à lui 26,1
% des voix la surprise vient de la 3e
place avec un score historique pour
Marine Le Pen elle devance Jean-Luc
Mélenchon la candidate frontiste obtient
18,5 % des suffrages exprimés le
candidat du Front de Gauche ne rassemble
que 11,7 % et vous le voyez sur votre
écran François baayrou ne dépasse pas la
barre des 10 % pour sa 3e tentative le
candidat du MoDem est à 8,8 %. eva jolie
obtient 2,3 la candidate d'Europe
Écologie Les Verts fait mieux que
Dominique voanet qui en 2007 avait
obtenu 1,57 % des voix un point sur le
score des petits candidats le
souverainiste Nicolas enignan du
ponteignan pardon rassemble 1,8 % des
voix Philippe outou 1,2 Nathalie au la
candidate de Lutte Ouvrière 06 et
Jacques Cheminade 0,2 % des voix le
second tour opposera donc François
Hollande au président sortant Nicolas
Sarkozi les deux finalistes se sont
exprimés ce soir pour le candidat
socialiste il était en direct de son
fief de Tul en corz François Hollande
qui a dit qu'il était le mieux placé
pour être président de la République je
vous propose tout de suite de
l'écouter majeur tin et il est sans
appel c'est que le premier tour
représente une sanction du quinquena qui
s'achève et un désaveux du candidat
sortant dont le discours tout au long de
ces derniers mois a fait le jeu de
l'extrême
droite voilà pour la réaction de
François Hollande et puis c'était il à
peine 5 minutes Nicolas Sarkozi s'est
exprimé quant à lui en direct de la
mutualité il a appelé les Français à se
rassembler au-delà de toute
considération partisane on écoute
Nicolas
Sarko ces deux semaines qui viennent
doivent permettre à chacun d'entre vous
de faire un choix dans la clarté tout
doit être
débattu sans hypocrisie sans esquive
sans fauxfuir c'est pourquoi je propose
que trois débats soient organisés entre
les deux
candidats la surprise vient donc du
score de Marine Le Pen pour sa première
campagne présidentielle la candidate
frontiste fait mieux que son père en
2002 qui avait obtenu 16,8 % des voix
salale Équinox dans le 15e
arrondissement de Paris à la lancé à ses
militants rien ne sera plus jamais comme
avant Flora sauvage avec nos équipes sur
place au QG du Front national ce soir la
joie se liit sur les visages avec 19,7 %
des voix le Front national devient la
3ème force politique de cette élection
jamais le parti d'extrême droite n'a
obtenu un tel score à une élection
présidentielle en France ce premier tour
n'est pas une fin en soi mais le
commencement d'un vaste rassemblement
des patriotes de droite comme de gauche
des amoureux de la France et des
défenseurs de son identité pour sa
première campagne présidentielle Marine
Le Pen dépasse le score réalisé par son
père en 2002 un Jean-Marie Le Pen plutôt
satisfait du score réalisé par sa fille
ce soir tout naturellement le Front
national devient la première force
d'opposition au socialisme si Marine Le
Pen n'a pas réussi l'exploit de son père
en 2002 qui s'était qualifié au second
tour elle réussit néanmoins à se
positionner en 3è position loin devant
Jean-Luc Mélenchon le candidat du Front
de Gauche aux élections législatives
prévu en juin le Front national espère
profiter de la dynamique présidentielle
pour être présent dans au moins 100
circonscription et les appels à faire
barrage au Front National au second tour
n'ont pas tardé à se faire entendre
c'est Eva jolie la première qui a mis en
garde les électeurs qui se sont laissés
abuser par le Front national elle a
appelé à voter Parti socialiste pour le
Parti socialiste au second tour on
l'écoute le score du Front national est
une tâche
indélébile sur les valeurs de notre
démocratie une menace pour la République
un avertissement que chaque responsable
politique doit entendre j'appelle dès à
présent toutes celles et ceux qui ont
voté pour moi et au-delà toutes celles
et ceux qui sont attachés au valeur de
la République à tout faire pour que
notre pays sorte enfin du sarcocisme en
se rassemblant autour de la candidature
de François Hollande et cet appel a été
relayé par Jean-Luc Mélenchon celui qui
se rêvait en 3e homme n'aura pas réussi
son Paris de faire mieux que Marine Le
Pen le candidat du Front de Gauche
atteint 11,7 % des voix ce soir place
stalingrade il a qualifié le score du
Front national d'alarmant et a appelé à
battre Nicolas Sarkozi au second tour on
l'écoute nous avons donc eu
raison de concentrer notre
campagne sur l'analyse et la critique
radicale des propositions de l'extrême
droite honte à ceux qui ont préféré nous
tirer dessus plutôt que de nous
aider souvenez-vous pour toujours des
noms de ceux qui ont refusé ce combat ou
pire qui ont préféré relayer les
arguments calomieux et antiommunistes de
l'extrême droite contre
nous pas de consigne de vote en tout cas
pas dès ce soir chez François beayrou le
candidat du MoDem obtient 8,8 % un score
au-dessous de ses attentes a-t-il
déclaré en direct de son QG rue de
l'Université à Paris je vous propose de
l'écouter je vais m'adresser aux deux
candidats sélectionnés pour le deuxè
tour je vais leur dire ce qui est pour
nous l'essentiel en terme de valeur en
terme d'action à conduire j'écouterai
dans les jours qui viennent leurs
réponsse et je prendrai mes
responsabilités
et puis le président du Sénat le
socialiste Jean-Pierre belle a également
réagi au score de François Hollande pour
lui ce soir c'est une nouvelle campagne
qui commence on l'écoute il était au
micro de Joakim Rob on va voir arriver
dans cette deème partie de campagne
frontalement de conceptions de notre
société de vision de l'avenir dans dans
le fond de façon de concevoir la
République la République vue par
François Hollande ben elle n'a rien à
voir avec cette République qui a été é
abîmé par Nicolas Sarkozi et je crois
qu'au travers des des journées que nous
allons vivre jusqu'au 6 mai nous verrons
bien la différence entre deux candidat
parce que il y a une différence dans les
comportements il y a une différence dans
les personnalités et il y a surtout une
différence dans le projet qu'il propose
pour les
Français et puis pour être tout à fait
complet sur ces résultats un dernier
chiffre celui de l'abstention qui
s'estlevé toujours selon les estimations
de notre partenaire l'institut Ipsos ce
soir à 19,7 % voilà c'est la fin de ce
flash on retrouve tout de suite Émilie
Aubri et Michel grossior avec leurs
invités pour commenter et analyser tous
ces résultats merci beaucoup Delphine
Gérard c'était le flash de 22h pour tous
ceux qui nous rejoignent seulement merci
d'avoir choisi les chaînes
parlementaires pour vivre en direct les
résultats de ce premier tour nous ont
rejoint sur ce plateau quatre nouveaux
invités Roland kérol ça commence bien
que je salue bonsoir vous êtes
politologue bien sûr on vous reçoit
fréquemment sur la chaîne parle
parlementaire jean-dianiel Levy de Louis
Haris que je salue également Jean ui
sénateur centriste merci d'être avec
nous et puis Yve Cochet député européen
d'Europe Écologie Les Verts alors on le
sent bien Michel depuis quelques minutes
maintenant une petite heure voilà
vraiment la campagne du deuxè Tour a
commencé on voit bien est-ce qu'il faut
trois débats est-ce qu'il n'en faut
qu'un on voit bien on commence bien avec
les interventions de François Holland
celle de Nicolas Sarkozy on commence à
voir sur quoi va se jouer cette campagne
du 2è tour Roland kérol dites-nous vous
comment vous voyez les choses pour les
jours qui viennent dans la teneur du
débat qui va maintenant s'enclencher
entre les deux hommes écoutez on a le
sentiment que l'un et l'autre ont assez
clairement annoncé la couleur hein il
s'agit pour Nicolas Sarkozi d'atteindre
l'impossible l'équation du premier tour
rend les choses extrêmement compliquées
pour lui hein si 80 % des électeurs de
Marine Le Pen et les 2 tiers des
électeur de François baayrou vote pour
lui ça ne suffit pas il faut en plus une
mobilisation d'abstention des
changements voilà donc il faut mesurer
la difficulté qui est devant lui on dit
il a dit lui-même plusieurs fois c'est
une nouvelle élection qui commence
est-ce vrai bah c'est une nouvelle
élection sur la base des résultats du
premier g voilà donc c'est pas tout à
fait ça là vous dites mathématiquement
ça tient pas quoi mathématiquement sur
le papier il a perdu mais une élection
c'est pas mathématiquement et sur le
papier tant que l'élection n'est pas
finie tout est jouable et même ces trois
variables impossibles à réunir d'un coup
il est pas absolument exclu qu'il y
arrive alors c'est vrai que on entend
beaucoup de critiques des instituts de
sondage de la part des ténurs de l'UMP
ce soir jean-aniel levis pour une fois
c'est bien tort hein oui euh non le
score de Marine Le Pen avait été
sous-estimé
par semble il semble qu'elle soit à
l'heure où nous parlons entre 182 et 185
elle était d' quoi 16 17 dans la plupart
des instituts en fin de campagne je l
est là aussi pour défendre justement les
standard des institut
SR à l'UMP on dit donc que rien n'est
joué on ne peut pas se fonder sur les
sondages euh on peut pas se fonder sur
les sondages on sait qu'il y a des
campagnes on sait que ça permet de faire
évoluer les les représentations quoi
qu'il en soit il y a deux éléments qui
apparaissent comme étant euh
relativement forts le premier élément
c'est que le fait que nous ayons
aujourd'hui au 2è tour de qualifier et
François Hollande et Nicolas Sarkozi ne
constiue pas une surprise c'était le
duel qui était un duel qui était annoncé
annoncé depuis le 2e tour de la primaire
socialiste et toutes les intentions de
vote ont donné à avoir je crois qu'il y
a eu plus de 200 sondages qui ont été
réalisés que le duel qui était attendu
c'est un duel donc c'est pas aujourd'hui
une surprise de la part des électeur qui
se réveill en se disant tiens c'est pas
forcément le scénario que nous avons
entendu deuxième élément sur toutes les
intentions de vote qui ont été réalisées
depuis cette période là aucune n'a
montré que Nicolas Sarkozi était
susceptible de pouvoir gagner ou
remporter l'élection au deuxième tour
même si on va un peu plus loin et qu'on
regarde l'ensemble des enquêtes aucun
n'a montré un écart qui était un écart
inférieur à 6 points c'est l'écart le
plus plus serré ça a été 47 en faveur de
Nicolas SARKOZY 53 en de Fran vous
écoute pour vous c'est plié c'est pas ce
que je dis un peuable que comend parce
qu'il y a une prudence de
sondeur dit par exemple il y a des
réserves à gauche il n'y en a pas à
droite est-ce que vous êtes d'accord
aujourd'hui indéiablement oui
indéiablement on retrouve indéiablement
enfin quand vous regardez aujourd'hui
l'appel de Mélenchon qui est un appel
même s'il n'utilise pas le mot François
Hollande qui est un appel indéniable à
voter en faveur de François Hollande et
même lorsqu'on va auprès d'un électorat
qui est un électorat centriste
aujourd'hui c'est-à-dire qui a voté pour
François maerou on a pu voir dans les
différentes enquête qu'il y avait
indépendamment des personnes qui
déclaraient qu'il n'allaient pas voter
au deuxième tour quasiment une
répartition à moitié moitié en faveur de
François Hollande d'un côté en faveur
deines de vote aujourd'hui n'ont plus
réellement d'utilité alors que pensez de
tous ces électeurs qui ont voté Marine
Le Pen presque 20 % comment le sondeur
peut essayer de deviner à ce jour de
mesurer comment va se faire le report de
voie en leur posant la question c'est
pas idio comme méthode tout simplement
et jusqu'à présent métier de base
descendeur il faut le rappeler à un
moment dans les Français nous disent pas
tout à fait la vérité ou ils peuvent se
mentir un peu à eu-même mais en tout cas
quand on leur pose la question que nous
disent-il ils nous disent en gros pour
20 à 25 % d'entre eux de toute façon le
duel annoncé Nicolas Sarkozi François
Hollande ne m'intéresse pas je n'irai
pas voter et après parmi ce qui reste on
a un rapport en gros de 2 ti3 1/3 2
tiers en faveur de Nicolas Sarkozi 1/ers
en faveur de François Hollande on va
voir si les thématiques de campagne qui
sont adopté ça peut changer avec le
débat de l'entre de tour l'le débat de
l'entre de tour change parfois un tout
petit peu les choses quand l'élection
est extrêmement serré nous ne savons pas
où on sera l'élection le 2 mai il y a
une chose qui est tout à fait
fondamentale c'est que si François
baayerou ne fait pas le score qu'il
espérait autour de 8 et demi ses
électeurs vont être comme d'habitude
dans une présidentielle au second tour
les électeurs décisifs qu'il donneent
clairement une consigne de vote ou pas
c'est eux qui vont vont faire pencher le
plateau de la balance et dans les
sondages d'avant l'élection ils étaient
un/ers un/ers un/ers un/ers baayrou
un/ers abstentionniste parole aura du
poid sa pas ce qu'il veut dire quand il
il prendra je prendrai mes
responsabilités ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire que probablement il indiquera
une préférence probablement probablement
et ça veut dire quand même que dans
cette situation d'incertitude de
l'électorat centriste qui va être
l'électorat décisif ça peut tout de même
avoir un poid alors nous avons avec nous
JEI qui est un soutien majeur de
François ou vous allez répondre à toutes
ces questions bien sûr on a envie de
savoir de quel côté va-t-il pencher
votre candidat qui quand même enregistre
un troè échec présidentiel c'est dur
pour vous ce soir c'est une
déception nous ne faisions pas trop
d'illusion sur sa qualification les
sondages étaient là mais même pas un
score à à deux chiffres c'est une
déception François bairou a mené une
campagne de vérité sur la dette publique
c'était pas nouveau il avait déjà fait
en
2007 sur la compétitivité pour recréer
de l'emploi et du pouvoir d'achat et
rééquilibrer les pays européens on va
pas refaire sa campagne on a dit tout à
l'heure sur la base des chiffres de
d'psos que les Français avaient trouvé
qu'il avait fait une bonne campagne sur
le fond on sait qu'il a une forte
personnalité mais ça ne prend pas al
d'abord le rapport entre la gauche et la
droite n'est pas tout à fait ce qu'on
imaginait à la veille de cette
consultation dire qu'il est moins
favorable à la gauche le jeu est un tout
petit peu plus ouvert me semble-t-il euh
que ce que l'on pensait euh avant la
consultation d'où votre importance
est-ce que euh vous attendez de François
Baayou qu'il prenne clairement position
pour l'un ou l'autre des fin des
finalistes ouiou non je pas qu'il moi
oui j'attends attendez c'est c'est notre
convention moi j'ai rejoint euh François
baayerou je suis pas modemme je suis
alliance centriste il est rendu que nous
devions ensemble interroger euh les deux
qualifiés en clair demain si demain vous
voyez François Barou se prononcer pour
François Hollande vous serez très
surpris consid voilà les choses sérieuse
commence on va avoir trois débats sur
l'économique et le social sur les
problèmes de sociétéun seul débat refuse
la notion de trois débats il y en aura
qu'un seul une soirée peut-être longue
mais un seul en tout cas comme si on
allait enfin parler des choses sérieuses
il m'est arrivé de penser pendant cette
campagne on va pas le reprendre mais que
les les thèmes étaient à la limite de la
frivolité par
h non mais vous avez abordé les bons
thèmes ça ne paye pas dans les viandes
pourquoi et ben pourquoi parce que on a
du mal à voir la réalité en face parce
qu'on voit bien qu'il y a un monde qui
est en train qui est en fin de cycle et
qu'il va
falloir se mettre dans la mondialisation
y trouver notre place c'est pas en
s'isolant en se repliant sur soi-même
donc ce débatlà je l'attends et j'espère
euh avec impatience que la préparation
les deux semaines qui nous séparent du
du second tour vont permettre de
clarifier les positions Roland Carol sur
ce mystère baayrou he toutes les
enquêtes le démontrent il convain on lui
s gré de dire la vérité de mettre en
avant les bons thèmes et pourtant ça ne
prend pas et quelle est la moins bonne
solution pour lui aujourd'hui écoutez il
a une image personnelle il a une image
personnelle excellente il est un homme
d'État il a dit des choses vraies le
premier le problème c'est que ce qui
fait son j'allais dire pardon son fond
de commerce politique qui est dire plus
les deux grands camps autre chose c'est
en même temps ce qui a à un moment quand
l'élection approche devient son problème
les gens à forcur en période de crise
ils ont envie de savoir qui va les
gouverner avec qui ils vont gouverner
avec qui ils vont s'allier et le fait de
continuer à dire ni gauche ni droite
dans une élection qui devient de plus en
plus gauche droite rien avir c'est aussi
ce que fait Marine Le Pen ça lui réussit
plutôt non non Marine Le Pen elle elle
ne dit pas ça elle dit clairement
qu'elle est à l'extrême d'un de
l'échiquier politique et les gens qui
ont envie de renverser l'échiquier ils
la suivent mais de ce point de vue il
n'est pas sûr d'ailleurs qu'il se
reporte autant sur Nicolas Sarkozi que
le croit Nicolas Sarkozi parce que
précisément les choses sont plus
compliqué du point de vue des électeurs
Jean comment est-ce que vous résumez
vous le second tour je vois Jean-Claude
Gudin qui dit on a le choix entre le
courage et la démagogie de votre point
de vue de centriste comment est-ce que
vous voyez le duel et l'opposition allez
trouver vos mots ce n pas ce sont pas
des ce sont pas des mot centristes on
essaie de vous brusquer un peu dans
votre nature ce so je pense je pense
qu'il va falloir mettre les candidats
face à ces problèmes précisément il
suffit pas de dire on va réduire la
dette publique on va retrouver de la
compétitiv comment y
parvient-on la durée du temps de
travail toutes ces normes qu'on a
multiplié à l'envie et qui sont toutes
des activateurs de dépenses publiques
comment va-t-on les traiter
désormais j' me trompe si je dis que
vous savez bien sûr pour qui vous allez
voter dans 15 jours jeanartu écoutez
j'attends demain je réunis mon comité
directeur de l'Alliance Centriste et
vous m'autorisez quand même à attendre
ce moment allez c'est accordé jusqu'à
demain merci en tout cas pour ces
réactions pour ces commentaires je vous
propose qu'on retrouve maintenant une
nouvelle fois Caroline Deschamps dans la
salle de rédaction publique Sénat c'est
elle qui suit pour nous tout ce qui se
passe ce soir sur la toile et il se
passe beaucoup de choses Caroline et oui
et l'intervention de Nicolas Sarkozi
fait réagir Twitter et notamment sa
proposition d'organiser trois débats
Versac écrit moi je veux un débat par
jour 12 au minimum Bruno Roger petit le
journaliste écrit trois débats il n'a
plus que ça c'est Rambo 5 Sarkozi alors
Marine Le Pen la 3è femme de ce scrutin
fait encore beaucoup gloser sur Twitter
le journaliste Olivier Picard écrit
Nicolas Sarkozi ne voulait pas admettre
que les ambiguités répétées de son
discours droitier validit les thèses du
FN et ce soir demande-t-il Arnaud le
parmentier journaliste monde l'écrit lui
sans ambage le 22 avril c'est le
lendemain du 21 avril c'est la France
qui pue et puis les internaut commentent
également beaucoup la déclaration de
François Baayou à l'image de police NES
et notamment sur sa non consigne de vote
elle écrit baayrou attend de se faire
draguer pour décider il ne facilite donc
pas la tâche à Hollande et à Sarkozi la
vraie politique commence Audrey pulevard
la la compagne d'Arnaud montebour écrit
Quantel François baayerou va attendre
les réponses des deux impétrants à ses
interrogations et puis sur la forme
certains tweetos se gos du dispositif de
France 2 Sylvain Zimerman écrit vive le
sport sur France 2 vive la moto tandis
que Fabrice pelozi tweet quant à lui au
second tour France 2 tentera
d'interviewver Nicolas sarcoszi à
travers le le hublot de son Falcon en
plein vol la la déclaration
de François Hollande et quant à elle
assez peu commenté même si la plupart la
juge plutôt digne pour la journaliste de
elle Michel fitousi c'est sans appel
Hollande endosse le costume présidentiel
et Sarkozi prend la veste merci beaucoup
Caroline avec deux invités qui nous ont
rejoint ce soir sur le plateau Monsieur
Roland museau du Front de Gauche bonsoir
vous vous apprêtez à aller voir vos amis
ça sera peut-être pas tout à fait la
fête manifestement ce soir pour le Front
de gauche qui espérait Jean-Luc
Mélenchon en tête un meilleur score ça
sera la fête quand même ça sera la fête
quand même brunoich est avec nous
bonsoir Marine Le Pen a été votre rivale
pour la présidence du Front national ce
soir vous saluez sans score oui
absolument sans réserve oui quand on
participe à une compétition on en a M le
résultat ça a toujours été mon cas et je
suis heureux que la cause que nous
représentons tous les deux
re 18 de et 20 % quels sont vos chiffres
à vous brunonich je sais pas c'était
c'est c'est vous les professionnels de
l'information en tout cas c'est un très
bon beau succès qui dém d'ailleurs les
sondages qui donnaient Jean-Luc
Mélanchon devant Marine Le Pen de façon
assez constante durant le dernier mois
de la campagne vous confirmez être le
premier parti par exemple auprès des
classes les plus populaires les ouvriers
oui absolument auprès des ouvriers aussi
dans le dans le monde rural il y a une
progression absolument impressionnante
je pense une France qui ne veut pas
mourir et dans le monde ouvrier en
réalité Jean-Luc menchon n'a pas n'a pas
pris c'est un son avavantage et
permanent syndicaux les bobo les
observateurs disent excellent début de
campagne pour jeanc Mélenchon qui se
peut-être un peut tasser sur la fin non
c'est une remarquable campagne qui a
mobilisé je crois un un peuple de de
gauche qui aujourd'hui était un peu en
en difficulté par rapport à ses
positionnement qui ne trouvait pas les
réponses auxquelles il aspirait et si
nous atteignons aux alentours d'environ
12 % c'est un remarquable succès je vous
signale que nous étions la seule
formation de gauche qui nous
positionnions contre un combat contre le
Front national et contre les idées de
l'extrême droite qui d'ailleurs était
reprise vioire d'illeurs bien évidemment
bien évidemment ils ont enregistré une
victoire éta pour moi une énorme
déception de ce point de vue parce que
je trouve c'est gravissime pour notre
peuple et pour le peuple en général et
le monde du travail en particulier et je
pense que les questions qui sont
aujourd'hui posées par le résultat de
ces élections sont absolument
considérables dans la mesure où le le
Front national additionné à Monsieur
Sarkozi qui ne renit en rien et Monsieur
Copé ce soir s'est vanté que ses premers
thèmes de campagne pour le deuxème tour
soit exactement les thèmes de ceux qui
sont avancés par Monsieur golnich et
Madame Le Pen c'est dramatique pour la
cohésion nationale dans notre if Cochet
comment chez les Verts on on regarde la
campagne qu'AM mené Jean-Luc Mélenchon
mais c'était une bonne campagne in
contestablement il a bénéficié
évidemment du fait que le NPA et l'ut
ouvrière n'étaient pas représenté par
les gens très médiatiques et que par
conséquent il a eu la un vote de
rassemblement disons de la gauche
radicale avec nos amis communistes je
crois crois qu'il a mené une bonne
campagne nous on a été avec Eva jolie
qui a mené aussi une bonne campagne mais
ça a été un peu l'effet je dire l'effet
berou aussi c'est-à-dire que la la
parole de vérité qu'elle a pu dire ne
plaît pas toujours et par conséquent son
son caractère plus plus fort quoi plus
déterminé a fait que il y a pas eu cette
campagne ca fait Jean-Luc Mélenchon une
campagne disons de de héros à ult
c'est-à-dire le fait de parler au peuple
avec avec les les mots du peuple mais
maintenant on est tous rassembl pour
soutenir François Hollande et j'espère
que tous ensemble on va
gagner je vous vouz réagir notamment à
ce que disait monsieur Muso sur
l'appropriation de de vos thèmes par
Nicolas Sarko honnêtement ce que je
trouve assez dramatique moi c'est qu'il
est encore autant de Français qui se
rattache au au recettes éculées du
marxisme qui a été l'imposture la plus
sanglante de l'histoire contemporaine é
éche un échec total la peste brune c'est
vous la peste brune un échec total dans
toute l'Europe la peste brune grandit et
ça c'est un vrai danger pour les peuples
et la démocratie et que Nicolas Sarkozi
fasse de la peste brune un de ces thme
de campagne c'est
graviss c'est votreavisme totalitaire
qui je le C mais ce que je crois moi
c'est que c'est que je ne suis pas moi
l'héritier de la peste brune tandis que
Pest brune d'ailleurs monsieur parlait
de Monsieur sarzy comme le national
socialiste encore quelques jours
seulement ça prve qu'il le dénoncait
lesau
rou réz
Maré cont00 € vous êtes contre la
renégociation des trait européen vous
êtes vous avez été pour le trait bien
évidemment vous êtes pour que
rienangees capme privilég dans ce pay
voil la
réalité et vous allez vous allier avec
SAR pour le deè tour voilà c'est ça la
réalit vous AZ fini non non j'ai pas
finé dites nous sommes contre la
renégociation des traités européens
votre candidat Mélenchon a voté
maastrichtonter histoires allez allez
allez arrêtez de
raconterand européen peut porter
témoignage de ce que nous avons toujours
été hostil à l'intégration de la France
dans l'Union euré je ne vais pas
souscrire à une seule de vos paroles
Monsieur Madame Jie attaqué Madame Le
Pen ou plutôt Madame Le Pen elle a perdu
deux fois elle a perdu de fois oui c'est
extraordinaire ça c'est intéressant on
peut revenir un instant làdessus instant
donir instant la justice rend la justice
la justice a considéré que Madame Jie
qui est pourtant juge d'instruction
pouvait prononcer des propos diffamato
car elle les a jugé diffamatoire en
cours d'appel contre Marine Le
Pen mais qu'elle avait l'excuse de la
bonne foi parce qu'elle était en direct
autrement dit une personne autrement dit
excusez-moi une personne qui a été juge
d'Instruction juge d'instruction un juge
d'instruction ça doit savoir ce que
c'est que la présomption d'inocque
elle fait la polique
Érard larch sur ce plateau qui vous
écoute
paisement
hello on a Gérard Larché sur ce plateau
sénateur UMP ex président du Sénat bien
sûr bienvenue et bonsoir à vous on voit
bien ce qui se joue sur ce plateau entre
vous deux Roland m Bruno Go c'est
exactement ce qui s'est joué par meeting
interposé dans cette campagne du premier
tour pourquoi finalement j'ai envie de
vous poser cette question il y a eu
cette cristallisation sur vos deux parti
par les observateurs Bruno goldnich par
rejet du système bien sûr mais
contrairement à ce qu'on dit le vote
d'exaspération et ce ça n'est pas le
vote Fond national le vote Fond national
c'est un vote parfaitement cohérent de
gens qui savent ce qu'ils veulent et de
savent aussi qui savent aussi ce qui ce
dont ils ne veulent
pas vot le le vote le vote du front
Front de gauche comme je le dis se
rattache à des solutions qui ont qui ont
fait faillite absolument partout
voilà mais ça c'est c'est n'importe quoi
le vote du Front de Gauche positionne
sur des questions offensives objectives
qui sont celles du pouvoir d'achat de
nos concitoyens sur les droits des
travailleurs sur la la mise à terme des
licenciements et des fermetures
d'entreprises simplement au nom des des
des ressources boursières et des
manipulations boursières qui peuvent
avoir lieu les délocalisations voilà on
a parlé du peuple on a parlé des
travailleurs voilà qui a été le
positionnement positif de deérard lar
est avec nous Gérard larch Nicolas SAR
n'est pas en pôle position on peut le
dire pour le second tour comment doit-il
l'aborder selon vous d'abord il faut que
nous ision car les Français qui nous
écoutent ce soir peut-être ils voient
les affrontements mais ils ont d'abord
exprimé massivement un certain nombre de
message aujourd'hui et un choix et ça il
faut l'entendre et l'écouter c'est
d'abord pour moi un vote de crise mais
je l'avais déjà dit depuis longtemps je
sens dans ce pays que la question de de
la crise est extrêmement présente je
l'ai vu en rendant à Rapport au
Président de la République il y a moins
de 15 jours j'ai vu que la question du
CH je est dans chacune des familles et
qu'elle touche chacune des familles quel
que soit leur vote qu'il
vote gauche mais attendezés la solution
la solution aujourd'hui il faut qu'on
essaie de de la trouver ou de la
trouver ça fait 10 ans trou aujourd'hui
nous voyons bien que notre pays a plutôt
mieux résisté que d'autres pays fent à
la crise en Europe aujourd'hui ce qu'il
faut retrouver c'est une forme
d'espérance et ça va être le choix VO du
second tour entre deux candidats les
choses sont claires c'est pas 9 contre
un c'est aujourd'hui un contre un projet
contre projet voilà pourquoi TR débat
comme le propose le président de la
République Nicolas Sarkozi
candidat c'est non la réponse non il
n'empêche que c'est l'occasion c'est
l'occasion j'allais dire sur les
questions économiques et social sur les
questions de conception de l'Europe de
frontière de l'Europe de gouvernance et
bien de se poser la vraie question et
puis je sens bien aussi que la
communauté nationale se pose en
elle-même à certain nombre de questions
non pas pour exclure les uns par rapport
aux autres mais il y a la question des
communautarisme par rapport à l'unité
nationale et pour le gaulis que je suis
unité nationale c'est un rassemblement
vous approuvez tout dans la campagne de
Nicolas SARC j'ai exprimé que la
question sociale n'était pas assez
présente je l'ai dit et donc je n'ai
aucune difficulté à le redire ce soir
voà pourquoi je pense que la question
sociale doit
être on a peu parlé de question de santé
on a peu parl de
questionour nauand je suis quelqu
responsabilitent
ré de ce que vous venez deard cont au
projet il vous faut maintenant trouver
des partenaires alors on va justement
voir tout de suite ce qu'en pense
Philippe doublasi il nous attend au
modem est-ce qu'il nous entend bien
bonsoir Philippe
doublasi bonsoir alors toute la question
l'une des questions qui se pose ce soir
c'est de savoir ce que va faire François
Baayou on avait beaucoup dit que vous
pouviez peut-être jouer ce rôle de
rapprochement entre le candidat du MoDem
et l'UMP quelle est votre position ce
soir à vous
personnellement écoutez il y a près de 3
millions de d'électeurs qui ont voté
pour François baayrou et donc vous ne
voulez pas quand même que quelques
secondes quelques minutes après cette
élection on puisse comme ça faire part
d'allian qui aurait eu lieu il y a
aucune alliance et il y a par contre des
idées des idées des convictions des
engagements politiques qui nous
paraissent essentiels que nous avons
avec honnêteté défendu pendant cette
campagne et avec courage de la part de
François Baayou par exemple la
construction européenne on a pas entendu
parler de construction européenne sauf
pour dire que l'espace Schengen était
une catastrophe sauf pour attaquer
l'Europe comme Monsieur Mélenchon ou
Madame Le Pen qui a même mis en cause
l'euro on a parlé d'éducation on a parlé
de réanimation de l'appareil productif
français et on a parlé surtout de
modernisation de la vie publique de
moralisation de la vie publique et donc
oui nous allons regarder avec attention
les attitudes les déclarations des deux
candidats les débats ou le débat plutôt
je repose ma question responsabilités
vous personnellement Philippe dou Blasi
je repose ma question quelle est votre
position ce so pour vous stratégiquement
vers où doit aller François
Baayou pardon mais oui moi maintenant je
vais aller voir François Baayou moi
personnellement comme vous dites je vais
aller voir François baayerou nous allons
parler ensemble c'est une commun accord
il ne s'agit pas ce soir d'être
totalement désordonné il s'agit d'une
chose excessivement importante
maintenant Marine Le Pen a fait 20 %
est-ce que demain par exemple pour aller
quelque part chercher les électeurs du
Front national est-ce que le candidat de
l'UMP va se tourner directement vers eux
est-ce que le candidat de gauche va se
tourner délibérément vers le candidat
d'extrême gauche sont des choses qui
sont très importantes madame avant de
s'exprimer et avant de dire quel est
notre point de vue nous prendrons nos
responsabilité bien évidemment Philippe
doueblas vous avez donc rejoint au début
de l'année he François Baou dans dans
son combat est-ce qu'il a toujours la
possibilité aujourd'hui hein de réformer
le centre de Le regrouper plutôt autour
de lui est-ce que vous redoutez qu'une
partie de l'UMP fasse alliance demain
avec le Front national Bruno golnich
vous écoute sur ce plateau il vous
répondre dans une minute non ça je ne
sais pas du tout ce que fera l'UMP ou le
Front national car je n'appartiens ni à
l'un ni à l'autre même si j'ai fondé
cofondé l'UMP non euh aujourd'hui je
pense que il est excessivement important
d'avoir une force politique en France
d'équilibre qui soit totalement à l'abri
des extrêmes loin des sectarisme comme
une sorte de vigilance je crois que
c'est important pour notre vie politique
et donc il y a un deuxème tour mais il y
a aussi un 3è tour législatif dans
lequel il y aura bien évidemment
j'espère cette force d'équilibre
politique merci en tout cas merci de
votre invit merci Philippe doueblas
d'avoir été en direct sur le plateau de
la Chaîne Parlementaire Gérard larch
Bruneau golnich vous êtes tous les deux
ensemble sur ce même plateau ce soir on
voit bien qu'on commence déjà à parler
de recomposition de la droite après ces
résultats du premier tour est-ce que
vous vous envisagez de pouvoir discuter
ensemble sur quelle thématique
pouvez-vous être d'accord pouvez-vous
construire quelque chose ensemble mais
nous sommes d'une certaine façon les les
les moteurs de la vie politique
française tenez par exemple monsieur dou
Blasi que je viens d'entendre critiquer
ce qu'il appelle les extrêmes comme
peut-être de l'extrême centre lui je ne
sais pas euh
il son
candidat François Baou a fait campagne
sur le thème ah maintenant il faut
produire français il découvre il a
découvert la désindustrialisation du
pays il a découvert qu'il fallait
produire français et de préférence avec
des travailleurs français c'était non
mais c'est ma réponse excusez-moi c'est
un thème c'est un thème c'est un thème
quand le Front national disait ça quand
Le Pen disait ça quand je disais ça à
l'Europe et cetera François qui était à
l'époque
unose avec vous oui ou des plus
européistes qui soit trouvait que
c'était chauin que c'était étriqué que
c'était national aut autrement autrement
dit l'es bien et bien c'est cet aspect
il y a au moins un aspect de la
préférence nationale qui est passé chez
Monsieur beou ça prouve que l'esprit
vient même à ceux qui ont y est le plus
longtemps possible les réalités à
s'installer dans le paysage à près de 20
% Bren est-ce que demain
que le Front national doit évoluer même
changer de nom et trouver de nouvelles
alliances peut-être à la droite de l'UMP
à la Droite populaire je P ce que je
pense en ce qui concerne les alliances
c'est que il y a des éléments
patriotiques aussi bien à gauche déjà
beaucoup de chevénantiste non des
moindres qui nous ont rejoint et à
droite je pense que l'UMP ne survivra
pas à l'échec programmé à l'éche
laissez-moi terminer ma phrase s'il vous
plaît à l'échec programmé de Nicolas
Sarko que des blocs s'en détacheront et
se rejoindr donc c'est bien vous
confirmer que c'est votre calcul et
c'est le choix à moyen terme de
calul calcul parce que le si ça crie
beaucoup au Sénat non non monsieur ça
fait du bien le soir comme ça vous
sortir le CB c'est les Françaises et les
Français qui choisiront entre deux
hommes entre deux projets entre deux
conceptions de la République et c'est ça
qui compte ça n'est pas une petite
cuisine avec des petites sauceson arrang
6 ma conction de la politique qui est
très attaché à la 5 République
l'élection présidentielle est une
élection fondatrice c'est vraiment un
débat entre deux candidats franais que
dit la droite de gouvernement ce soir au
Front national jamais avec vous ou
peut-être on réfléch en tous les cas je
me suis déjà clairement exprimé je crois
en certain nombre de valeurs et ces
valeurs là pour moi elles sont
intangibles et notamment que l'homme
l'humanisme su est au cœur j'allais dire
de mon engagement politique je ne fais
pr une attention à personne je dis le 6
mai ne nous trompons pas les deux
semaines qui viennent c'est vraiment ce
dialogue entre les Français et deux
candû vous vous adressez à François
baayerou vous ne vous adressez pas à
Marine Le Pen je ne m'adresse pas à
François baayrou j'ai avec François
beayou eu des contacts permanents depuis
des années parce que sur un certain
nombre de sujets nous l'avons partagé
quand j'ai
euh conduit les réflexions sur des
sujets comme la santé et par exemple
j'ai débattu avec les habis de François
beou comme j'ai débattu avec tous ceux
qui avaient envie de débattre mais
vraiment ne nous trompons pas on n'est
pas dans une élection législative on est
en élection c'est pas je ne veux pas
répondre ça n'est pas le sujet du 6 vous
avez dit clairement en tout cas ce que
vous pensiez d'une éventuelle alliance
accord avec le Front national je salue
l'arrivée sur ce plateau de Jean-Marie
leogan député socialiste de Paris même
si Bruno gold je considère que vous
n'avez rien dit Jean-Marie Logan qu'on
dit inscrit sur la liste de François
Hollande s'il est élu pour peut-être
aller au ministère de la Santé
en tour en êtes-vous là ce
soir non pas du tout vraiment nous
sommes je crois que chacun prend les
résultats de ce soir avec beaucoup de
sérieux etun certain point de vue de la
gravité nous sommes dans une situation
où François landand est en tête avec une
très large participation des Français
c'est une bonne chose mais en même temps
on voit bien quand même s'est exprimé
au-delà du rejet du président sortant
une colère très forte dans le pays et
donc il va falloir répondre à ces
questions je crois que François Holland
est en position naturelle pour
l'emporter mais je crois que cette
élection il va se jouer plusieurs choses
la victoire électorale à proprement parl
mais aussi la capacité que nous allons
avoir à rassembler les Français pour
sortir de cette crise par le haut et je
crois que le discours qu' a tenu tout à
l'heure François Hollande où il s'est
exprimé sur les fondamentaux qui sont
les
sur aussi bien la question sociale
l'emploi la question européenne qui est
très importante je pense qu'il y a une
vraie divergence fondamentale entre les
droites européennes et ce que propose
François
Hollande la politique d'austérité qui
est aujourd'hui mise en œuvre d'une
façon abusive dangereuse par Madame
Merkel par Monsieur Sarkozy qui
conduitou aussi en Grèce quand même
monsieur PAP andreéou n'est plus au
pouvoir comme vous l'avez remarqué et il
a été effectivement victime à l'époque
vous pensiez qu'on pouvait sortir
facilement de l'euro je crois qu'il a
été démontré que c'était plus difficile
en clair question pour pour tous les
deux Jean-Marie Lequen garché on a
beaucoup dit cl l'urope c'est une
question claire qui est présente
dans on a beaucoup dit dans cette
campagne he c'était d'ailleurs un
article du Monde il y a trois e qui
n'ont pas été évoqués l'environnement
l'Europe l'écologie est-ce que cette
campagne du deuxième tour elle peut être
l'occasion n'est pas été évoqué regardez
les propositions de Nicolas Sarkozi sur
la question
de membre de la commission ici de
contrôle de la mise en place de Schengen
il était prévu un rendez-vous pour faire
le point sur la gouvernance de Schengen
on l'a oublié Nicolas Sarkozy l'a
rappelé la question de l'Europe c'est
pas simplement l'austérité c'est aussi
retrouver les conditions de la
croissance en Europe parce qu'on sait
que seul la croissance crée la richesse
et c'est la richesse qui crée l'emploi
oui mais justement la politique qui est
menée à l'heure actuelle par les droites
européennes au premier rang desquel
évidemment Madame Merkel aboutit
aujourd'hui à une situation économique
et sociale et politique et
monsieur qui appartenz à votre famille
politique qui n'a pas connu le sort de
Monsieur papendreou il faut le
reconnaître et bien nous voyons bien
qu'il y a des nécessités de retour à
l'équilibre dans les pays continu comme
ça continuer comme ça et il faudra pas
s'étonner que l'extrême droite fasse
effectivement un certain nombre de voix
en Europe parce que la politique
économique absurde l'austérité tout
entier tourné vers la satisfaction des
marchés aboutit aujourd'hui à une chute
de la croissance à une baisse de
l'emploi à une crise sociale comme
jamais et il est temps qui non seulement
dans notre pays mais en Europe une autre
politique voyager un peu dans Paris
maintenant si vous voulez bien j'ai une
question encore pour Bruno goldnich
Marine Le Pen annonce qu'elle va prendre
position qu'elle va annoncer sa position
le 1emier mai ou à place de l'opé très
bien laquelle souhaitez-vous de sa part
comme prise de position vous l'élection
est à deux tours et il y a 15 jours
entre les deux tours c'est pour c'est
pour analyser ce que disent ce que
fontux
c je vais je vais en parler avec elle je
lui réser la primeur de mes analyses
ferz à sa place vous si vous aviez été
élu président du Front national que
j'écouterai ce que disent les deux
candidats restés en list d'accord donc
c'est trour allez on va faire un dernier
point sur les ambiances dans les deux
principaux sièges des deux principaux
candidats ceux du 2è tour on va tout de
suite retrouver Germain andriux Germain
décrivez-nous un petit peu l'ambiance
autour de vous il les 22h44 à l'UMP
oui et bien effectivement comme vous
pouvez le voir dernièrement il n'y a
plus beaucoup de de militants à la
Mutualité les militants se sont assez
vite en allés après les derniers mots de
Nicolas Sarkozi des militants et bien
qui avaient du mal à cacher leur
stupéfaction avec le score très élevé
effectivement de Marine Le Pen à Nicolas
Sarkozi en 2e place pas question de
s'attarder sur cette 2è place pas
question non plus de se laisser
déstabiliser par les sondages qui à
répétition invariablement et bien
prédisent la victoire de Françis
Hollande ici et bien on veut croire que
dès demain une nouvelle campagne
commence il reste 15 jours et les
militants ont beaucoup applaudi bien
cette proposition faite par Nicolas
Sarkozi d'organiser trois débats pendant
cette rent de Tours ici on veut bien sûr
croire que Nicolas Sarkozi peut encore
le porter en face- à faceace face à
François Hollande projet contre projet
et le premier meeting est déjà fixé dès
demain dans la région de tour Nicolas
Sarkozi tiendra un meeting à 18h merci
beaucoup on va voir s'il y a plus de
monde à l'heure où nous parlons au Parti
socialiste sol ferino à Paris bien sûr
michaelll zames toujours sur place
michaell
oui toujours sur place alors l'invité
surprise à 22h46 Michel et bien c'est la
pluie et le vent qui viennent de
s'inviter ici rue de Solferino et dans
Paris ce qui a douché les derniers
espoir ici des militants et des
sympathisants qui étaient réunis à Rue
de Solferino la rue avait été bloquée
avec des écrans géants et là évidemment
et bien il y a plus personne et iici
aussi vous le voyez au siège du Parti
socialiste et bien on vide un petit peu
les lieux la soirée touche un peu à sa
fin ce qui n'a pas empêché les militants
ici réunis très nombreux d20h pour
écouter François Hollande notamment
auentour de 21h et bien d'applaudir à
tout rompre à partir du moment où on a
donné les résultats mais la campagne
continue François Hollande est attendue
dès demain du côté de quimpère et en
Bretagne notamment à Lorient et ici les
dirigeants du Parti socialiste insistent
il reste bien sûr un 2è tour et ce
deuxème tour reste à préparer à partir
de demain des réunions se tiennent un
petit peu partout dans Paris au fugé de
François Hollande notamment très attendu
une réunion demain matin mais ici Rud de
Solferino on voit bien que l'ambiance
est retombée un tout petit peu et on
attend évidemment dans une quinzaine de
jours ce deuxième tour que ce soit ici
rue de Solferino et dans les
préparations à travers toute la France
une mobilisation qui sera très
importante nous ont dit les responsables
du parti socialiste merci beaucoup
Michel allez vite vous mettre à l'abri
on va continuer notre petite balade
notre tour des quartiers généraux on
retrouve tout de suite Mathilde crier
avec le Front national Mathilde quelle
est l'ambiance autour de vous il y a
encore pas mal de monde à ce que je vois
ça danse ah il y a pas mal de monde et
l'ambiance est à la fête ici la salle
s'est transformée en dance Flor où
Marine Le Pen a elle aussi fait quelques
pas de danse il faut dire que le Paris
est doublement réussi ce soir
puisqueavec ce score historique qui
dépasse celui de Jean-Marie Le Pen en
2002 elle est désormais la trè femme de
cette élection la candidate FN qui est
montée à la tribune vers 21h pour
affirmer que l'extrême droite était la
seule opposition à la gauche rien
dit-elle ne sera plus jamais comme avant
ce soir des milliers de Français sont
entrés en résistance continuons le
combat a-t-elle lancé à ses électeurs
avant d'entonner la Marseillaise quant
au choix des alliances à sa consigne de
vote elle le réserve au traditionnel
défilé du 1er mai merci beaucoup
Mathilde alors on va voir celui qui
n'est pas le trè homme en tous les cas
supporters ce soirin les militants les
électeurs du Front de Gauche place
stalingrade à Paris où il pleut
également évidemment et c'est
Pierre-Henri jargon sur place avec
Pierre Laurent je ne sais pas si on
ginche du côté de la place non gincher
c'est pas le mot que j'emploiris il y
avait du soleil tout à l'heure au début
de cette réunion euh de premier tour au
fond de gauche place à Lig grrade il y a
la pluie ce soir avec des militants qui
sont partis avec peut-être un Arger goû
d'amertou dans leur bouche en effet tout
le monde le sait maintenant Jean-Luc
menchon n'a peut-être pas réussi ce
qu'il espérait au cours de cette soirée
à savoir arriver 3e à ce premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle Pierre Laurent
est à mes côtés merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous secrétaire national du Parti
communiste vous partageriez cette
amertume des militants non je crois
qu'il y a deux choses dans le résultat
de ce soir d'abord le Front de Gauche
fait une éruption remarquée sur la scène
politique c'est la première élection
présidentielle où nous nous présentions
avec le Front de gauche et nous sommes
ce soir un des acteurs majeurs de la vie
politique et un des acteurs
incontournables de la gauche et de la
victoire contre Nicolas Sarkozi dans 15
jours maintenant effectivement il y a un
score du Front national qui nous
inquiète et d'ailleurs nous sommes fiers
ce soir d'avoir été de ceux qui alertion
qui mettions en garde contre cette
possible situation et nous avons engagé
un combat qu'il faut évidemment
amplifier poursuivre parce que on voit
VO bien que nous ne sommes pas
totalement parvenus à nos objectifs mais
beaucoup de gens ont des comptes à
rendre et singulièrement la droite qui
elle a alimenté ce discours pendant que
nous nous le combattions on a entendu
Jean-Luc Mélanchon s'exprimer ce soir
placealingrade il a appelé à voter
contre Nicolas Sarkozi sans à aucun
moment citer le nom de François Hollande
est-ce que vous-même vous appelez
clairement à voter François Hollande au
deuxè tour non mais vous vous savez on
fait une polémique de rien du tout il
reste deux candidats à l'élection
présidentielle euh quand on dit battre
Nicolas Sarkozi ça veut dire que nous
allons utiliser le bulletin François
Hollande euh pour le battre c'est très
clair et nous allons le faire d'ailleurs
en continuant à porter les idées que
nous avons défendu au premier tour le
Front de Gauche ne renonce pas à ces
idées c'est au contraire avec toutes ces
idées qu'il va mettre fièrement le
bulletin François Hollande pour battre
Nicolas Sarkozi dans euh dans les urnes
euh dans 15 jours alors on a entendu
également Jean-Luc Mélenchon appelé à
s'organiser massivement pour le 1er mai
c'est-à-dire euh continuer j'allais dire
la lutte dans la rue cette fois est-ce
que ce n'est pas également pour faire
pression toujours à côté de ou contre
François Hollande mais mais la
mobilisation sociale a toujours fait
partie de nos convictions et ce et cela
va le rester effectivement notre
engagement ferme dans la campagne de 2e
tour il va de paire avec le fait que
nous allons continuer à porter haut nos
exigences sociales parce que nous les
croyons nécessaires à une réussite d'une
politique de gauche c'est ce que nous
avons dit dans la campagne de premier
tour c'est ce que nous allons continuer
à à dire le Front de Gauche va rester
lui-même avec ses idées et ses valeurs
tout en en s'engageant dans cette
campagne de 2e tour le Front de gauche
devrait selon vous se transformer en un
en une nouvelle force de gauche
aujourd'hui non mais écoutez ce qui a
fait la force du Front de Gauche
précisément c'est d'être une
construction pluraliste qui rassemble
des partis différents des gens qui sont
venus nous rejoindre sans être être
membre d'une de ces organisations donc
cette forme là un front unitaire elle a
fait la preuve de son efficacité c'est
comme ça que nous allons continuuer
voilà ne rien lâcher c'est ce qu'on
entendait tout à l'heure ici place
lingrade c'est un petit peu le le mod
d'ordre pour vous jusqu'au 6 mai bien
sûr bien sûr bien sûr ne rien lâcher et
je crois que les militants ce soir
étaient lucide sur la situation et le
travail qui restait à faire mais
extrêmement combatif et je peux vous
dire que c'est le climat qui règne en ce
moment au Front de Gauche merci beaucoup
pierrelaurent d'avoir été avec nous ce
soir sous la pluie place
stalingrade merci beaucoup au courageux
qui travaill sous la pluie place
stalingrade est avec nous toujours sur
ce plateau Jean-Daniel levvi merci
d'être toujours fidèle au poste avec
vous j'aimerais qu'on revienne sur vos
derniers chiffres avec un écart qui se
resserre entre François Hollande et
Nicolas Sarkozi selon votre étude
l'étude Louis Harris 29 27,1 oui pass
étude har interactive effectivement
qu'on a mené avec vio. M6 et qui montre
effectivement qu'aujourd'hui il y a qu'à
cette heurelà 29 % en faveur de François
Hollande 27,1 en faveur de de Nicolas
Sarkozi quoi qu'il en soit il semble
avérer que François Hollande arrive
devant Nicolas Sarkozi on sait qu'il
avait fait le président sortant une
volonté et une ambition d'arriver en
tête de faire en sorte qu' est un écart
qui soit un écart important avec
François Hollande cette Paris
aujourd'hui apparaît comme étant un
Paris qui n'a pas été atteint et le choc
psychologique était attendu à savoir
peut-être une faible participation
doublée d'un écart important en faveur h
auourdui n pas plus tout à l'heure vous
disiez la ma prudence de sondeur
m'interdit de dire que c'est plié que
les jeux sont faits leur avance il est
22h52 les résultats s'affine qu'est-ce
que vous dites franchement vous là
maintenppelle le chiffre d'abord hein
peut-être du second tour alors vous êtes
touours la projection en tout cas de
l'IPSOS cette fois 54 46 qu'est-ce que
vous dit oui on estu près on est sur les
mêmes sur les mêm sur les même zoau et
ça correspond d'ailleurs au point près
aux différentes enquêtes qui qui avaient
été réalisé en toute fin de semaine
également il av satisfaction des surs ce
soir satisfaction cherchez des arguments
pour ceux qui vous critiquent là vous en
avez un on verra satisfaction on la
verra notamment lorsqu'il y aura eu le
le deuxième tour quoi qu'il en soit ce
qui est absolument certain et c'est un
petit peu ce qu'on disit tout à l'heure
c'est que s'il y a pas de surprise dans
le fait qu'il y ait et Nicolas Sarkozi
et François Hollande qui soit élu la
surprise ce soir c'est le score de
Marine Le Pen c'est et la participation
par qu'en fait beaucoup de Français et
beaucoup d'observateurs avaient dit
cette campagne ennuie les Français on a
des acteurs qui sont pas forcément les
mêm acteurs avec la même classe ou en
tout cas avec la même envie que ceux qui
pouvaient être Segolen Royal d'un côté
Nicolas Sarkozi de l'autre et donc les
Français vont bouder cette élection ça
n'a pas été le cas le deuxième aspect
c'est de toute façon les enjeux ne les
intéressent pas parce qu'on est dans un
climat global où on nous parle de la
dette où on nous parle de la crise où il
n'y a pas de joie ou de perspectives qui
sont offertes et donc dans ce contexte
là les Français vont pas aller voter ils
sont allés voter ils sont allés voter
assez massivement h alors donc voilà
vous êtes assez catégorique sur le score
du second tour néanmoins d'ici là avant
le 6 mai il va y avoir un un match
télévisé un seul hein il y aura pas
trois débats et là on désigne souvent
les médias peut-être les sondeurs aussi
he la presse un vainqueur et un vaincu
est-ce que là ça peut peser est-ce que
Nicolas Sarkozi en d'autres termes peut
renverser la table ou alors peut-être
que s'il renverse la table ça sera avant
le match ou en tout cas avant la
confrontation le 2 mai si je me trompe
pas et que cette confrontation entre
François Hollande et Nicolas Sarkozi
serait un peu l'aboutissement d'une
campagne qui aurait été amenée on sait
qu' général alors qu'est-ce qu'il
pourrait faire a bien vu aujourd'hui que
Nicolas Sarkozy avait entamé une
campagne qui était une campagne qui
appelait pour parti les électeurs du
Front national à le rejoindre très très
rapidement on a vu les thématiques de
campagne qui étaent des thématiques
autour des frontières autour de
l'identité autour de valeurs qui sont
des valeurs dont on sait que une partie
des électeurs du Front national sont
assez sensibles et dans ce contexte- là
peut-être que le déma peut amener
François Hollande à revenir un peu dans
ses retranchements quoi qu'il en soit il
y a aujourd'hui une vraie difficulté
pour Nicolas Sarkozi c'est une
difficulté inverse c'est que François
Hollande n'fferit pas c'est que les
majeure partie des Français savent que
François Hollande ou a la pression que
François Hollande peut être le prochain
président de la répuique est-ce que ça
les amène aujourd'hui à se mobiliser en
contre soit dans le casre du premier
tour soit dans le casre du deuxème tour
ça n'a pas été le cas donc il y a une
vraie un vrai enjeu de la part de
Nicolas Sarkozi de faire en sorte que
l'image de François Holland soit une
image qui soit modifiée et donc qu'il y
ait la perception de la part des
Français que indépendamment de la
politique qui serait motée par par
Nicolas Sarkozi celle qui éventuellement
pourrait être menée par fr si jamais il
était demain président de la répuique
n'irait pas dans le sens ser
pas on voit bien qu'il y a encore plein
d'interrogations de questions qui
restent en suspens ce soir on ne sait
toujours pas ce que va faire François
Baayou on ne sait pas réellement ce que
va dire Marine Le Pen le 1er mai
prochain on ne sait pas non plus comment
va se recomposer la droite car on voit
bien qu'il va y avoir nécessairement
recomposition tout ça ça fait beaucoup
d'incertitude ça va se dénouer très vite
vous pensez dans les tout prochains
jours moi d'abord ce que je voudrais
dire c'est qu'on n'est pas propriétaire
de ces électeurs et c'est vrai que les
leaders ne pèse pas nécessairement sur
le comportement électoral je crois que
ce qui était important de regarder ce
soir on l'a dit au début de l'émission
C'est le rapport de force droite gauche
je crois que dans toutes les études on
voit que je me retourne vers Danel on
voit que la gauche est au-delà de 43
entre 43 et 44 % vous avez la projection
qui plutôt donc favorable à une élection
de François Hollande donc je pense pas
que la manière dont vont se prononcer
les
and déterminante il y a une vraie
autonomie des citoyens sur quel thème
selon vous va se cristalliser cette
campagne de deè tour en quoi sera-t-elle
fondamentalement différente de la
campagne du premier tour à part le fait
évidemment qu'on a plus que deux
candidats suffisait d'écouter Nicolas
Sarkozi et François Hollande je crois
qu'ils ont donné immédiatement le cap
franç François Hollande tient la ligne
qu'il tient depuis le début y compris
dans la primaire c'est ce thème du
rassemblement parce que son calcul
électoral depuis le début c'est que les
Français ne voulaient pas qu'on rajoute
aoute du stress à la crise et qui
voulait changer de président qui avait
géré en opposant les Français Nicolas
Sarkozi lui n'a pas d'autre choix qu'à
d'aller chercher les voies du Front
national donc il va radicaliser son
discours sur la droite et on l'a entendu
dès son discours ce soir alors ben janar
quand est-ce que vous avez vous annoncé
que François Hollande serait vainqueur
de cette présidentielle en 2012 en
quelné année vous l'z annoncé je l'ai
annoncé sur la chaîne parlementaire en
septembre 2010 en septembre 2010 et
depuis franchement depuis septembre 2010
jusqu'à jusqu'à ce soir estce moi j'ai
un témoin là puisque je discute beaucoup
avec jean-diel je n'ai jamais changé
d'avis parce que j'ai une analyse qui
est pas trop sur les campagnes
électorales je pense qu'une une élection
présidentielle se joue sur avec trois
leviers ouais le premier c'est
l'aboutissement d'une construction
politique avec un parti dominant comme
une forme pyramidal et le Parti
socialiste est devenu dominant dans la
société politique française comme
l'avait été le RPR dans les années 80
comme l'avait été le Parti socialiste au
début des années 80 ensuite je pense
qu'il y a un thème dominant une
espècez-moi l'expression anglaise
mainstream un courant porteur je crois
que le rassemblement était le courant
porteur et c'était ce qu'avait choisi
comme thème François Hollande dès le
c'était l'homme de la synthèse et le
dernier point c'est la présidentialité
l'élection alors Nicolas Sarkozi jouait
sur son image en politique étrangère
mais les élections en France pas plus
d'ailleurs qu'aux États-Unis ou ailleurs
ne se jouent sur la politique étr angère
mais sur la politique intérieure or
chaque fois qu'on a sondé sur la
présidentialité sur les questions
essentielles qui préoccupent les
Français c'est-à-dire le chômage la
crise économique et le pouvoir d'achat
c'était toujours François Hollande qui
sortait en tête on souviendra he quand
même
de c'était votre pronostic et c'était
surtout vos trois variables lourdes pour
expliquer qu'un candidat gagne ou non
vous citiez François justement on va
réentendre un moment fort de son
intervention c'était tout à l'heure aux
environs de 21h àul on
l'écoute le second fait majeur du
scrutin et il est sans
appel c'est que le premier tour
représente une sanction du quinquena qui
s'achève et un désaveux du candidat
sortant dont le discours tout au long de
ces derniers mois a fait le jeu de
l'extrême droite voilà donc et puis on a
entendu également ce soir le s triomphal
il faut le dire de Marine Le Pen je ne
sais pas si aurait tenu un discours
différent sil avait été qualifié pour le
second tour den non mais c'est vrai vous
avez vu quand même bien sûr il faut dire
qu'elle réalise un score vraiment
historique on va voir en nom on va voir
en nombre de suffrages vous allez voir
qu'elle va faire sans doute plus de voix
que Jacques Chirac au premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle de 95ut
pronosti de on bien tenu on écoute
justement un extrait de ce discours qui
a tenu la présidente du Front national
quoi qu'il puisse
arriver dans les 15 jours à
venir la bataille de France ne fait que
commencer chers amis
français rien ne sera plus jamais comme
avant
maintenant face à un président sortant à
la tête d'un parti considérablement
affaibli
nous sommes désormais la seule et
véritable opposition à la gauche ultr
libéral l'acist et
libertaire voilà et on l'a dit c'est
évidemment l'une des principales
informations finalement de cette soirée
électorale du premier tour c'est le
score de Marine Le Pen une fois qu'on a
salué la performance c'est interpellant
aussi sur ce que signifie ce contexte
politique français c'est très alarmant à
plein d'égard sur ce qu'est la politique
aujourd'hui Jean-Daniel Levi en tout cas
ben c'est le signe qu'il y a un certain
nombre de thématiques qui ont été
abordées par Marine la Pen qui ont
trouvé une forme d'écho de la part des
Français en gros il y a deux piliers il
y a un pilier autour de l'immigration et
la sécurité qui sont des thématiques
traditionnelles porteurs de la part du
Front national il y a également une
autre thématique qui est une thématique
autour d'une dimension sociale ou une
dimension de justice pour parti qui
aujourd'hui anime une partie d'un
électorat en faveur de Marine Le Pen il
y a quelques jours on a parlé avec force
du vote des jeunes ou du vote des
catégories populaires en FA du Front
national semblant un petit peu découvrir
qu'il pouvait y avoir de la part de la
jeunesse un vote à l'extrême droite ça
n'est pas une nouveauté mais il s'agit
aujourd'hui d'une exacerbation de leur
part une partie de la jeunesse
aujourd'hui notamment de ceux qui
rencontent des difficultés à pouvoir
s'insérer sur le milieu du travail
accordent avec force leur suffrage en
faveur de Marine Le Pen pas forcément en
ayant le sentiment de procéder à un acte
qui apparaîtrait comme étant
transgressif c'està-dire que il n'y a
pas la perception d'être à la limite de
ce qui apparaît comme étant dissible
mais il y a la perception que au moins
moins elle est capable de pouvoir
désigner et dire les difficultés d'une
partie des Français Denis je parle
beaucoup de de ce compris l'immigration
hein compris l'immigration jeun le
revendique paraî-il même si un sondage
publi par le monde a été contesté
puisque il plaçait Marine Le Pen en tête
chez les 18 25 ans sauf que le panel
n'était que de 200 personnes hein on le
rappelle den beaucoup de de socialistes
disent ce soir dans ce contexte là
effectivement François Hollande peut
s'estimer voilà confiance sur le deuxè
Tour mais dans ce contexte là avec un
Front national à ce niveaulà avecoron
représenter les extrêmes dans cette
élection quel contexte difficile pour un
premier mandat présidentiel on s'attend
notamment à ce qu'il n'y ait pas d'état
de grâce est-ce que vous redoutez
effectivement pour François Hollande ce
début de quinena dans ce contexte là je
crois pas d'ailleurs que c'est un homme
qui attend d'un état de grâce et
difficile pleinement conscience et puis
c'est difficile d'imaginer un état de
grâce avec la conjoncture économique que
nous que nous connaissons la deuxième
chose c'est qu'on va avoir des élections
législatives et le score du Front
National et de Marine Le Pen est très
important sans doute va va-t-il conduire
à une explosion de l'UMP dans les
élections législatives puisqu'on risque
d'avoir beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de de
tri de triangulaire donc on va avoir une
Assemblée nationale sans doute très
étrange comment va s'exprimer le Front
national par la suite comment et puis a
une autre question c'est quand même
fondamental qu'on doit se poser
aujourd'hui comment s'est créé cette
situation qui l'a créé le paradoxe de
Nicolas Sarkozi c'est que c'était
l'homme qui avait réduit de moitié le le
Front National et c'est l'homme qui
aujourd'hui se retrouve avec
en utilisant les mêmes thématiques
parement les mêmes thématiques et c'est
dans sans doute l'arroseur arrosé a dit
quelqu'un tout à l'heure sur ce plateau
merci s l'amplifie au cours de cette
campagne de second tour voilà merci
Émilie on va donner la place on va
laisser la place dans un instant à Sonia
mabrou et à pour la poursuite de cette
soirée avec d'autres invités très
nombreux qui vont se succéder ici la
nuit sera encore longue sur les chaînes
parlementaires merci en tout cas de nous
avoir suivi à très vite Michel Merci à
VOUS 15 jours absolument et pour
l'instant on va reprendre un petit peu
les éléments clés de cette soirée qu'on
vient de rappeler mais plus en détail
avec des illustrations avec Pierre bon
Joseph et ensuite donc Sonia mabrou et
puis Arnaud
Arduin premier chiffre pour ce premier
tour de l'élection présidentielle 2012
François Hollande en tête avec 28,4 %
suivi bien sûr de Nicolas Sarkozi
25,5 % les autres tris estimations
Michel voilà pour la suite donc le 3è
homme la trème femme Marine Le Pen donc
avec ce score impressionnant de 20 %
celui qu'elle espérait mais que n'avait
prédit aucun institut manifestement ces
derniers jours et Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui
visait beaucoup plus obtient donc 11,7 %
François baayrou n'arrive pas à un
chiffre à deux chiffres un score à 8,5 %
derrière nous vous entendez on va gagner
on va gagner mais rien n'est fait Jean
rien n fait le vote maintenant c'est le
qu' faut réussir mais ce qui est sûr
c'est qu'en plaçant en tête François
Hollande à l'occasion d'une élection
présidentielle pour le président sortant
à toutes les élections présidentielles
le président sortant est arrivé en tête
et là il est Dee et puis enfin l'écart
entre Nicolas Sarkozi et François
Hollande on va voir s'il est tr points
ou de de points après une campagne de
premier tour c'était 9 contre avec une
agressivité très très forte c'est je
crois un très bon résultat pour Nicolas
sarzi d'avoir résisté à ce point alors
que dans beaucoup d'autres pays
européens on a vu que les gouvernements
ou les pouvoirs en place étaient
déstabilisés quand on totalise toutes
les voix de gauche on est à 42 et dem%
comme en 2007 et ceci est dû au fait que
le score merfique annoncé à Monsieur
Mélenchon n'a pas été au rendez-vous 2
erreur des sondages 3è erreur on n pas
vu la poussée de l'extrême droite à 20 %
elle est très forte elle s'explique sans
doute par un votre protestataire face à
la
crise
quoi qu'il puisse
arriver dans les 15 jours à
venir la bataille de France ne fait que
commencer ne sera plus jamais comme
avant car face à tout le système coalisé
à coup de mensonge et de faux
sondages nous tous ensemble avons fait
exploser le monopole des deux parties de
la banque de la
finance des
multinationales du renoncement et de
l'abandon
nous avons porté plus haut que jamais
les idées nationales nous imposerons le
grand changement que vous attendez car
tous unis tous
rassemblés tout est possible
maintenant le score du Front national
est une tâche
indélébile sur les valeurs de notre
démocratie une menace pour la République
un avertissement que chaque responsable
politique doit
entendre je veux dire à cell et ceux qui
se sont laissés abuser par le Front
national qu'il se trompe de
colère le total des voir des droites
dans toutes leurs composantes reculent
par rapport à
mais l'extrême droite est à haut
niveau nous avons donc eu
raison de concentrer notre
campagne sur l'analyse et la critique
radicale des propositions de l'extrême
droite nous avons eu raison de le faire
et si nous ne l'avions pas fait
peut-être le résultat ce soir seril
encore plus
alarmant il
est alors c'est le moment pour moi de
dire combien nous nous sommes sentis
seuls à certain moment dans cette
bataille je vous appelle à vous
retrouver le 6 mai sans rien demander en
échange le Sim pour battre Sarkozy tous
les votes doivent être respectés parce
qu'ils sont tous l'expression de notre
nation ce soir rien n'est joué enfin en
ces temps difficiles il faut un chef
d'État peu d'hommes ont été aussi
injustement attaqués que Nicolas Sarkozy
mais personne ne peut douter de sa
détermination et de son
courage français française le 6 mai vous
allez
décider faites-le pour l'idéal
républicain que nous avons en partage
non mais faites-le pour la France pour
son avenir pour celui de vos enfants
faites-le autour du président de la
République je pense que je pense qu'elle
ira jusqu'à 21 parce que ça ce sont les
résultats de Monsieur Guéant ils sont
toujours audessous de la vérité à
quelques heures des élection est-ce que
elle fait un score plus important encore
que vous en 2002 est-ce que vous avez
l'impression qu'elle vous éclipse pas du
tout un relayeur marine je lui ai passé
le bâton elle court elle court plus vite
tant mieux l'extrême droite à 20 % en
France en 2012 c'est la gravité de la
crise étalée devant tous les yeux crise
du chômage crise économique crise
sociale crise morale et ces crises
s'additionnent alors bien sûr notre
score est au-dessous de nos attentes
mais ce que nous avions vu et
diagnostiqué de l'état du pays de l'état
réel du pays et là plus impressionnant
que jamais je vais m'adresser aux deux
candidats sélectionnés pour le deème
tour je vais leur dire ce qui est pour
nous l'essentiel en terme de valeur en
terme d'action à conduire j'écouterai
dans les jours qui viennent leurs
réponsse et je prendrai mes
responsabilité non non non je n'ai pas
eu Franois Hollande au téléphone je le
laisse se concentr
mais je vais l'écouter avec plaisir et
en plus du siège du PS il se dirige donc
vers son
cortège à tout à l'heure et il va donc
prononcer son allocution dans ce gymnase
du centre de Thul où nous nous rendons
nous aussi François Holland donc il se
rend dans son gymnase à Thul on regarde
voilà il a une petite fille qui lui
offre des fleurs François Hollande va
dans le gymnase àul présent vous devez
les entendre voilà François Hollande qui
ses partisans et qui devrait maintenant
faire une déclaration assez courte
d'environ 5 minutes je suis ce soir en
tête du prier
tour je veux remercier chaleureusement
les électrices et les électeurs qui par
leur suffrage m'ont placé dans cette
position qui m'honore et m'oblige la
plus forte pour l'emporter second fait
majeur du
scrutin et il est sans
appel c'est que le premier tour
représente une sanction du quinquena qui
s'achève et un désaveux du candidat
sortant dont le discours tout au long de
ces derniers mois a fait le jeu de
l'extrême droite pendant tous ces jours
qui me sépareront du second tour je
continuerai à rencontrer les Français à
les mobiliser et leur dire la fierté qui
est la mienne de conduire cette campagne
et qui sera s'ils en décid la fierté de
conduire le pays comme président de la
République merci on voit des images de
la voiture de Nicolas
sarkozyes chers
compatriotes avec une participation
supérieure à
80% les
Français ont fait un acte de civisme et
en agissant ainsi ils ont démenti toutes
les prédictions et déjouer tous les
pronostics je sais que dans ce monde qui
bouge si vite le souci de nos
compatriotes de préserver leur mode de
vie et la question centrale de cette
élection les deux
candidats deux candidats désignés pour
le second tour par les Français on
maintenant un devoir de vérité et un
devoir de courage nul n'aura le droit de
se dérober ces deux semaines qui
viennent doivent permettre à chacun
d'entre vous de faire un choix dans la
clarté tout doit être débattu sans
hypocrisie sans esquive sans faufuir
c'est pourquoi je propose que trois
débats soient
organis et j'appelle
maintenant tous les Français qui mettent
l'amour de la patrie au-dessus de toute
considération partisane ou de tout
intérêt particulier à s'unir et à me
rejoindre et viv la
France